SOME IN LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING OF APRIL
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DUE
TO THE CONTINUED STATE
HOMEOWNER RIPRAP FAXING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDINGS WERE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCHING PARTICIPATE
IN THE- HEARING ROOM IN PERSON.
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRED THE MASTERY
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
BETWEEN TANK. BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE- OF THE PUBLIC BUT OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIFYING WITH HERE IN
THE ROOM OR- AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU- WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM- THEY WERE HERE AND
ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN WE CAN
ONLY. AGAIN ACCOMMODATING A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT. OF STAFF ON
THE NUMBER THE PUBLIC CAN BE
YES WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
THE PUBLIC TO ENSURE ONLY THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC THE ROOM OF LIKE
TESTIFYING THE BILL. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND LASSEN OPPOSED
TO MAKE FUN OF THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC TO
NOT. TOUCH THE MICROPHONE- YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING RETURN
YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE FISCAL JUST SAYING.
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING. ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
WE DO HAVE REMOTE TEST STATE
REMOTE TEST STATION IN CAPITOL
PARK FOR DIALING WITNESSES- BUT
OVER OF IN IN CAPITOL PARK AS
WELL OUT IN THE FRONT ON THE L.
STREET SIDE WHERE I BELIEVE MY
SON- AND FOR DIALING WITNESSES
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. FOR CALLING IN TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK YOU STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE
ANTICIPATE A HIGH CALL VOLUME
TODAY. THE CALL NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN-
AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHICH IS A
L. B. R. A. L. B. R. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. AS
WELL AS ON THE TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING EMPLOYEES PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR
OPERATOR THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON-
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL. YOU'LL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE WILL NEED
TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. FOR HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
OF PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. THE TWO ZERO
NINE ONE AGAIN NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
ONE AND MY STAFF BE THERE TO
TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL BUT ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE ALSO
HAVE THEN EMAIL AN EMAIL
ADDRESS SET UP THAT YOU CAN USE
TO IT YOU MONSTER TESTIMONY THE
EMAIL IS. A L. B. R. DOT
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS BE OFF
BASE. AND SO AT THIS TIME MADAM
SECRETARY WE CAN TAKE WILL
PLEASED TO ESTABLISH KERR.
KALRA HERE FLORIDA YOUR THE
REINA GONZALEZ. JONES SAWYER
RADIUS TO SEATTLE HERE LORD
CORVUS THAT'LL START THANK YOU
SO MUCH I IS THE FIRST ITEM OF
BUSINESS TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES ARE MOTION ON THAT. THANK
YOU MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR
SECONDED BY MEMBERS SAY ART
THOUGH- AND IF WE CAN THERE
WILL CALL ON THAT PLEASE. KALRA
RIGHT FLORIDA REINA GONZALEZ HI
JONES SAWYER. YES SEATTLE FIVE
WARD. PHILADELPHIA ALL RIGHT SO
THOSE RULES ARE ADOPTED AND THE
FINAL ITEM BEFORE WE ARE IN A
CENTER IF- I MONEY USED TO I
UNDERSTAND WHY MY FIRST NAME
NEED TO BE CALLED OUT BECAUSE
THERE IS NOT A GONZALEZ NUMBER
HE HAS DONE THIS AS FAR AS SOME
LITTLE TURNOUT BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW
TO PROPERLY SAY MY NAME BECAUSE
OF ITS GONNA BE CALLED OUT THE
NINE I HEAR IT A LOT- AND IT'S
LA REINA THE RENT. THANK YOU.
FOR EVERYBODY HERE AND ALL OUR
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU. YES I
HAVE BEEN CORRECT ON MORE THAN
ONE OCCASION BY HOURS YOU KNOW
COLLEAGUES AND I DON'T MIND
BEING CORRECTED. AS SOMEONE
THAT HAS A NAME THAT I
OFTENTIMES HAVE TO QUIT.
BRIGITTE THAT- AND SO AT THIS
TIME IF- ADOPTING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE ARE THREE BILLS
ON CONSENT. TO BUY SOME RELAX.
A LACKEY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX
FIVE. AND ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THREE SEVEN. AND THEN A
COMMITTEE BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE. AND SO
FREAKIN ARM ALSO TAKE ROLL ON
THE ORIGINATION TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU SO
WE HVE A MOTION BY SUMMER
SEATTLE SECONDED BY SOME REWARD
I'VE WE CAN TAKE ROLE ON THE
SAME COUNTY PLEASE ALL RIGHT I
KALRA HI FLORA FLORA HI
GONZALEZ. SALAS JONES SAWYER
RADIUS SEATTLE FIVE SEATTLE I
WARD WARD ALL RIGHT. DR ALL
RIGHTS OF THE CAN COUNTY I HAVE
ADOPTED AND PASSED AND SO NOW
WE CAN GO IN FILE ORDER WE HAVE
AB SIX EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE IS HERE IN A TIMELY
FASHION- ON HER ITEM AND SO
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER IN COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE OUR STATE OF LATE LED
THE WAY AN AGGRESSIVE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS WHILE EXPANDING OUR
ECONOMY TO THE FIFTH LARGEST IN
THE WORLD. DESPITE THESE THIS
GREAT PROGRESS THERE'S MORE
MORE EVIDENCE SHOWING THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE NOT GOING TO
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE FUNDING
IS MOST NEEDED I JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT AUTHORED BY THE
STAFF FROM THE UCLA CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOUND
THE STRUCTURE OF OUR CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS IS SKEWED TO
BENEFIT THE MOST AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE. THIS
IS COMING EXPENSE OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
ABILITY AND RESOURCES TO ACCESS
X. EXISTING PROGRAMS INCENTIVES
PRODUCT MEANS ARE BEING LEFT
BEHIND BY THE WAYSIDE AS OUR
STATE ADDRESSES CLIMATE CHANGE
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY HELPS BRIDGE
THIS GAP BY IMPLEMENTING KEY
POLICIES RIMAC RECOMMENDED AND
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S RECENT
REPORT PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON
THE HIGH ROAD A JOBS AND
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR TWENTY
THIRTY. AB SIXTY WOULD REQUIRE
GIGI R. F. APPLICANTS TO USE
FAIR AND RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYEES
STANDARDS TO PROMOTE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS INCLUDES
PROCUREMENT PART POLICIES TO
MAKE SURE APPLICANTS ARE
CONTENT ARE CONTRACTING WITH
OTHER RESPONSIBLE ENTITIES AND
PREVAILING WAGE FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. THIS
BILL WOULD FURTHER PRIOR TO
PRIORITIZE APPLICANTS THAT
PARTNER WITH EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT TARGET RESIDENTS
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
TRIBAL AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAME REGION
OF THE PROJECT THESE PROVISIONS
WHICH ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS PROPOSED BY C.
W. D. B.'S HIGH ROAD REPORT
WILL PUT PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY
ON THE FRONT END OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS RATHER THAN
AS AN AFTERTHOUGHT. I
RESPECTFULLY QUESTION I. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO REMEMBER- AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE ANY A
WITNESS. WILL BE CAN GO. I'VE
WE NEED IS YOU SO I THINK IF
YOU EVER. FEEL IF THERE IS
ANYONE THAT'S- PRESENT. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
YEAH COME ON UP THE MICROPHONE
TO SIR TRYING TO TEST
MICROPHONE THINK IT'S ALREADY
MADE IT SHOULD BE READY TO GO.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MIKE WEST REPRESENTING THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF SO FAR ON THIS BILL.
WE'RE THANKFUL TO THE AUTHOR
INCLUDING LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
PROTECTING WORKERS PARTICULARLY
ON PREVAILING WAGE AND PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS- END UP HIGH
QUALITY JOBS. SO THAT
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
CAN GO TOWARDS A LIVING WAGE
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS. WE HAVE
SUGGESTED A NAME CHANGE. AWAY
FROM JUST TRANSITION AND- WITH
THAT MORE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE
THE FEEDBACK AND IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM. IN
SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE ANYONE OF
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
AND FINALLY- DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE FOR THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU TO SHOW SUPPORT FROM
THE PHONE ON A. B. SIX EIGHTY
MINUTE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD IT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE FORTY TWO FOUR
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M FORTY
TWO ARE YOU WANT ME. WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT. NINE
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY. DO YOU NEED
BESIDES THE SOMETHING THINGS
YES. THIRTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BOB HERTZBERG I DON'T
KNOW MY MEDICAL TO THE- YEAH
BUT I AM SICK SIX BILLION IS
OPEN. I'M ACTION BY AB TWO NOT
THIS ONE OKAY THANK YOU VERY
PROP AT THAT TIME. FIND SEVENTY
FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE OF OPEN. SO.
HI MY NAME IS LANA HI MY NAME
IS LEVEL OF THIS I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES AND I AM WITH EAGLE
COUNTY WAS WOMEN'S CENTER I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY SIX TO EIGHT. THANK YOU.
I'M YEP EVEN IF WE CAN MAKE
CLEAR- HONEST MODERATOR THEY
WERE HERE FOR OUR ITEMS AB SIX
EIGHTY ANOTHER FIVE FOLKS LINED
UP FOR DIFFERENT ITEMS BUT- IF
THERE ARE FOLKS CERTAINLY. HOPE
CLEARLY WITH RIGHT NOW ON THE
PHONES BUT WE ARE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX EIGHT
ZERO. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
EIGHT ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. A FEW CUBA UP TO
SPEAK ON ANOTHER BILL PLEASE
REPEAT ONE THEN ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. ORDER ONLINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR. THREE FOUR HAS
REMOVED HIMSELF. SEVENTY FIVE
DO YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON SIX
EIGHTY. FIND SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO BERMAN BONTA
WATERLINE FORTY SIX FORCE FOR
SIX IS CLOSED. ONE FOR FINAL
LINE IN Q. LINE FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY SHARE
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX EIGHTY AT
THIS TIME. I'M LINE FIFTY FIVE
BUT I'M FOR AB SIX TO EIGHT.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU- AND THEN WE CAN MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION WE DO OT HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. IN
THE ROOM THE OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANYONE RAISING THEIR HAND-
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AND FINALLY ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
SIX EIGHTY. QS STATED IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE OPPOSITION TO AB
SIX EIGHT ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
CAN ONE ZERO THIS YEAR
OPPOSITION TO A. B. SIX EIGHT
ZERO. YOU HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
MY NUMBER
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS RICHARD MARCUSSEN FOR
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO A. B. SIX EIGHTY.
THE MEASURE REQUIRES THAT FOR
CERTAIN GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND PROJECTS OF A
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE- THAT
THE PROJECT IS REQUIRED TO HAVE
A COMMUNITY WORKFORCE AGREEMENT
HOWEVER. SB SIX EIGHTY DEFINES
A COMMITTEE WORKFORCE AGREEMENT
AS A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
HISTORICALLY PLA'S INCLUDE
DISCRIMINATORY HIRING PRACTICES
AND CAN INCREASE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS BY UPWARDS OF TWENTY
PERCENT. WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE BECAUSE OF THIS
REQUIREMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER. FULLER IN THE
PROPOSITION. NO FOR THE LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU AND AS A REMINDER TO FOLKS
ON THE LINE NUMBER TO CALL IN
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE SUPPORTING OR
OPPOSING STARS ARE PRESENTATION
PLEASE. OKAY AND SO LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. NOT
ON A MOTION A SECOND- ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON IT.
YES SANDRA WARD THANK YOU
OFFER- FOR BRIEFING AFFORDING
ANYTIME WE ARE USING PUBLIC
FUNDS PARTICULARLY THE GROWING
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
TO BE ABLE TO PUT OUT FOR
PUBLIC PROJECTS- TRYING TO LOOK
FOR OTHER COMMUNITY BENEFITS IS
ALWAYS A WISE MOVE SO THANK YOU
FOR TARGETING THOSE THAT THINK
IT'LL HAVE MULTIPLE BENEFITS
FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND IN THE
FORM OF- BETTER LABOR STANDARDS.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE- I THINK THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS FOR- TO
FOLLOW UP ON A SUMMER COMMENTS
YOU KNOW AS WE'RE DOING THIS
GREETING OF OUR ECONOMY IT MUST
BE WE MUST CREATE JOBS ARE GOOD
HIGH QUALITY JOBS WITH EQUITY
IN MIND SO I APPRECIATE YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- WE DO
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION DO PASSED
OF NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
WANT TO- TO THE SUPPORT I WE DO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE NAME
CHANGE AND WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT SO WHAT IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS. WITH OTHER BUCKLEY A
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER APPROVED
THE NAME CHANGE ALL RIGHT. WE
WILL. THANK ALL RIGHT ME- HAVE
ROLL CALL ON AB SIXTY KALRA
KALRA HI FLORA. LARA NOT VOTING
IN. AND I JONES SAWYER YES HI
RES I SEE ARE NOW C. R. NO.
WARD HI APPROVALS THOSE OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. PEOPLE
EXCITED THIS ONE AB SIX EIGHT
RIGHT. WE HAVE. FULL OF THE AS
A MEMBER GARCIA SB SIX EIGHT.
OKAY YOU'RE MOST FROM SOME
GONZALEZ. YOUR SECOND. AND THE
SECOND WAS AREAS OKAY. WELL OF
BE BRIEF AB SIX TO EIGHT WOULD
LINE THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN WHILE
EXPANDING AND RENEWING THE-
INITIATIVE BY SYSTEM
INDIVIDUALS IN OBTAINING THE
FORMER PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT
SERVICES NECESSARY TO SECURE
MEANINGFUL AND STABLE CAREERS.
LEVERAGE MULTIPLE SERVICES TO
MEET WORKERS INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
AND REACH PEOPLE FACE SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. IT'S A
CONTINUATION OF WORK THE TO
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WITH THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION ALSO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT SUPPORTED. OVER A
HUNDRED PROPOSALS TO HELP OUT
WITH THE WORK FORCE NEEDS OF
OUR STATE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES BY PHONE-
BOB LANTER AND SHEENA PAUL. AND
SO I MISS MODERATOR IF WE HAVE%
THEM LINED UP WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND START WITH THE WITNESSES
AND- THE TOTAL TIME IS FIVE
MINUTES. HOWEVER FOUR MINUTES
SORRY FOR MINUTES- THE SPLIT UP
ANYWAY IT WE'VE ENCOURAGED HIM
TO KEEP IT. SHORT AND SWEET
OKAY THANK YOU THE- KEEP THE
LINE TO THOSE WITNESSES ARE
OPEN THEY MAY BEGIN. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
MORNING- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS BOB LANTER LACKING OF
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER C. OUT- FOR
CARRYING THIS VITAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
UNDER- ASSEMBLY MAN CUSTANCE
LEADERSHIP PASSED THE BREAKING
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE. SPECIFICALLY CAN
IMPROVE ACCESS TO THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE STATE WAS
MAKING ANCHOR TECHNICAL
EDUCATION THE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY IS THAT THERE ARE
SIZEABLE GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS
UNABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND WERE IN DANGER
OF LEAVING BEHIND COMMUNITIES
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY DISFRANCHISED. AND
PRECLUDED FROM OPPORTUNITY AND
CAREER PATHWAYS WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE FUNDED BREAKING
BARRIERS IT WAS CLEAR THAT THE
NEED BUT EXTENT OF AN URGENT
TEN POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
WAS ULTIMATELY RELEASED TO FIND
TWENTY THREE PROPOSALS WHILE
THE STATE RECEIVED OVER. ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
APPLICATIONS. EVEN BEFORE KOBE.
THE NEED TO FIND AT FOR JOBS
AND SUPPORT SERVICES WITH
OBVIOUS WE WERE ALL WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE LEFT BEHIND
WOULD NOT FALL FURTHER BACK.
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT IT
DESIGNED TO IMPROVE ON THE
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY OF THE
BREAKING BARRIERS PROGRAM BOTH
IN GEOGRAPHY AND PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS. IT STREAMLINED
THE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
ALLOWS FOR MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION CAN APPLY LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES AND A
DEDICATED WORK HISTORY. WITH
THE INDIVIDUALS BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT WITH INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY. ACCORDING TO
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA ABOUT FOUR IN TEN OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL LIVING
IN OR NEAR POVERTY. 78% OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE LIVING IN
FAMILIES WITH AT LEAST ONE
WORKING ADULT MAJOR MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE WORKING FULL TIME.
AND THAT'S JUST UNACCEPTABLE.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT IS A CRITICAL
TOOL TO OUR STATE AND PROVIDING
PATHWAYS TO FAMILY SUSTAINING
WAGES IN QUALITY JOBS AND NOW
MORE THAN EVER IS NEEDED TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK CURRENT I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- WE ALSO HAVE WITH US YOU
KNOW PAUL ON THE PHONE. YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TWENTY
MACHINE OF CALL AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER WE ARE
A PROUD CO SPONSOR EIGHTY SIX
TO EIGHT WHICH HELPS REMOVE
BARRIERS TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMET PROGRAMS. FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND INVEST
IN WORKFORCE PROGRAMMING THAT
IS RESPONSIVE TO THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND REGIONS IN OUR
STATE. WE KNOW THAT IMMIGRANT
BLACK LATIN AT ASIAN FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WERE
ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
ACCESSING JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS
TO LET THEM OUT OF WORKING
POVERTY BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THE JOB
GAINS NECESSARY BIRTHDATE TO
RECOVER AND PRIVATE THE WHOLE.
FOR EXAMPLE AT THE PEAK OF THE
PANDEMIC THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
CALIFORNIANS THE COLOR AND
WHILE JOB GAINS HAVE REDUCED
UNEMPLOYMENT RESPOND 230% AND
BLACK CALIFORNIANS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE YET. COULD BE
ANY SIGNIFICANT JOB GAINS. NOW
FIRST HAS THE- TO MAKE
WORKFORCE OF PRO A THE STATE
STRONGER. AND MORE EQUITABLE
IMPROVING AND EXPANDING THE
BREAKING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE. WHEN IT SHOULD HAVE
CAME FROM A SHARED DESIRE
BETWEEN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
WORKFORCE BOARDS. ENHANCE
COLLABORATION AND EFFECTIVELY
THER ECONOMICALLY DISPLACED
COMMUNITIES WE'VE ALSO HEARD
THE NEED DIRECTLY FROM LOW
INCOME IMMIGRANT WORKERS. IN A
SURVEY SEVENTY FIVE DAY LABOR
WORKERS HE THOUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA. 81% THAT JOB
TRAINING WOULD HELP THEM OBTAIN
EMPLOYMENT OR DANCE
PROFESSIONALLY. IT IS CLEAR
THAT WORKERS WANT TO BE ABLE TO
IMPROVE THEIR SKILLS. EIGHTY
SIX TO EIGHT WILL ALLOW CBO
TRIGGERING GROUND BREAKING WORK
SUCH AS VOCATIONAL ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNING. AND TRAINING
HEALTH WORKERS AN AREA FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO BUNDLE COAT
TO ENSURE INNOVATIVE AND
HOLISTIC PROGRAMMING. EIGHTY
SIX TO EIGHT LAKH SALARY ARE
KEITH PATHWAY TO AN EQUITABLE
RECOVERY BY ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN REACH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THEY CARRY THE PROMISE OF
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. FOR THESE
REASONS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU.
ANOTHER TAKE A PUFF HOME FOR
THOSE AND AGAIN THIS IS JUST
THE STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE ON SUPPORT FOR
A BI SIX TWENTY EIGHT AND SO
LET'S START WITH THE ROOMS OR
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE RAISING THEIR HAND
AND THE ROOM. IS OR ANYONE OF
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. I
DO NOT SEE WHERE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SESSION. SO NEXT-
HONEST MODERATED WE HAVE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE THIS IS
AB SIX TWENTY EIGHTH. THANK YOU
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX TO
EIGHT IN A PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON YOUR TELEPHONE. WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL IN CUBA ALREADY
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX TO EIGHT.
BORDERLINE FORTY FOUR FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ERIC MORSE THE
METROPOLITAN MAKE IN THEIR
LIVES BUT THE MEN OF COLOR
WE'RE COSPONSORED PENSTOCK
SUPPORT SB SIX THE WAY. I'M
ALSO CALL ON BEHALF OF THE
ORGANIZATION AID WOMAN CENTER-
YOUNG WOMAN FREEDOM CENTER ANTI
POLICE TERROR PROJECT JEFF THE
TEAM'S NETWORK CRAWL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. SIXTY WAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
THREE SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ST LOUIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I'M SORRY
AT LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING DURING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BENEFIT THAT ON A POLICY AND
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATE I LIVE
AND WORK IN VENTURA COUNTY AND
I'M WITH THE MISTAKE ON THE
CONNECT MINUTE ORGANIZING
PROJECT A SUPPORTER AND-
SPONSOR OF AB SIX TO EIGHT-
WE'RE CALLING BECAUSE WE NEED
TO INVEST IN JOB TRAINING
SYSTEMS FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN SUPPORT
INDIGENOUS AND IMMIGRANT WOMEN
OF COLOR WITH LOW INCOME TO
BECOME COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND INTERPRETERS. THAT
BEST REFLECT THE CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY COMMUNITY
RESPONSIVE WORKFORCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIND FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KAREN NUMBERS
REFLECTED OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING ALEX
KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY TWO FOUR
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING EVERYONE JENNIFER R. O.
ON BEHALF OF THE CULTURE
RESPONSE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
NETWORK IN FACT THE PART OF AB.
THANK YOU. PINE SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TWO ON ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FORMER IRVINE IRVINE SIXTY SIX
SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIXTY SIX YEAR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVEON CLIMBED THIRTY
NINE THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME
IS. AND I LIVE AND WORK IN THE
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AREA I'M PART
OF THE FRESNO CENTER AND I'M
CALLING TODAY IN COURT EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. H. HI MY NAME IS
AMBER HODGE SAID THE I LIVE IN-
THE BAY AREA CALLING FROM DEATH
ROW IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX TO
EIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ENTERED RECALL MAY I LIVE IN
FEAR WHICH IS TRUE AND WITH THE
BAY AREA ALSO I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF THEIR COMPLIMENTS BUNCH.
OF AB. SIXTY RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
OUR NEXT LINE IS LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KEN OLIVER I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
CROP ORGANIZATION. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PASSING OF AB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY NINE TO NINE A
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARED NUMBER DISADVANTAGED
DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I AM SIXTY SIX ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
HILDA MORRISON MY SISTER'S
HOUSE IN SACRAMENTO CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATION HELPING VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ESPECIALLY THOSE BEIJING
LANGUAGE OPTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY ONE NINE
ONE ONE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
POSSIBLE THING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
LATE. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
SIX THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRD THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOTOR FINAL LINING
HEALING LAST LINE NINETY SEVEN
NINE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS A LITTLE BIT I LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES AND I AM WITH
EAGER FANS ARE GOING TO CENTER
I AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SIX TO EIGHT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO
THAT SERVE THE SUPPORT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESS. PREPARED IN
OPPOSITION HOWEVER IF YOU DO
WANT TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
OF ANYONE OPPOSED TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES SO IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIX TO
EIGHT. AGAIN JUST STATING NAME.
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
BILL. NO ONE IN THE ROOM ANYONE
IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB. SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. YOU TO QUEUE UP
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO AB SIX
TO EIGHT I MEAN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. WHAT ONLINE FIFTY NINE
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M SORRY I RECEIVE MY NAME IS
MARK ORDERS OUR GONNA BERMAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
PARTICULAR CAMPESINO BUT I'M
READING THE COLOR TRYING TO GET
IN. BACK TO THE PORCH THE BILL
I THINK IF IT OPENS THE DOOR
FOR DISTRICT ARE WIDE
ORGANIZATION MY BECAUSE THAT
SERVES FARMWORKERS EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING. SO I AM IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NO OTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY WELL THAT
SOUNDS GOOD- BRING IT BACK TO
HER TO OUR OTHER WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE TABLE MOST BY
SUMMER GONZALEZ SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MASON IS THERE
ANY COMMENT OR QUESTION FOR
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. ON
SUCH AN IMPORTANT BILL. I
THINK. ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC.
BARRIERS OF INCLUSION
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR PEOPLE OF
COLOR- I IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
I THINK THAT. WITH THE BILL
SUCH AS THIS I THINK THEY'RE
THEY'RE THE SERVICE IS BENEFIT.
TALK COMMITTEES- WILL BE SEEN.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR IF YOU DEEM THAT
APPROPRIATE- AND I HAVE ONE
QUESTION. IS THERE A PLAN FOR
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AT TRANSGRESSION THE
ANSWER'S YES MANY OF THE CBO'S.
ARE WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING SOME OF THAT OUT REACH.
LONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE BOARD- I DO WANT TO
WELCOME YOU YOUR- ADDITION TO
THE BILL IN ANYONE ELSE'S. YOUR
WORK ON HELP IN ADDRESSING THE
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS. APPLE THE
COMES TO MIND FOR FOUR OR FIVE
FACTORS- ALLOWING THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- HAVE A PATHWAY
TO- UTILIZING THE SKILLS THAT
THAT THEY'VE BEEN. TAUGHT AND
TRAINED FOR- AT THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WILL GO A LONG WAY
IN CERTAINLY ALIGNS WITH THIS
TYPE OF CONCEPT. THAT WERE
PUSHING FORWARD SO- WHAT
COMMUTER ADDITION TO THE BILL
AND THE ANSWER IS YES EDUCATION
OUTREACH WILL BE DONE BY ME AS
HE DEALS- DOING THIS WORK. I'M
ANY OTHER A COMMON QUESTION
ABOVE WAS BACK UP WITH OUR
MAJORITY LEADER SAID IN A I
THINK THAT THIS IS REALLY
CRITICAL WORK I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THESE ISSUES
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS OF THIS
IS BUILDING UPON- THE ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES I KNOW SOME
OF GARCIA THAT THAT YOUR FOCUS
SO MUCH OF YOUR CAREER ON- IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT- AND THIS
DOES HAVE- A RECOMMENDATION DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION OF SUPPORT
MOTION ON THE TABLE HOWEVER I
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE JUST ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TRANSACTION DECLINED
PLEASE KALRA I KALRA HI FLORA.
FLORA HI GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
TO ANSWER. FREYA'S REYES I
FEARFUL HI I LOWERED WARD I
THANKS VERY THE BILLS OUT.
THANK THE NEXT STEP FOR SOME
REAL LOW SO FAR WAS BEEN GREAT
WASN'T IN ORDER ON TIME WE HAVE
A LOT MORE BILLS TO DO THERE'S
A- MOVE ALONG. AND UP NEXT WE
HAVE AB NINETY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY- FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
I'M- HERE PLEASE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY FIVE ON.
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE PROTECTIONS
AS WE ALL KNOW ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS COVERED PANDEMIC
MANY HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES. AND
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THE AN
IMMENSE PRESSURE- DURING THESE
SPECIFIC HARDSHIPS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE. UNPAID
FRIEDMAN LEAVE. JUST TO BE
CLEAR AGAIN THIS IS ON PAID
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE COLLEGE YOU
KNOW THAT I HEAR EVEN IN THIS
BODY WE HAVE BEREAVEMENT LEAVE
PROTECTION THAT IS PAID FOR
EMPLOYEES PAID. LEAVE FOR
EMPLOYEES THIS IS AN PAID
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE THIS HAS THE
DISTINCTION OF BEING ON THE
LIST OF THE JOB KILLERS. LIST
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AND I JOKED LAST YEAR
THAT WELL IF IT'S A JOB KILLER
MIGHT NOT MAKE IT PAID
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE AND- WE JUST
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU'LL-
DEMONSTRATE A DEEP SENSE OF
COMPASSION. DEEP SENSE OF
COMPASSION. AND HELPING TO
PROVIDE UNPAID PER EVENING
LEAVE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND SUPPORTING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
UNPAID. UNPAID BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE TIME
TO GRIEVE. WITH THE FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK.
I THANK YOU SEVERAL LOCAL WE DO
HAVE WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AGAIN FOUR MINUTES
TOTAL- AND SO WE HAVE A RACHEL
LANGSTON AS WELL AS YVONNE
TRIES THEY'RE BOTH ON THE PHONE
AND SO MISTER MODERATOR-
BECAUSE START WITH RACHEL LANG
CENTER SHE'S WRITING UP. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS RACHEL AND
I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
AID AT WORK NONPROFIT LEGAL
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
THE RIGHTS OF LOW INCOME
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY FIVE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
WORKERS WITH JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. EIGHTY NINE FIVE A
PROVIDE WORKERS THE RIGHT TO
BRING IT WITH YOU IT IS NOT HAS
ANY OBLIGATION ON EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL PAID. TO
REACH OUT PART ONE. THAT BRING
WE BUT FEAR DISCIPLINE A GERMAN.
IS ALREADY THERE. BUT OFTEN NOT
HAVING SAID THAT THEY LEARN
OTHER. IN THE MIDST OF THEIR
GREAT LINE THE TEMP HAS UP TO
GO AND WE FROM WORK TO MORE ON
A WHAT. ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT PARTS OF MY JOB IS
THE BY SOMEONE THERE'S I CAN DO
FOR THEM. BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
WAY FOR ME TO PROTECT. RECENTLY
RECEIVED A CALL FROM FATHER WHO
I'M- BROUGHT. YEAH WHETHER HE
COULD USE THAT. OF BOND WE TO
MORE. HI DID HE HAVE A RIGHT
COULD PRETTY GOOD WEEKS WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING. HE HAD NO RIGHT
TO TAKE ME FROM. TO GRIEVE THE
LOSS OF HIS SON. I AM ONE OF
THOSE CALIFORNIANS. RIGHT
BEFORE THANKSGIVING I LOST MY
DAD TO COOK IT. YEAH MY MOM
READY TEXTURES AND I LOST TRACK
OF THE HOURS MY BROTHER AND I.
HELPING MY MOM MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS FOR THAT BIRD
SHORT SURVEY. BY ITS WAY TO
GATHER AND JUST READING
TOGETHER BEST WE COULD. GIVEN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. I DON'T
KNOW HOW IT HAVE GOTTEN THAT
TIME ABOUT THREE. WELL I COULD.
MY FAMILY HONORED MY DAD AND
DEALT WITH THE GRIEF AT THE
SUDDEN LAW. I AM FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO WORK FOR AN EMPLOYER
TO GRANT ST. BUT THAT IS NOT
THE CASE FOR MANY OF THE
WORKERS THAT WE- I DON'T KNOW
HOW ANYONE MANAGES TO WORK
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME GREETING
A LOT HONORING A LOVED ONE. I
DO KNOW THAT NO ONE SHOULD HAVE
TO. SEPARATE HERE JOHNSON
SCORED EIGHTY NINE FIVE AND
ASKING FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
UP NEXT- YVONNE TRIES. I'M HERE.
I AM AVON ATHLETICALLY TRYING
ORGANIZATION IS CALLED A
MOTHER'S VOICE. I STAND IN
AGREEMENT WITH AB NINETY FIVE A
JUST WANTED LET THEM KNOW THAT
I AM STILL IN CHINA LAST MONTH
SPENT ALMOST SIX YEARS AGO
DON'T KNOW- HOW HOW WHEN OR
WHERE THE KILLERS ARE ALWAYS
MOVING AROUND THIS TIME AND
NEVER LEAVE I LOST MY JOB I WAS
WORKING FULL TIME WHEN MY
FRIEND DIED AND WITH THAT BEING
SAID. I'M STILL IN CHINA
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING OUT OF THE
WORK WENT THROUGH DIFFERENT
PLACES TRYING TO FIND OUT- IF
YOU WANTED TO WHEN IT CAME TO
THEM THE LOSS OF MY JOB I LOST
AND THREE DAYS FOR A WHOLE
WEEK. I CAN'T CALL MY SON AND I
KNEW YET PATCH DRAMA THE NEW
HIS ISSUE AND WE HAVE SAID HAS
THE REASON BAY AREA I WOULD
LIKE MY DAD BECAUSE I THINK
WOULD NOT EAT MEAT BUT I'M OFF.
TO EVEN DO A GREAT JOB WARY TO
EVEN SIT DOWN AND STOP CALLING.
I AM IN TOTAL AGREEMENT. WHAT
EIGHTY NINETY FIVE. THIS IS A
BILL THAT WE BUT I SUPPORT
STRONG. NO GRIEVING DON'T KNOW
WHERE WHO THE KILLERS ARE WHAT
TO HIM AND A LOT TO HAPPEN I
STILL NOT INCOME AND STILL LOOK
AT WORK I THINK AND AGREE WITH
AB NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO AND CERTAINLY OF
CONDOLENCES YOUR LOSS AND CAN
GRIEF WELL AS CONDOLENCES TO
MISS LANGSTON FOR HER RECENT
LOSS. AS WELL- WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS INTO THE GAME
DISCIPLINE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
IS JUST STATING YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL AND THIS IS AB NINETY
FIVE. LET'S START IN THE ROOM
IS ANYONE IN SUPPORT. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AND THEN WILL MOVE TO
A MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT AB NINETY
FIVE ON THE PHONE. PUBLIC
COMMENT SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
FIVE IN A PRESS ONE AND THEN
THE ZERO. WE DO HAVE FOURTEEN
LINES IN Q. RIGHT NOW. LOCAL
FIRST ONLINE THIRTY SIX. WELL
MY APOLOGIES ONE MOMENT. OVER
THIRTY FOUR THREE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
TRANSIT UNION MACHINE AT FIVE
P. T. E. LOCAL TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE UNITE HERE D. W.
WORKERS AND CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO BROWN
BOTH SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
PEOPLE THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE OF THREE ONE HUNDRED THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN INFO FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND
THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS TO RELY ON THE TOPICS
WATER CHILD CARE LAWCENTER AND
WE ARE INSTRUCTORS BUILDING
WHILE THE BACK ENTRANCE. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIX ONE HUNDRED
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY
ONE HUNDRED AND SIX YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. REMOVE THE LINE ONE OF
SEVEN ONE OR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SAMUEL MOLINA WITH MI FAMILIA
VOTA AND CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB UP ANYWAY. THANK
YOU. FIND ONE OH WAIT ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS LISA FRIEDMAN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CENTER FOR JUSTICE WE BELIEVE
THAT AB NINETY FIVE IS THE
CENTRAL BECAUSE EVERYONE
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO TAKE TIME
OFF TO GRIEVE THE LOSS OF THEIR
LOVED ONES. SO PLEASE VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE
THIRTEEN ONE ONE THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THERE ARE BLOCKS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION YES CA IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY NINE TWO
NINE DEADLINE OF THE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS ANYTHING
DEPARTURE. CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS FOR
SEEKING JUSTICE WE ARE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR EIGHTY NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND ONE
OH FIVE ONE HUNDRED FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THE H. ONE AND NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND-
AT EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIXTEEN ONE ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MONICA DIRECTLY ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES HOW TO CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE TURN CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND FORTY FOUR ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. 81% WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE ARE INSURANCE
ACCORDING EIGHTY NINETY FIVE
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE TIME OFF
DEGREE WITHOUT FEARING LOSING
YOUR JOB. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIND SIXTY FOUR SIX FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIND SIXTY FOUR
DID YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR
COMMENTS. YES SORRY- MISTER
CARE MEMBERS WHERE YOU GET YOUR
G. R. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO PROUD TO CO SPONSOR EIGHTY
NINETY FIVE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FOURTEEN ONE ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FOURTEEN
DID YOU HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL. HOME OF THE LINE SIXTY
ONE SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ORDER ONLINE ONE SEVENTEEN ONE
ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SPEAK ON
SEVENTEEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OF SIX ONE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN OUR FINAL LINE IN
QUEUES LINE SIXTY TWO SIX TWO
APPLICABLE AT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE YOU CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION. OF AB NINETY
FIVE- TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE ASHLEY HOFFMAN BY PHONE
AND SO. AS MODERATOR FOR THE
FAST YOU HAPPEN UPON YOU CAN
START ANYTIME. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ACTUALLY HOPPING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY NINETY FIVE AS A
JOBKILLER. WE HAVE ALL
SUFFERED THE LOSS OF A LOVED
ONE THAT REQUIRES TIME AWAY
FROM WORK IN POOR COMMUNITIES
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT AND MANY
EMPLOYERS ARE READY TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES. WITH THAT LEAVES
MANY EMPLOYERS HAVE VOLUNTARY
FREQUENTLY POLICIES AND EVEN IF
THERE'S NO FORMAL WRITTEN
POLICIES MOST EMPLOYERS WILL
GLADLY PROVIDE EMPLOYEES WITH
THE KIND OF CRAZY. THEY'RE ALSO
COMBINATIONS AVAILABLE AND
UNFAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT
PRETTY MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
TRAUMA RESULTING IN A
DISABILITY OUR CONCERN AT THIS
BILL INVITED ESTABLISHES THE
ANOTHER INFLEXIBLE THREE TO TEN
DAY LEAD MANDATE PATTERSON
FORCIBLE PROPRIETOR RIGHT OF
ACTION OR POT THAT. BUSINESSES
OF ALL SIZES ARE DOING THEIR
BEST AT THIS MOMENT TO KEEP
OPERATIONS RUNNING AND AVOID
ADDITIONAL LAYOFFS THE STRUGGLE
TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN THE
NUMBER OF BELIEVES THAT
BUSINESSES HAVE HAD TO PROVIDE
HAS GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
PAST YEAR. INCLUDING TWO ROUNDS
OF SUPPLEMENTAL COVER
NINETEENTH EIGHT SICK LEAVE
PAID LEAVE UNDER THE CALLOUS AT
REGENCY STANDARD THE EXPANSION
OF SECRETIVE SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT THE EXPANSION OF FAMILY
MEMBERS FOR WHICH AN EMPLOYEE
CAN TAKE WEEKS TO PROVIDE CARE.
THE FOURTEENTH ARE IN ADDITION
TO ALL OF THE OTHER LEAVE
PROVISIONS AS WELL AS
ACCOMMODATION REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT WALL OF WHEN YOU
LEAVE MAY NOT SEEM SIGNIFICANT
AND ISOLATION THAT THE QUALITY
OF THESE OBLIGATIONS HAS BECOME
OVERWHELMING ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. NEWLY SUBJECT
TO THINK FOR A TWELVE WEEK LEAD
MANDATE EVEN UNPAID LEAVE CAN
COST THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
EMPLOYERS TRYING TO FIND
REPLACEMENTS FOR EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE UNEXPECTEDLY OUT. AB NINETY
FIVE NEW MANDATE ELIMINATES ANY
DISCRETION TO ASK AN EMPLOYEE
TO MODIFY THEIR LEAVE REQUESTS
TO ACCOMMODATE OPERATIONS OR TO
ACCOMMODATE OTHER EMPLOYEES YOU
MIGHT ALSO BE OUT ON A
DIFFERENTLY. FURTHER AB NINETY
FIVE CREATION OF A NEW PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION IN THE
PROVISION OF THE LABOR CODE
OPEN THE BUSINESS WITHOUT THE
COSTLY LITIGATION A SINGLE
POINT OF CASE CAN COST A SMALL
TO MEDIUM SIZED BUSINESS. ON
AVERAGE ABOUT ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND OUR- DR PAGI CASES RUN
FAR HIGHER PENALTY. BACKING
QUICKLY EVEN AT. BY OF THE
LABOR CO. EMPLOYERS NEED AS
MUCH CAP POSSIBLE TO MAKE
PAYROLL AND ENSURE THERE ARE
MORE PLACES OPERATE SAFELY
INCOME. RIGHT NOW AFTER WILL
HELP RIGHT. EXPENSIVE LAWSUIT
MEAN THAT OF THE LINE FOR THE
BILL. FOR THE THREE. WE HAVE
PROPOSED IN AND THAT. IF YOU
PLAY AND THE GUY. CO AND THE
QUALIFYING REASON UNDER SIEGE A-
PLACING RECENTLY. THAT A- FOR.
WILL BE MARKING. FOR EMPLOYER
ESPECIALLY SMALL EMPLOYER. BY
HELPING REDUCE OVERALL OF TIME
THAT. CAN OUT ON. AND MAKING IT
EASIER TO TRACK
ADMINISTRATIVELY BY PLACING THE
SLEEVE UNDER ONE UMBRELLA THAT
THE EMPLOYERS FROM EARLIER
WITH. THIS AMENDMENT WOULD ALSO
ELIMINATE THE THREAT OF PAGA
PENALTIES AND WOULD ALLOW SMALL
EMPLOYERS. BE ABLE TO USE A
SMALL EMPLOYER FAMILIES
MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM.
WITHOUT THAT AMENDMENT WE MUST
REMAIN OR OPPOSED TO EIGHTEEN
NINETY FIVE THE JOB KILLER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE WILL
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND-
ANYONE OPPOSE STATE NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
BILL AB. NINETY FIVE. NEW IN
THE ROOM. NO IN THE ROOM.
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TO WHICH
IS TEST MONITOR. NOT MISTER
MODERATOR FOR SEE THIS AND I ON
THE PHONE A TO A B. NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINETY FIVE ME
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. HELLO
FIRST COLLIDE ONE OH NINE ONE
HUNDRED NINE OF LINES OF. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TOM SHE HE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. IN OPPOSITION TO
AB NINETY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. PLANE TWENTY THREE TO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD ACTORS ARE GOOD MORNING
THIS IS PRETTY HE'S OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE IF WE PRODUCE
RECORD ANYTHING PROCESSING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
FOUR ONE HUNDRED FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR KATIE
HANSON WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY FOUR TWO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MATTHEW ALLEN
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE TO OUR
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
WELL I NINETY FOUR NINE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS PROFESSIONALS ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC GREAT
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIND SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LAWRENCE GATE OPEN UP
THE CALIFORNIA MANY FACTUAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIX ONE HUNDRED SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KEVIN
PADRONE REPRESENTING AND THAT
MIGHT BE WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. THE FINAL LINE IN Q. AS
LINE SIXTY EIGHT SIX EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WHAT'S BEEN. THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS A SUMMER GONZALEZ.
BUILDING MOVED I'M OF THE BILL-
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT ONE THING AND
THAT IS THAT WE ARE NOW
CREATING AN CODE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN A DIFFERENCE OF RIGHTS
WHETHER YOU ARE AN EMPLOYEE
WORKING FOR SOMEBODY WHO HAS
TWENTY FOUR EMPLOYEES OR TWENTY
SIX RIGHT THAT THE EXTREME
DIFFERENCES YOU YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT MINIMUM WAGE- YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR WORD. LEAVE
POLICIES AND WORK WORK WORK
CONTINUING DOWN THAT PATH AND I
JUST. THINK I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IN THE FUTURE THAT WE COME UP
WITH A REASONABLE NUMBER THAT-
IT'S- IT'S A NEED FOR THE
EMPLOYEE ABSOLUTELY BUT YOU
HAVE THAT NEED. TO TRULY BRAVE
WHETHER. YOU WORK FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS OR LARGE BUSINESS SO
IF THERE'S A WAY TO- PROVIDE
CARE IT SIR IT'S SOME SORT OF
INCENTIVE OUR HELP THE SMALL
BUSINESSES COMPLY. WITH WHAT I
THINK IS A VERY REASONABLE
STANDARD AYE I WOULD MUCH
RATHER HAVE THAT APPROACH IT'S
JUST- I I'M REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING ON THIS-
THE DIFFERENCE IT IN THE WAY
THAT WE'RE TREATING WORKERS
DEPENDING ON. THE SIZE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES SO THAT'S ALL I WILL
OF COURSE BUT FOR TODAY. THANK
YOU IS THERE IS THERE A SECOND.
OKAY BUT A SERVER SETUP THANK
YOU. SO I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU I AM REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH THESE AS A PERSON
AT WORK IN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS AS A
MEMBER OF THE UNION. DUES
PAYING UNION MEMBER- TEN DAYS.
WHAT WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IN TEN
DAYS. FOR ME WHY TEN DAYS WHY
NOT TWO WEEKS OR THREE WEEKS.
IF THAT IS THAT YOUR PREFERENCE
IS IT NO I'M JUST CURIOUS. I'M
CURIOUS WHAT WHAT THE TEN DAYS
WAS ABOUT HER WELL. AS A
MEDICAL THING THAT SAYS IN TEN
DAYS YOU'RE OVER IT BECAUSE AS
WE HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
WITNESSES. SHE'S NOT OVER IT I
KNOW WHEN MY DAD LOST MY MOM
AND I WAS TEN HE WAS A TEACHER-
HE NEVER GOT OVER THAT- YOU
KNOW HE HE HAD TO TAKE HE TOOK
THE NEXT WEEK OFF. BUT IT YEAH
I I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS WHY
WHY TEN DAYS YEAH BUT IT GETS
TO THAT OF A SPECIFICALLY THAT
OF AMOUNT OF TWO WEEKS- AND AS
YOU CAN APPRECIATE THEM AS A
REST CHAIR OF THE BUSINESS A
PROFESSION COMMITTEE WHICH
WE'VE OVERSEEING DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND AS YOU
KNOW DURING THE CALL WE'VE HAD
BEEN EXPENSIVE EQUIPMENT
FUNERAL HOMES WERE OVERLOADED
AND DID NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY
SELDOM EVEN WHEN SOMEONE PASSES
WE DON'T JUST HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY DROP EVERYTHING
MANY LIFE CHALLENGES AS YOU ALL
KNOW AS I'M SURE SO IT'S JUST
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP PROVIDE.
SOME TYPE OF ACCOMMODATION FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS GIVEN ALL THE
DIFFERENT LIFE CHANGES AS YOU
ALSO KNOW AS YOU'VE EVER READ
THE BILL THERE'S ALSO A SMALL
BUSINESS- OF LANGUAGE IN THERE
THAT ON THE TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES AT ITS THREE DAYS
AGAIN THIS IS UNPAID RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THE UNPAID PART BUT
THE OTHER PART OF THAT IS THE
LAWSUIT THAT FOLLOWS IF THEY
AREN'T GRANTED THAT UNPAID
LEAVE THE OTHER QUESTION I SAW
PEOPLE SNICKERING. ABOUT IT BUT
THE CFRA. WHY CAN IT BE FOLDER
INTO THAT BECAUSE THAT DOES
COVER A LOT I'VE HAD EMPLOYEES
CALL UP AND- THEN ASK. HEY THIS
IS HAPPENING SOMEBODY DIED. AND
WE JUST WOULD TACK ON WHATEVER
IT IS HEY USE THIS USE THIS AND
USE THIS YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
FIRED BY DOING OUT ALLOW THE
EMPLOYERS. TO DO THAT- BECAUSE
THEY ARE- THEY HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO DO THAT YEAH. A
COUPLE OF DISTINCTIONS HAVE
AFFECTED DEBT THROUGH THE
CHAIR. IT MIND- TO QUALIFY
UNDER THE SPECIFIC AKKA WORKER
MUST BE EMPLOYED FOR AT LEAST
ONE YEAR. SO IN IN IT IF OF
WANTED EMPLOYEES ALL TWELVE
WEEKS AS WELL. OF THE RELIEF
THEY ARE OUT OF LUCK SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF A PARENT IS ALL OF
THEIR BENEFITS FOR MATERNITY OR
PATERNITY LEAVE. THEN THEY HAVE
NO RECOURSE IN CASE THAT MIGHT
BE A DEATH OF A CHILD OR FAMILY
MEMBER SO AGAIN I THINK THOSE
ARE TWO DISTINCTIONS AS TO WHY
THAT. THE NOTE FROM THE AUTHOR
OF SICK LEAVE AVAILABLE TO
THEM. VACATION TIME AVAILABLE
TO THEM. THEY HAVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT LEAVES AND- HELLO IN
IN IN SOME BUSINESSES. WHEN YOU
TAKE LEAVE AND YOU HAVE TO
EITHER HIRE SOMEBODY AND PAY
THEM TIME AND A HALF TO COMMAND
WHICH COSTS BY THE WAY PUBLIC
AND THAT THE CLASS WHEN WE SAY
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ARCHITECT THAT
TAXPAYERS THE COST THEM
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. TO COVER THAT I THINK
L. A. COUNTY ALONE WAS UPWARDS
OF A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS-
SO THERE IS A THERE IS A COST
TO THAT NOT COST. FOR PRIVATE
BUSINESSES. IS ABSORBED EITHER
BY CUSTOMERS OR OR BY THE
PRIVATE BUSINESS SO- YOU KNOW
THOSE THOSE ARE BIG CONCERNS
FOR ME. ANY OF THESE I THINK IT
SHOULD BE I THINK YOU SHOULD
WORK TO FOLD IT INTO CFRA- I
CAN'T SEE ADDING ANOTHER LAYER.
OF LEAD TIME- ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. THERE'S A
REASON MY WIFE'S BUSINESS NEVER
EXPANDED BEYOND HER YEAH SHE
COULD PROBABLY BE EMPLOYING TEN
TO FIFTEEN PEOPLE NOW IF YOU
WANTED AND HAD GROWN HER TAX
BUSINESS. BUT SHE WON'T NEED
THESE TYPE OF THINGS ARE THE
REASON WHY. SO THAT'S WHY I'M
GOING TO HAVE A HARD TIME
SPORTING THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR ADDRESSING THE ISSUE AND
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS AND I APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU I'M NOT SURE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR HER. I THINK
MY ISSUES ARE. SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT LIKE I DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE PART OF THIS
AND- I THINK IT IS- VOTER SOME
FOR THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AND
I DO UNDERSTAND IS ONLY WOMAN'S
CONCERNS ABOUT THE OTHER THE
SIZE OF THE BUSINESS AND YOU
KNOW IT WHAT TRIGGERS THAT
WHETHER YOU GET TEN DAYS OR
THREE DAYS- BECAUSE IF YOU.
HAVE YOU KNOW. ELEVEN EMPLOYEES
OR TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES ARE
STILL IN THE SAME- SIZE OF
EMPLOYER. MY ISSUE IS WITH THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION PART OF
THIS- FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
WE'VE SEEN. THIS BUSINESS
COMMUNITY M. IN MY OPINION JUST
MY HUMBLE OPINION. COME UNDER
ATTACK- FROM. QUITE FRANKLY
PREDATORY LAWSUITS I'M IN A LOT
OF WAYS NOT SO MAYBE DESERVED
SOME OF THEM- I THINK OR NOT.
SO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
WHEN IT TALKS ABOUT LIKE WE
MAIN STREET- COMING THROUGH
COVERT IN THE DEVASTATIONS
HAPPEN TO MAIN STREET. SOME OF
THESE BUSINESSES THE MOM AND
POPS THE BAKERY THEY MAY NOT
KNOW OF ALL THESE NEW LAWS.
THAT ARE DROPPED ON OUR YOU
KNOW. I JUST DROPPED OUR LAP
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. BUT THE
ATTORNEYS DO. THAT'S WHAT THEY
DO. IT'S THEIR JOB TO DO THIS
RIGHT. IT'S HOW THEY MAKE THEIR
LIVING AND SO WHEN WE HAVE
THESE LAWSUITS THEIR OPTION IS
TO FIGHT IT AND PAY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND OR
SETTLE FOR SMALLER. AND I AND I
DO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THAT AND
SO. I'M NOT REALLY ASKING IS
MORE OF A STATEMENT- AND JUST
KIND OF ALWAYS MY CONCERNS-
IT'S NOT THE BREED APART OF
THIS QUITE FRANKLY IT IS THAT
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND
WHAT WE ARE CONTINUING THAT
THAT. THAT WEIGHT THAT WE PUT
ON THAT AND RELEASED THE SMALL
BUSINESS MAIN STREET COMMUNITY
THAT I AM DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT MAY GET CAUGHT UP IN
THIS. SIMPLY NOT KNOWING SO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF THE GULF YOUR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS AND I
APPRECIATE- SOME ALONE REALLY
BRING THIS FORWARD AGAIN I
THINK THAT. SINCE YOU LAST
BROUGHT IT IS EVEN MORE.
RELEVANT I THINK HIS VISCERAL
WELL HE'S SEEN. OVER THE PAST
YEAR AND LOOKING AT SOME. OF
THE ARGUMENTS IN OPPOSITION-
LISTING THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
LEADER AVAILABLE MEAN BOATING
LEAVE FOR TWO HOURS YOU KNOW
BUT- THE WHAT I JUST FIND IT.
MENTIONED THE OREGON AND-
DONNER LEAVE FOR THIRTY DAYS
BECAUSE SOMEONE'S DONATING AN
ORGAN I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE
JUST DON'T JUST THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. THIS IS ON PAID LEAVE AS
YOU'VE STATED SEVERAL TIMES
APPROPRIATELY SO- AND I THINK
THAT YEAH I DON'T KNOW MAYBE
WE'RE JUST LIVING IN DIFFERENT
WORLDS AND YOU HAVE MANY PEOPLE
DIED THIS PAST YEAR. I
APPRECIATE EVEN THOSE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR MORE
FREQUENTLY BUT I THINK BOTH YOU
EXPRESSED- OF THE GENERAL
SUPPORT FOR THE CONCEPT AT
LEAST HAVING. THE ABILITY TO
HAVE BEREAVEMENT AND I THINK
THAT IF THIS LAST YEAR HASN'T
AT LEAST TAUGHT US THAT MUCH TO
ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS
TO TAKE TO TAKE CARE WHEN THEY
NEED TO TAKE CARE OF ONE.
ANOTHER PASSED AWAY AND I THINK
THAT- AGAIN WE'RE JUST SEEING
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS- DURING
THE COURSE OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
SELF I APPRECIATE YOU A SIMILAR
BRING THIS FORWARD WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SUMMER GONZALEZ.
SECONDED BY SUMMER RADIUS AND
SO MADAM SECRETARY CAN OVERTAKE.
THE ROLL CALL VOTE. MOTION IS
DEEP TO A- KALRA. I KALRA I
FLORIDA. FLORA NOW GONZALEZ.
AND SALAS I JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE RADIUS. AYE FREYA'S
AYE ACR THOUGHT NO. SIERRA
DON'T KNOW WARD WARD I. THE
BILL IS OUT ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU. UP
NEXT ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S
SEARCHING WITH- FILE ITEM SIX
IS AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TAKE YOUR
TIME GET SET UP AND THEN- YOU
CAN BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
FOR THE MOTION THE SUMMER WAR
SECOND BY SUMMER GONZALEZ. YOU
MAY BE AS GREAT GIVE ME JUST
ARTS WE MAY PROCEED THANKS MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT TO THIS BILL THAT- SIX
TO CREATE A ROAD MAP WITH
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT THROUGH
A PUBLIC DIALOGUE ON ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT TO- WE
HAVE BEEN FACING AND THIS
LEGISLATURE. WHICH IS HOW DO WE
GET TO. THE AMBITIOUS GOALS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
ESTABLISHED. IN TERMS OF-
CONTINUING OUR STATE'S
LEADERSHIP IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE. CONTINUE TO
WORK TOWARD OUR GOALS OF
REACHING A 100% CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER LAST YEAR TO
PHASE OUT. THE ESTATE SALES OF
ALL. FOSSIL FUEL POWERED CARS
AND TRUCKS BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL
KNOW FROM OUR EXPERIENCE IS
THAT TO A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
EASIER TO SET GOALS AS HARD TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THERE.
AND SO THAT IS WHAT I'M
PROPOSING WITH THIS BILL- IT IS
A AUTHOR SPONSORED BILL I'VE
HAD. MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH-
YOU KNOW VERY INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS BUT GIVEN YOU KNOW.
THE POLITICALLY CHARGED NATURE
OF MANY OF THESE ISSUES OF THE
ORGANIZATION'S UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO STEP
FORWARD TO YOU KNOW EITHER
SERVICE AS SPONSORS ALL OR AS
A- YOU KNOW EVEN A PUBLICLY
IDENTIFIED AS A SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE.THIS IS BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE- SEVEN YEARS IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. WHERE YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S TRYING TO
MAKE REFINERY SAFER- WHETHER
IT'S TRYING TO PROTECT OUR
COAST BY- BANNING OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING. OUR WEATHER IS TRYING
TO PROTECT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WITH THE
OIL DRILLING SETBACKS. AND THAT
YOU KNOW CONSISTENTLY ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT I
FACE AND THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE
FACED IN THIS LEGISLATURE IS
HOW WE CAN. FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
PROTECTING AND GROWING. GOOD TO
MIDDLE CLASS UNION JOBS- THE
WORKERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY. SO WE NEED A ROAD MAP
WITH STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED
LABOR ENVIRONMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. THROUGH A
PUBLIC DIALOGUE SO THAT WE CAN.
ALL FIGURE OUT WE CAN ALL
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE AND HOW. WE ARE GOING
TO REACH OUR CLIMATE GOALS- AND
WHILE THE SAME TIME SUPPORTING
AND PROTECTING OUR WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE
DO- WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE ROOM. IF
NOT WE CAN GO AHEAD AND GO TO
REMOTE TESTING STATION. AND
THEN- WE CAN IMPROVE THIS
MODERATOR IF ANYONE'S IN THE
PHONE AGAIN IF ANYONE'S IN
SUPPORT TO STATE THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THIS IS AB. FOURTEEN
FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU TO STATE
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE IN A PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO IN THE COMMANDOS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO LET'S
GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP. TO
AGAIN PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE. IN
OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE TO STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL. STARTING IN THE ROOM-
MOVING ON TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. AND THEN
FINALLY- MISS MODERATORS OR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE TO AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE. STATE OPPOSITION FOR
THIS BILL MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. OKAY WELL WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THE
SENATE MEMBER. I'LL JUST SAY
LOOK YOU KNOW YOU ARE RIGHT
THESE ARE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS AND I COMMEND YOU
FOR. PUTTING IN THE EFFORT FOR
WANTING TO ENGAGE IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU KNOW NOT
NOT EVERYONE IS EITHER READY OR
WILLING TO- HAVE IS SOMEONE
THAT IS TAKEN ON. ISSUES THAT
THAT CAN BE CHALLENGING AND
DIFFICULT TIMES I COMMEND YOU
FOR THAT AND THIS DOES HAPPEN-
AND RECOMMENDATION OF DO PASS
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION. OF SIMILAR
WAR SECOND BY SUMMER GONZALEZ
AND SO A SIMILAR SITUATIONS
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK VERY OFTEN THANK YOU. MA'AM
SUCH A CRITICAL ALLOWED KALRA
HI KALRA ALRIGHT. FLORA NOT
VOTING GONZALEZ GONZALEZ SIDE
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I
RADIUS. REYES AYE SEATTLE
NUMBER ZERO TWO NOT VOTING.
BOARD WARD I. THINK. IT DOES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ABC TWO THREE ITEMS A. SEVENTY
SEVEN ROBERT RIVAS. WHO IS
HERE- AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GO AHEAD MAKE AN- YEAH.
SO WE GOT A MOTION FROM THE
SUMMER GONZALEZ SEPTEMBER SOME
REWARD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES GREAT TO SEE
EVERYBODY I WANT TO THANK GOD
COMMITTEE STAFFER CONSIDERATION
AND ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR AGRICULTURE IN
POINT FOR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
THANK YOU KNOWN AS WE KNOW
WILDFIRES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
PART OF LIFE HERE IN. OUR STATE
YOU KNOW BUT- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
OUR WILDFIRE STATISTICS FROM
LAST YEAR AND IN PREVIOUS YEARS-
THEY'VE THERE IT'S STAGGERING
YOU KNOW ACCOUNTING FOR FIVE OF
THE SIX LARGEST WILDFIRES IN
THE RECORD HISTORY OF OUR
STATE- WILDFIRE SEASON LAST
YEAR- IT THERE. THERE IS A
DISCONTINUANCE OF UP YOU KNOW A
TREND THAT ARE WILDFIRES IN
GOVERNMENT BECOME MORE INTENSE
BECOME MORE DESTRUCTIVE AND
MORE DEADLY YOU KNOW A NEW
STUDY PUBLISHED LAST MONTH
FOUND THAT TINY PARTICLES
RELEASED IN WILDFIRE SMOKE. UP
TO TEN TIMES MORE HARMFUL TO
HUMANS- THEN- SO PARTICLES
RELEASED FROM OTHER SOURCES
SUCH AS CAR EXHAUST FACTORIES
AND SOME POWER PLANTS.
ACCORDING TO ONE OF THE STUDY'S
AUTHORS THE HEALTH IMPACTS TO
THE WILDFIRE SMOKE ARE ON THE
SAME ORDER OF MAGNITUDE. OR
POSSIBLY EVEN GREATER THAN THE
DIRECT PHYSICAL COST OF
WILDFIRE. AND IT DOESN'T TAKE
MUCH TO MEMBER THE WILDFIRES
FROM LAST YEAR WE HAD ORANGE
SKIES. AIR WAS FILLED WITH
CHOKING SMOKE. AND THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS FOR US TO
SHELTER INDOORS AND SO MOST OF
US HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO BE
AN AIR CONDITIONED ROOMS IN
WITH AIR PURIFIERS. FARMING
AGRICULTURE WORKERS. THEY WERE
MADE OUTDOORS IN SMOKY TOXIC-
SOME CONDITIONS AND FILLED IN
ORCHARDS. TO PICK CROPS THAT
HELP FEED CALIFORNIANS AND OUR
COUNTRY. IN OUT. UNFORTUNATELY
HERE CALIFORNIA AND DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A FIRST IN
THE NATION EMERGENCY STANDARD.
THAT REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM WILDFIRE
SMOKE. MANY PHARMACEUTICAL
DRUGS TO GET THE WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS THEY NEEDED- AND
SO. THEIR FIRST OBVIOUSLY THE
COMBINATION OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND PRESS THE NUMBER
OF WILDFIRES PUT ENORMOUS
STRAIN ON THE AVAILABILITY OF
ASA PP- AND SO WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION PROPOSES TO DO IS
THE BUILT ON COUCHES STANDARD.
AND SO WITH ME HERE- THIS
MORNING TO TESTIFY SUPPORTERS
ARE NON HERNANDEZ EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARMER FOUNDATION. AND MICHAEL
MILLER THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SOME REMEMBER MISS
MODERATOR IF WE ARE IF WE HAVE
A WITNESSES WE CAN GO AHEAD.
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE PHONE AND
ON AND ON AND ON MONDAYS AND
THAT'LL BE FALL HE'LL BE
FOLLOWED BY MICHAEL MILLER. YES
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMA FOUNDATION
BELIEVES EDUCATION IS THE
GATEWAY TO LIKE BRING HEALTHY.
AIR IMPROPER SOCIETY AB SEVENTY
THREE. WILL PROVIDE THE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT EDUCATION
MATERIALS NEEDED. IN
PHARMACOLOGIC COMPLIED WILDFIRE
SMOKE DURING. THE LEGISLATION
OF OFFICE AS A CONSERVATIVE
SAFETY DURING THE EVER
INCREASING WILDFIRE SEASON. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LAST
YEAR CFF DELIVER TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF N. NINETY FIVE.
MASK DURING THE WILD SEASON TO
FARMWORKERS. AFTER WORK SITE.
BECAUSE OF A SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
THE COVENANTING PANDEMIC. IF IT
WEREN'T FOR OUR ORGANIZATION
AND OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FARMWORKERS WOULD
HAVE BEEN LEFT TO THE LEFT. OF
THE SHORTAGE AFFECTED EVERY
INDUSTRY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
INCLUDING AGRICULTURE. AB SEVEN
THREE. IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE COMING
YEARS AND DURING THE NATIONAL
CATASTROPHE. FORTY THREE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC ACCOMMODATION
AS PROPS APART AB SEVEN THREE.
AND WE THINK THAT'S A REQUEST
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THESE.
CRITICAL ISSUES. THANK YOU.
MICHAEL MILLER. GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS AND- MYSTERY OF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND OFTEN IT'S IMPORTANT
THEY'LL I'M NOT KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WINE
GRAPE GROWERS APOLOGIZE WE DID
NOT GET A LETTER IN A TIMELY
BASIS- WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY THREE I WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OFFICE
ADDRESS SOME ISSUES IN THE
WEEKS AHEAD- ESSENTIALLY WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THE BELIEVE
REGULATION WAS APPROVED FOR
ABOUT PERSONAL PROTECTION- WE
LEGALLY NOTIFIED OUR GROWERS I
THINK EVERY AGRICULTURE
SITUATION STATES AT THE SAME.
ADVISE THEM TO STOCK UP AND
NINETY FIVE MASK- JUST TO BE
PREPARED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THEM IN PLACE SHOULD THE WIRE
POSSIBLE PICKS POACHER. WHAT WE
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR WITH
THE COMPANY TEAM THAT WAS THAT
OUR GOAL IS ALSO THE SAME TIME
WITH THE PROVIDING N. NINETY
FIVE MASKS TO HELP WORKERS TO
DEAL WITH THE LACK OF PP IN THE
MISTER CALL THAT SAID THAT WHEN
THE FIRES HAPPENED LATER IN THE
SUMMER DOES THAT. NINETY FIVE
PASSAGE WORK AVAILABLE. THE
STATE'S SEPTEMBER STOCK- UP AND
IF I MAY ASK THAT THE BILL TO
THE AG COMMISSIONER. WHO THEN
WERE WITH THE- GROWERS TO GET
THE OUT TO THE- IN. AND THAT
WAS A GOOD HELP AND THAT IN THE
NEED BROWN AND IF I. WITH FIRST.
OPERATOR CALLED WORKER. THIS
BILL. A BILL ON THEM. AND MAKE
SURE THAT SHOULD BE. OR
SOMETHING COMES THAT THE ROAD
TO BE CAP IS MASK BILLABLE.
THIRTY THREE YOU WOULD THINK
THAT- THE PART OF WORKING
WITHOUT YEAH THE AUTHORIZED- WE
THINK THAT RECALLS A COMMISSION
IS A GOOD WAY TO CONTINUE THE
EFFORT- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. ANY INFORMATION PROVIDED
UNDER THIS BILL IS DUE SOLELY
FOR THE PURPOSES OF- IDENTIFIED
THE NEED FOR BASKET NOT EACH
OTHER PURPOSES. AND THEN WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE ANY
TRAINING MATERIALS. ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE REGULATION
THAT WITHOUT THE BY THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD. WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE HAVE NO
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN.
INFORMATION PROVIDED UNDER THIS
BILL THIS IS INFORMATION
PROVIDED THAT THE REGULATION.
SO THAT THAT WE WORKERS HAVE
CLARITY ON WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO BE PROTECT SMOKE AND OUR
PLAYERS ALSO HAVE THE- THIRTY
BUT- BAITED AFFECTED WORKERS.
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND THANK YOU- COMMITTEE
PRODUCTIVE SERVICES IMPORTANT.
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT THE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION ON
THE BILL. START IN THE ROOM AND
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ROOM SO.
WE'LL MOVE ON FROM OTHER
TESTIMONIES STATION. AND-
MISTER MOM. TO BE ANYONE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. FOR A BI
SEVENTY THREE. THE STATE'S FOR
THIS PRESS BUTTON ZERO ON THE
TOP KEYPAD. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
SEVEN LINES IN Q. WHAT FIRST
ONLINE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
ISRAEL ALL LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
WITH YET THE W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX ONE TWO SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT AND
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF MICHAEL
MILLER FROM ONE RECORDS
RELATING TO OUR LETTER AND THE
FOCUS ON DISTRIBUTION GROUP
POSSIBLY THROUGH ACTS
COMMISSIONERS AND ALSO ACTIVELY
LEADING TRAINING AND INFO TO BE
TO PROTECT WITH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND YOU TO THE AUTHOR BY
THE BALLOT. THANK YOU. BY ONE
THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS ACTUALLY WALKER WITH
KNOCKED AND THEN ON BEHALF OF
THE MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY ONE. ONE
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ANDREA RIVERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE THIRTY TWO ONE
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURZUM INSPECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BILL WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE INTENT AND VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THE
TWO MAIN ISSUES THAT WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON OUR THE
DISTRICT TEAM OUTLINED IN THE
BILL WE'RE JUST HOPING TO GET
SOME LANGUAGE THAT CLARIFIES
CULTURE DISTRICT MANAGER STILL
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
PRIORITIZE IMMINENT HAZARDS
WHEN THEY BELIEVE THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND RELATED TO THE
STOCKPILE. WE'RE STILL WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT EMPLOYERS
RESPONSIBILITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DO HAVE THE RIGHT
KIND OF THE RIGHT NUMBER OF AND
NINETY FIVE WILDFIRES DO HAPPEN
IS PRESERVED AND THAT THE BILL
IN THE WAY WE CONSENT
REQUIREMENT BUT CONTINUE TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
DOCTORS OFFICE THEY'VE BEEN
QUITE WELL AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE SIXTEEN ONE ONE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
SIXTEEN DID YOU HAVE A POSITION.
HOME OF THE LINE ONE. WILL MOVE
TO THE NEXT LINE WHICH IS NINE
THIRTY FOUR THREE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BACKGROUND ON BEHALF OF THE
TEACHERS IN CONSUMER TURKEY TO
DEPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CLIMBED ONE TWENTY NINE ONE TWO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB MY
NAME IS MARCO HE'S OUR GUY AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CORPORATE YUBA COMPASS SHE LED
THE CALIFORNIA- WE ARE A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL WE SERVE
OVER FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS. CAN ANYONE HERE
ASSEMBLY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
GOOD. ALL THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
EIGHT SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES GO HEAD OUT SORRY BUT
THE BIBLE THIS IS BY LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION SELECTED THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND STAFF FOR
TALKING TO US ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WE HAVE BY
THE WORKING ON ADDRESSING AND
LOOK FOR TO BE A SPORTY SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ON
OUR FINAL NINE IN CUBA'S LINE
ONE THIRTY THREE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
LINE WILL TRY ONE SIXTEEN
SECOND TIME ONE ONE SIX ARE YOU
THERE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NOW FOR THE LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU- MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION AB
SEVENTY THREE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY SCHEDULE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL JUST GO
AHEAD TO. PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO STATE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND OPPOSITION
POSITION- STARTING WITH THE
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
ROOMS WILL GO ON TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. IT'S BEEN
VERY LONELY TODAY. SO I MOVE ON
TO- ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE MISS MODERATOR FOR AB
SEVENTY THREE. GET A STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN THREE
PRESS ONE BUTTON THERE ON YOUR
PHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO WE WISH TO STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN THREE.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU AND WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO YES SERVICE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION.
AS I UNDERSTAND THE EMPLOYERS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE NUMBER
OF EMPLOYEES SO THAT THE N.
NINETY FIVE MASKS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. IF THEY
DON'T THEN THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR
THEM THEMSELVES. IS THAT
CORRECT. BUT MY MAIN QUESTION
IS. IF THEY DON'T THEY'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO IF THEY DON'T
PROVIDE THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
THAT THEY HAVE WORKING FOR
THEM. THEN THE- BUT- AT THE
STATE CANNOT HAVE THE MASKS OF
STOCKPILE READY FOR THEM. HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT THOSE WORKERS
WHOSE EMPLOYER DID NOT PROPERLY
GIVE THE NUMBER- OF EMPLOYEES.
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THEY GET
MASKS. YEAH THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE ENGAGED WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN AGRICULTURE
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY- YOU KNOW
WHEN IT COMES TO LABOR NUMBERS
THEY FLUCTUATE BECAUSE A LOT OF
WORK IS SEASONAL- AND SO YOU
KNOW I THINK. YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO
SPECIFIED IN THIS LEGISLATION-
A WAY THAT WE CAN HAVE AN
ONGOING- ASSESSMENT OF THE
ACCOUNTING OF EMPLOYEES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
WE CERTAINLY WILL DO. THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS- I
REALLY APPRECIATE SEEING BRING
THIS FORWARD AND IS MANAGED BY
SOME OF THE- CALLERS YOUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT. TO
FARMWORKERS AND TO ENSURE THAT
AS WE'VE SEEN EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC- THE IMAGES. SMOKE
FILLED AIR AND YOU HAVE
FARMWORKERS THEY'RE ALLOWING US
AGAIN TO STAY HOME AND BE FED
ANOTHER DOES PRODUCE IN THE
WORLD. AND YOUR COMMITMENT IS
CLEAR- I DON'T OFTEN JOINT
OUGHT TO BILLS ARE GONNA COME
FOR ME BUT I HAVE ON THIS ONE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT I ALSO KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND AND- TRUST IN YOUR
ABILITY TO WORK WITH THE
CONCERNS THAT IN BROUGHT
FORWARD. AGAIN WITH THE TO
ENSURE THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
MEETING THEIR OBLIGATION WHILE
THE SAME TIME FARMWORKERS AND
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ARE
GETTING THE PROTECTION THEY
NEED AND SO- WITH THAT- WE DO
HAVE. A MOTION BY A SUMMER
GONZALEZ SECOND BY SOME MEMBER
AWARD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BY CLASS WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMOUNTS
EXCERPTED ROLL ON AB SEVENTY
THREE. MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
HI KALRA HI FLORA. FLORA HI
GONZALEZ. SALAS I JONES SAWYER-
JONES SAWYER RADIUS. REYES I
SEE. HI HERE TO A WORE. WARD I.
SO ALRIGHT THE BILL'S THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOT WE HAVE FIVE EIGHT
THAT'S AB THREE FOUR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. TAKE YOUR
TIME YOU'RE READY YOU CAN BEGIN.
YEAH THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB THREE
SIXTY FOUR TODAY. WE'RE NOT
SURE THAT ALL OF THE PROXIMALLY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND TEMPORARY
VISA HOLDERS WHO COME TO
CALIFORNIA TO WORK AND RECEIVE
COMPREHENSIVE PROTECTION AT THE
POINT OF RECRUITMENT PROTECTION
FROM WORD DOCUMENT DECEITFUL
PRACTICES OF THIRD PARTY LABOR
RECRUITERS WHO EXPORT
CONFORMABLE MIGRANT WORKERS
SEEKING. TO LAWFULLY ENTERED
THE UNITED STATES NOT TO
MENTION THE IMPACTS EXPERTS BY
LAW ABIDING PORTERS WHO CANNOT
COMPLETE WITH THESE UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICES. DECEMBER BUT
WERE CORRECTED DRAFTING ERROR
MADE AN S. B. C. FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN STEINBERG IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THAT CREATED THE FIRST
FRAMEWORK FOR COMPREHENSIVE
PROTECTIONS FOR TEMPORARY VISA
HOLDERS. AMONG ALL THE TYPES OF
VISAS THE H. TWO A.
PROPRIOCEPTIVE UP. IS THE
TEMPORARY VISA COVERED LINKED
TO THE LARGEST NUMBER OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE UNITED
STATES. EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT DEMONSTRATE THAT
FARMWORKERS THE LOWEST PAID
WORKERS WHO ARE CENTER FOR
KEEPING AMERICA'S. AMERICANS
FED DURING THE PANDEMIC ARE NOT
BEING PROTECTED EFFECTIVELY. AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR WOULD ENSURE
THAT THEY MUST ALSO COMPLY WITH
MANDATES THAT ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM EXISTING LAWS
REGULATING FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS. AND ONLY APPLY TO
THEM IF THEY RECRUIT WORKERS
FROM OUTSIDE THE UNITED STATES.
IMPORTS TO CONTRACT FOR THEIR
OWN H. TWO A. WORKERS WOULD NOT
BE SUBJECT TO THESE
REQUIREMENTS. I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY ON THE LINE STEPHANIE
RICHARD REPRESENTING THE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY.
AND TRAFFICKING ALSO CALLING IN
IS THE VICTIM OF THE LABOR
PRACTICES ON THIS BILL WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF MY AND SO WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES. OF THE TWO
MINUTES EACH AND THE FIRST ONE
IS STEPPING RICHARD AND AFTER
THAT WE'LL HEAR FROM. ANGELA
GONZALEZ SO STEPHANIE IF YOU'RE
READY- FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
RICHARD NINE TESTIFYING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
CAST. CAST OF THE SPONSOR OF AB
T. SIX WHO ARE CATHOLIC THE
LARGEST LEGAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICE PROVIDER FOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS IN THE
UNITED STATES. BASED ON CASTE
AND OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS
EXPERIENCE WITH WORKING WITH
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS WE LEARNED
THAT ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO
PREVENT TRAFFICKING. BEFORE IT
STARTS IS TO LIMIT THE
FRAUDULENT PRACTICES OF THIRD
PARTY FOR MAJOR CONTRACTORS AT
THE TIME OF WORKER RECRUITMENT.
THE SHADOW AGENTS FORCE WORKERS
INTO DOUBT BY CHARGING THEM
EXORBITANT FEES FOR LEGAL WORK
VISAS. IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
EC BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN WAS
PASSED WITHOUT ANY THIS
PROBLEM. AB THREE SIX FOUR IF
NECESSARY FOR THE SAME REASON
BUT SB PORT ON SOMEONE WITH AN
ACTIVE. DOCUMENT ANGRY THAN
WIDESPREAD ABUSE OF THE SYSTEM
INCLUDING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TRAFFICKING OF THE DIFFICULT
CRIME TO PREVENT BUT TODAY WE
CAN PROTECT THESE VULNERABLE
WORKERS. MANY OF WHOM ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
HARDEST HIT BY THE EPIDEMIC AND
CONTINUING NEGATIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS. SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
REQUIREMENTS AS CLARIFIED BY
EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR PROTECTING ALL
TEMPORARY WORKERS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. MUCH OF THE DEBATE
AROUND EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR
FOCUSES ON H. U. AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS ONLY ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND WORKERS BUT WE MUST
NOT LOSE SIGHT OF ALL THE VISA
CATEGORIES THE BILL IS DESIGNED
TO PROTECT. ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS. EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT ABUSES SUFFERED BY
WORKERS RECRUITED BY FOREIGN
LABOR CONTRACTORS ARE THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF THE CATEGORY. FOR
THAT REASON THE PERFECT
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY EIGHTY
THREE SIX FOUR GO WAY BEYOND
THOSE EXISTING IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL LAW THEY
PROVIDE A SIMILARLY NEED A
CONSISTENT FRAMEWORK COVERING
ALL THESE THE CATEGORY ONE THAT
MESHES WELL BUT DOES NOT
OVERLAP WITH EXISTING
PRODUCTION. THE BILL PROVISIONS
ARE ALSO GOOD FOR BUSINESS
EMPLOYERS WILL NOW HAVE A
BADLY. BUDGET RECRUITERS IF
THEY CHOOSE TO NOT DIRECTLY
RECRUIT THEIR OWN TEMPORARY
WORKERS. THE UNFAIR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE OF BUSINESSES USING A
RECRUITER. TO UNDERPAID WORKERS
WITH EMPLOYER MADE FOR THESE
READ CAP STRONGLY URGES I'VE-
AYE AT SIX. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ARE YOU THERE. YES HI
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS AND
GOING TO ANALOGY THAT OF BY THE-
FROM THE FILM. I DON'T KNOW IF
WE AT ANY OF THE EQUIPMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S FROM SEVEN TWO
ABOUT THE FIFTEEN BUT I LIVE IN
FRONT YOU THAT THAT I AND MY
HOW. A LOT. BECAUSE I THOUGHT
YOU SEE WOULD HAVE REALLY AND
WILL PROTECT OTHER MCCARTY. I
WAS DEVASTATED WHEN I HEARD
THAT THE WOULD COME COVER TO BE
WHAT CURRENT BECAUSE OF
ATTRACTING A- ADDING THAT ARE
COMPANY AT THE STATE FUNDED IT
SHOULD BE THE- I CAME IN. ONE
THAT LOOKING OF HIGH COULD SHE
HAVE BEEN BEEN THE FACT THAT
LIKE. THAT AND UP TRAFFIC CON
TO THE UNITED STATES AND OF THE
OF THE GOOD JOB. I WILL
CONTINUE DOING A CONTRACT
TRANSATLANTIC PARTNER MY HOME
COUNTRY. I WAS TOLD THEY OWE
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION TO THE
UNITED STATES AND OF THE FACT.
I LOOK. THE CALLS AT WHAT
HAPPENED LIKE TEN YEARS AT A
TIME AT HOME. FOR THE ELDERLY
IN THE LOS ANGELES. OFF THAT. I
LIKE EIGHTY NINE. A DAY NOT
THINK. I HAD TO SLEEP ON THE
FLOOR IN THE- AND EIGHT EIGHT
O'CLOCK. MY TOPIC THAT ALWAYS
STRUCK AN AXE. YOU THOUGHT.
THAT THE- ACT. FOR ID AND- I
HAVE MY- HE COULD PULL THAT.
CHANCE AND WILL BE PART THAT.
AND THIS WENT ON THREE. I AM
LOOKING FOR. OF POLITICAL BEEN.
BECAUSE AND THE MEMBER OF NEXT
YET BUT THE FACT ONLY FILL BY.
AT MONTH. I KNOW THE FACT OF
YOU TO HAVE. TO ME AND MAKE. HI
THINK ALL ADDED. AT BASED ON MY-
EXPERIENCE. MANY ADDED TO
VIOLENCE IN MY- SB FOUR SEVEN.
SHOULD COVER MORE. VTECH CARD
EITHER THAT H. TO. SPECIALLY
NOW WE DISCOVERED. POINT I
BELIEVE. MANY PEOPLE ME. BUT
ONLY CHANCE THE CAR AND WHAT
YOUR UNITED STATES. NO ONE
SHOULD BE. THE CAP WHITE FOR I
NEED. NOW AND DAY. AND FRANKLY
THEIR OWN SAFETY AFTER. OF THE-
I HOPE YOU. I LIKE I'M ON A-
THREE SIX MARK THANK. THANK YOU.
THREE SIX FOR ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
THREE LINES IN Q. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE ONE NINETEEN ONE
ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS PERSECUTE
US ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI THE COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
CHAIR IN MEMBERS I'M GAIL
STEWART CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SUMMER STEPHAN DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AND NANCY O'MALLEY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF ALAMEDA COUNTY BOTH
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB
THREE SIX FOUR AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR THE NEXT TO LINE ONE
SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX CURRICULA.
ONE OF THE ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATE WITH THE BAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR OUR
FINAL LINING Q. IS LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE ONE TWO NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE
DID YOU WANT TO STATE YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AT THIS TIME THEY'RE NOT
FOR THE LINES AND YOU. THANK
YOU. I'M WILL MOVE ON THEN TO
OPPOSITION AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS WE HAVE MATTHEW ALLEN AS
WELL AS BRIAN LITTLE BOTH BY
PHONE IN OPPOSITION AND SO IF
YOU'RE READY- MATTHEW ALLEN YOU
MAY BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HI GOOD MORNING I'M NOT
GOING WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR. THE BILL UNNECESSARILY
EXPANDS THE PROVISION THE UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTING REGULATIONS NOW
INCLUDE ASK WORKERS UNDER THE
H. TWO A. VISA PROGRAM. HM THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT ACTUALLY
OVERLOOKED DURING THE
DISCUSSION AND NEGOTIATION OF
THAT BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH CREATED
THE FORM THEY WERE CONTRACTING
PROGRAM. H. TWO A. VISAS WERE
SIMPLY NOT INTENDED TO BE
COVERED BY THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF NECESSITY TO DO
SO BECAUSE THE H. TWO A. VISA
PROGRAM IS ALREADY REGULATED BY
RESTRICTIVE APPLICATION AND
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. AND CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS A PRE EXISTING
SPECIFIC FARM LABOR CONTRACTOR
BY THINKING PROGRAMS THAT IS
MANAGED BY CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. BY THE
PRESENT GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS
EMPLOYERS MUST AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED TO HIRE AN EXTREMELY
SUPPORTER. HEY THE HIGHEST THAT
THE ADVERSE EFFECT WAGE RATE-
THE PURPORTED PREVAILING WAIT
TO TURN BY PREVAILING WAGE
SURVEY HI FOR THE APPLICABLES
STATUTORY MINIMUM WAGE ARE THEY
ALSO PROVIDE. HOUSING AT NO
COST TO THE WORKER- ADMIN CAL
ALREADY HAS A EXISTING. FARM
CONTRACT LICENSE PROGRAM THAT
IS NOW A FOR BUT IT'S- WHERE
COMMISSIONER OFFICE AND ALREADY
COVERS FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS.
AND IN FACT THIS PROGRAM SERVES
AS A MODEL FOR THE CREATION OF
THIS BEFORE STEP SEVEN. IT WAS
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED IN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
ANALYSIS THAT SB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN QUOTE CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
LICENSING UP VOMIT BURKE
CONTRACTORS ONLY. THIS HAS
CURTAILED HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RELATED ABUSES UNQUOTE. AS A
RESULT EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA
FOR LABOR CONTRACT MAKE A
PATIENT TO COVER ASK WORKERS
UNDER THE H. TWO A. PROGRAM.
SIMPLY MAKES LITTLE SENSE- AND
IS TO PUT THAT UP TO EXISTING
LAW THIS PROJECT IS REASONS
THAT WESTERN GROWERS AS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BRYAN LITTLE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M BRIAN
LITTLE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST ORGANIZATION FARMERS
AND RANCHERS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE WILL IMPOSE TRIPLICATE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ON FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS PARTICIPATE
IN THE FEDERAL H. TWO A.
TEMPORARY AGRICULTURAL WORKER
VISA PROGRAM AND FURNITURE
CULTURAL BOYCOTT MANY
CALIFORNIA FARMS THE FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS HAVE FOR DECADES
BEEN REQUIRED TO OBTAIN AND
MAINTAIN A STATE FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS LICENSE. DOING THIS
REQUIRES FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
TO DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE TO
THE SATISFACTION OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WITH A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING FOR THEIR
PERSONNEL POSTING OF WAGE BOND
FOR CONTRACTORS SEEKING AN
INITIAL LICENSE AN EXTENSIVE
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS WITH
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR FLCS
TO SEEK RENEWAL OF THEIR
LICENCES. AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
SEEK TO CHANGE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH CREATED A
FOR LABOR CONTRACT REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTRACTORS TO
RECRUIT AND APPOINT PEOPLE TO
VARIOUS FOREIGN WORKER VISA
PROGRAMS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THIS BEFORE SEVENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOURTEEN IN DOING
SO THE AUTHOR SPONSORS OF THIS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN MADE A
WISE DECISION TO SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDE EMPLOYERS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE COVERED BY IS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN
REQUIREMENTS BUT YOU WERE
COVERED BY THE LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS APPLYING TO FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERED AS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVENTY SOME
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SPECIFICALLY CITED THE EXISTING
FOR A LABOR CONTRACT PROGRAM AS
A REFORM THAT HAD SERVED TO
CURTAIL LABOR TRAFFICKING THE
PROPONENTS OF SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR CLAIMS THAT IT SEEKS TO
CORRECT A LOOPHOLE WILL PULL
THE LAW CREATED BY US BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN I WAS SERVING MY
PRESENT POSITION IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I ENGAGE THE AUTHORS
ALSO THAT TIME TO CONFIRM THIS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN DID NOT
COVER FROM LABOR CONTRACTORS.
AB THREE SIXTY FOUR TO START
CORRECT ADDRESS TO YOUR REPORT
OVERSIGHT ON THE PART OF THE
CRAFTERS BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN
SB FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN RATHER
IT'S UNNECESSARY EXTENSION OF
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT TO
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS ARE
LICENSED BONDED IS SUBJECT TO
EXTENSIVE EDUCATIONAL COMPUTING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND
MONITORING. BY THE OFFICE OF
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU. A AND LET'S-
MOVE TO THE PUBLIC HARM- FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION AGAIN STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION JUST ON
THE BILL- IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM I DON'T
SEE ANYONE OPPOSITION AT THE
REMOTE TEST MY STATION AND THE
MISS MODERATOR MS WATER IF WE
CAN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE-
FOUR. AB TWO SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU TO STATE OPPOSITION FOR A.
B. THREE SIX FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
THE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN
THE COMMAND IS ONE OF THEM ZERO.
I WE'LL GO TO OUR FIRST LINE
WHICH IS LINE ONE TWENTY SIX
ONE TWO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REGION'S PREVIOUSLY
STATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT ONE THREE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEP AND
THEN THE OTHERS BACK ABOVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS IT IS IN NO
WAY. CORRECT YOU CAN DRAFTING
OUR PREVIOUS SPELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. PINE FIFTY ONE FIVE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD
MORNING MELISSA HI DO ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FIND ONE FORTY
THREE ONE FOUR THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BROUGH TREE CAL
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION TO PICK
IT UP THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND
ONE THIRTY SEVEN ONE THREE
SEVEN NINE US OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH BATONS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
JUST MITCHELL CALIFORNIA COTTON
JERICA GUARD THE POSITION
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROFIT FOR THE
THIRTEENTH AND ASSOCIATION AND
WESTERN PLANT HEALTH
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND I HAVE LINE
ONE FORTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
OF THE PASSAGE ASSURED
COMMITTEE BY SUMMER GONZALEZ
SECOND BY SUMMER REYES WITH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- I JUST
SAID IF YOU LOOK AT THE RELATED
EMPIRE LEGISLATION YOU'LL SEE
AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN BY A GUY
NAMED KALRA FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SO. I APPRECIATE YOU FOR TAKING
THIS BILL ON- IN AND- I THINK
IT'S A WORTHY IT'S NECESSARY.
AND YOU KNOW OF AT THE TIME
WINDOW AND- THAT THE BILL
ORIGINAL BILL SB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN. WRITTEN BY. OF THEN
SENATOR STEINBERG WHEN I
PRESENT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE
HAD SOMEONE FROM HIS STAFF IS
MAYOR TOM ACTUALLY SAY YES THE
INTENTION WAS ALSO TO INCLUDE-
THAT THE FORM THEY WERE
CONTRACTORS BUT WITH A DRAFTING
ERROR OR NOT IT'S NECESSARY
IT'S IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THIS ON REALLY
APPRECIATED I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE FOR SPECTRUM STRUGGLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT IS ON
OF MADAM SECRETARY ROLE ON AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR ALL RIGHT HI
KALRA HI FLORA FLORA NOW
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER FIVE JONES SAWYER HI
RADIUS RADIUS I SEE- DON'T KNOW.
FEAR OF THE UNKNOWN BOARD. WARD
I BILLS. BILLS OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CEMEX SAB TEN FORTY
ONE. WICKS. WHEN EVER YOU ARE
READY YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TEN FORTY ONE UPDATES THE
DEFINITION OF A FAMILY MEMBER
FOR THE PURPOSES OF FAMILY AND
SICK LEAVE ALLOWING EMPLOYEES
TO TAKE TIME OFF TO CARE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO ISN'T RELATED BY
BLOOD BUT ASSOCIATED AS A
MEMBER OF THEIR CHOSEN FAMILY.
THIS INCLUDES A FRIEND'S
NEIGHBOR MEMBER OF THE LGBTQ I
COMMUNITY- OR AT WHO CAN PROVE
THEIR DEPENDENCY WITH A
DOCTOR'S NOTE. TODAY THE
MAJORITY OF HOUSEHOLDS APART
FROM THE NUCLEAR FAMILY MODEL
OF A MARRIED COPLE WITH HER
BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN INSTEAD
THOSE FAMILIES. INCLUDE CLOSE
LOVED ONES WHO AREN'T
BIOLOGICALLY OR LEGALLY RELATED
DATA FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS BUREAU SHOWS THAT
EIGHTEEN POINT 4% OF AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS FOLLOWED THE
TRADITIONAL FAMILY STRUCTURE.
CALIFORNIA FAMILY LEAVE LAWS
CONTINUED TO REFLECT AN
OUTDATED TRADITIONAL FAMILY
MODEL ONLY ALLOWING EMPLOYEES
TO TAKE OFF TIME TO CARE FOR
NARROWLY DEFINED FAMILY
MEMBERS. THIS POLICY GAP
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS THE
L. G. B. T. Q. I COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST L. B. T. Q. I
POPULATION IN THE U. S. MANY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMUNITY DO
NOT HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR BIOLOGICAL RELATIVES.
THEREFORE THEY'RE LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE BIOLOGICAL SUPPORT AND
RELY ON THEIR CHOSEN FAMILY
INSTEAD. ANOTHER STUDY FOUND
THAT THE LARGEST CONCENTRATION
OF MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILIES
CAN BE FOUND IN NEW YORK AND
LOS ANGELES TO THE MOST
HOUSING. TO THE MOST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING MARKETS IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR RELATIVES TO BE
LIVING WITH COUSINS UNCLES AND
OTHER RELATIVES NOT COVERED BY
EXISTING LEAVE LAWS
SPECIFICALLY DURING THE CLIFF
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
PRECEDENT FOR UPDATING OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS AND STATE LOCAL
LAW ORGAN CONNECTICUT NEW
JERSEY. COLORADO AND EIGHT
LOCALITIES INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES HAVE PASSED SIMILAR
SICK LAWS THAT COVER CHOSEN
FAMILY. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN THESE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
THERE. FOR THEIR LOVED ONES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR BLOOD OR
LEGAL RELATIONSHIP. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IS A DEFEAT FOR WALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND
FAMILY COALITION. AND ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS OUR
ELDEST AMANTE SPEAKING AS AN
INDIVIDUAL. HI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ATTENTION TWO MINUTES EACH
OF OUR THAT THE FOOTBALLER AND
A REAL- BUSTAMANTE SO I DON'T
SEE IF YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER. READ FIRSTLY
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS A DEEPER
WHILE I AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND A STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE PROUD SUPPORTERS AND EIGHTY
TEN TWENTY ONE ARE CURRENTLY
POPULOUS AN EMPLOYEE TO TAKE
TIME OFF WORK TO CARE FOR A
SICK FAMILY MEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA CAN ONLY TAKE ME FOR
SPECIFIC FAMILY MEMBERS AND YOU
IF YOU MARRIED AND I LEAVE LIVE
THE DEFINITION OF FAMILY DOES
NOT REFLECT THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF LGBT PEOPLE.
IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WERE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE CLOSE
BONDS WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
OUTSIDE OF OUR NARROW
TRADITIONAL DEFINITION AT TEN
FORTY ONE EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY OUR REPLY
TO INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS FOR
EQUIVALENT AT FAMILY AND
EMPLOYEES LIFE THERE ARE THREE
IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ABOUT THE BELL THE
BILL DOES NOT CREATE NEWMAN
IT'S SIMPLY ALLOWS EMPLOYEES TO
TAKE THEIR EXISTING PAID SECOND
FAMILY LEAVE TO CARE FOR THE
PEOPLE THEY CONSIDER FAMILY
MANY LGBTQ PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SHUNNED BY THEIR FAMILIES AND
I'VE WORKED HARD TO FORM NEW
CHOSEN FAMILY AND STUDIES SHOW
THAT ONE HALF OF LGBTQ PEOPLE
TURN TO CHOSEN FAMILY TO CARE
FOR THEM. BUT OUR CURRENT
DEFINITION OF FAMILY LGBTQ
PEOPLE ARE BEING DENIED LEAVE
OTHER WORKERS ALREADY WRITTEN
THE SECOND THING I WANNA POINT
OUT ABOUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO TYPICALLY THE MALL BEFORE
THOSE PEOPLE THE LEASE OF LIFE
CHANGING EDT REPORT THAT LESS
THAN ZERO POINT 3% OF ALL
DISABILITY AND KEEP THEM IN THE
PLANE OUR TO CARE FOR EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS ZERO POINT 3% IS
NOT A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
BUSINESS BUT WE DO NEED IT IT'S
CRUCIAL. THE LAST THING I WANT
HIGHLIGHTED THAT CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY BEHIND ON THIS ISSUE
THE US GOVERNMENT SIX STATES
AND LOCALITIES INCLUDING LA
HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED AN
EXPANSIVE DEFINITION OF FAMILY
IN THEIR LEASE NOT ONCE A
LEADER IN LGBTQ RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA NOW LAGGED BEHIND TO
STAND BY OUR VALUES OF EQUITY
AND INCLUSION. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ARE YOU ABLE TO
MY- FOR READY YOU MAY. YES
MORNING HONORABLE MEMBER MY
NAME IS AREA WAS THE MONDAY AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THAT YOU'D FIND IN A
FIRE DISTRICT FIFTY I'M
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AS A QUEER
WOMEN OF COLOR AND PARTNER TO A
TRANSGENDER BAN I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF CARING FOR HIM
AFTER HE UNDERWENT CHIU GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE PROCEDURE. MIGHT
MEAN MY PARTNER EXPERIENCED
FAMILY REJECTION AND
HOMELESSNESS AT A YOUNG AGE AND
WEBER LINE UPON ME AS THE
PRIMARY CARE GIVER TO SHEPHERD
HIM THROUGH THE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE QUEUE AT THE TV.
AND I WAS FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE.
TO BUY BE BY HIS SIDE AS HE
RECOVERED. WHAT A MONTH AFTER
OF THE- A LONGTIME FRIENDS AND
THEN ROOMMATE ALSO UNDERWENT
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE. HE TOO
WAS IN A SIMILAR POSITION. NOT
HAVING OTHER TO BE ABLE TO CARE
FOR HIM. AND AFTER CARING FOR
MY PARTNER I WAS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO PROVIDE HIM POST
OPERATIVE CARE AS HE RECOVERED.
SOMETHING THAT WAS NECESSARY
FOR HIM AND WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN UNABLE TO BE
ACHIEVED. WITHOUT A PROPER
SUPPORT SYSTEM. AS AN EMPLOYEE
OF THE LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER.
I WAS ABLE TO UTILIZE PAID TIME
OFF TO CARE FOR BOTH OF MY
LOVED ONE. I NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DO SO I WOULD HAVE BEEN IN A
POSITION TO CARE FOR THESE
IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN MY LIFE DUE
TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACT. AND
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN- IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY HAD TO
POSTPONE THIS CARE. THIS PAST
YEAR. AS WE AS AN LGBTQ PLUS
HELP HOLD HAVE ALSO DEALT WITH
THE EFFECTS OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT'S BECOME
INCREASINGLY CLEAR WHITE BEING
ABLE TO TAKE LEAVE FOR CHILDREN
FAMILY IT'S SO IMPORTANT AND
NECESSARY. TO MANY PEOPLE IN
THE LGBTQ I A PLUS COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
IMMIGRANTS. SHARKS APPEARANCE
OF MODERN LIKE MINE. AND THAT
TOO MANY PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO PAID LEAVE I DID IN
ORDER TO CARE FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES. WHO FOR ALL. INTENTS AND
PURPOSES ARE THEIR FAMILY. IN
HONOR. OF ALL FAMILY BY THE
EIGHTY. TEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I'M UP NEXT WILL
HAVE THE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAIN JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL AB TEN FORTY ONE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT FOLKS SO
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IS ONE OF
THE ROOM. GOING ON TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. THE NEXT
YEAR. MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE FOR AB
TEN FORTY ONE. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE ROUGHLY TWENTY LINES IN
Q. THE FIRST COLLIDE AND ONE
THIRTY TWO ONE THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EXPORT I
APOLOGIZE SPEAKER COULD YOU
REPEAT THAT YOUR LINE WASN'T
QUITE OPEN. MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IMPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ONE TWO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THIRTY FOUR ONE ONE FOUR
WILL. FIND FORTY ONE FOUR ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MICHAEL
FRAZIER ON AN AARP VOLUNTEER
ADVOCATE IN AND PLEASED TO BE A
CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBL MEMBER
WORKS ON BEHALF OF OUR THREE
POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA A. A. R. P. REPORTS
BABY TEN FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIND ONE THIRTY NINE
ONE THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX
CUTLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR EIGHT ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
SOB'S SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
OVER TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND REPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIND ONE
FIFTY ONE ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY NINE ONE FOUR NINE A LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME'S LISA
FRIEDMAN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE JEWISH CENTER FOR
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FORTY ONE FOUR
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS EVAN MINTON WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS WE ARE CALLING WITH A
HIGHER PRIORITY SUPPORT WELL.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TRINA LEGO I
AM ECSTATIC JOURNEY WITH THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER AND DRUG
AB TEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I AND ONE SIXTEEN
ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONICA MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CHARGE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK AND PUBLIC
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOUR
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KATIE
WATER SPENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WORKAND FAMILY COALITION WHERE
CROWDS COSPONSORS AT EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY ONE I'M ALSO
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER ALSO
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE FIFTEEN ONE
FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS RACHEL LANCASTER
LINE WITH ANYBODY AT WORK YOUR
PASSCODE SPONSORS AND IN STRONG
SUPPORTER- IF YOU CAN. KEEP
THANK YOU. FIND ONE FIFTY TWO
ONE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILLIAMITE
COMPARED ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE FORTY FOUR
ONE FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT. ORDER ONLINE SIXTY
FOUR. SIX SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON VERY CO
YOSHIHARA WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
ANOTHER PROUD CO SPONSOR OF A
BECAUSE FORTY ONE ON STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY FOUR ONE FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT
AFTERNOON BEEN PLEASE ON BEHALF
OF PREVENTION INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU. ONE ONE OF FIVE
ONE HUNDRED FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THE
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
TEN FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY FOUR THREE FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR CURRENT
MEMBERS YOU HAVE BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
ONE FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM AN ENERGETIC BAKER-
I AM WITH ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER GREAT QUALITY LOS
ANGELES I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT TEN FORTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR FINAL
LINING KEY WAS FROM LINE ONE
FIVE EIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOU MAY STATE YOUR
POSITION. HI MY NAME IS DONNA
RIGHT AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND ON BEHALF OF LA
BEST BY THESE NETWORKS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO FOR THE ALLIANCE
SECURITIES TIME. I THANK YOU
WELL I WOULD ALSO BE A PROUD
CONSTITUENT OF THE SENATE
ROLEX. OF REGARDLESS WE HAVE TO
HEAR MY POSITION. AND- WE DO
HAVE OPPOSITION. PAIR TO
TESTIFY OF JB TEN FORTY ONE
AND- ON THE PHONE I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ASHLEY HOFFMAN AND
ACTUALLY IF YOU'RE READY YOU
CAN BEGIN. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW- MISTER CARE
MEMBERS WHO COULD ACTUALLY
HOPPING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE EFFECTIVELY OPPOSED
TO EIGHTY TEN FORTY ONE AS A
JOB KILLER. I'M AS A RESULT OF
THE BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THERE ARE THIRTY SEVEN
POINT EIGHT FEWER SMALLER
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA THAN
THERE WERE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY SMALL BUSINESS REVENUES
DOWN STILL BY ABOUT THIRTY
POINT 6% WITH SOME INDUSTRIES
REVENUE DOWN BY MORE THAN SIXTY
PERCENT. BOTH SMALL AND LARGE
BUSINESSES ARE STILL FIGHTING
TO KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN AND
MAKE A WHILE. TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO KEEP OPERATIONS
GOING EMPLOYERS OBLIGATIONS TO
PROVIDE LEAVE HAS INCEASED
OVER THE PAST YEAR ONE OF THE
MOST. SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANSION
DURING COLD IT WAS THE
EXPANSION OF THE FOR JUST THREE
MONTHS AGO SB THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE AT THE END OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST SO THAT
IT NOW APPLIES TO SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH FIVE OR MORE
EMPLOYEES. SB THIRTY THREE ALSO
EXPANDED THE LIST OF FAMILY
MEMBERS FOR WHICH AN EMPLOYEE
COULD TAKE ME TO PROVIDE CARE
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES HE FOR
NO LONGER RUN CONCURRENTLY WITH
ITS FEDERAL COUNTERPART THE
FMLA. BETWEEN THE TWO STATUTES
AND EMPLOYEE COULD BE OUT OF
WORK FOR SIX MONTHS AND THE
EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE NO
DISCRETION TO DENY C. FOR OR
FMLA OR ASK AN EMPLOYEE TO
MODIFY THAT LEAD. TO CALM THE
OTHER EMPLOYEES WHO ARE OUT.
NOW JUST THREE MONTHS AFTER SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE EXTENSION
AB TEN FORTY ONE SEEKS TO
EXPAND IT AND THE HEALTHY
WORKPLACE HEALTHY FAMILY ACT
EVEN FURTHER. THE BILL BROAD
PROVISIONS WOULD ALLOW
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE CARE FOR
ANYONE OF THEIR CHOOSING AN
EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE NO ABILITY
TO CHALLENGE AN EMPLOYEE'S
ASSERTION THAT THEY CONSIDER
NON RELATIVE TO BE LIKE FAMILY
TO THEM. THERE'S ALSO NO LIMIT
ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
EMPLOYEES CAN TAKE CARE TAKE
LEAVE TO CARE FOR. CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES CANNOT AFFORD
A NEW BURDEN FAMILIES MANDATE
EMPLOYERS MUST ALREADY PROVIDE
A MYRIAD OF PLEASE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW INCLUDING PAID
SICK LEAVE A SECOND ROUND OF
THE NINETEEN SICK LEAVE
EXCLUSION PAY. CHILD CARE LEAVE
CRIME VICTIM LEAD PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE C. FOR LEASE
FMLA LEAVE ANYBODY MARK
PROPONENTS. OF THE BILL POINT
TO DATA FROM HE- ARE YOU THAT
LEAVES NOT BECAUSE- YOUR-
SAYING THAT THERE. FEW OF. TO
TAKE THEIR CLEAN. PERSPECTIVE
ONLY REC. AND INTO LEAVE ANSWER
PAID FOR. LEAVE I AM. AND
BROUGH EDT. THEIR OFF IT DOES
NOT. EMPLOYEES TOOK LEAVE AND
THEN NOT TO GO BENEFITS OR-
INSTEAD. OTHER EMPLOYER
PROVIDED BENEFITS. I THINK IT
WAS NOT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT EMPLOYEES COULD TAKE TO
GUARANTEE CALLED WEEKLY BOX. TO
CARE FOR SOMEONE OTHER THAN A
PARENT TRAVIS. AND WITH THE
INCREASING AVAILABILITY THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO THAT DO
USE THAT IS SURE TO INCREASE
AND THIRD. THAT DATA IS FROM
THE C. FOR APPLY ONLY TO
BUSINESSES OF FIFTY PLUS
EMPLOYEES WHICH IS GREATLY
EXPANDED THREE MONTHS AGO.
REGARDLESS LEADER COSTLY FOR
EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY OUR
SMALLEST EMPLOYERS. AND
EXPECTED ABSENTEEISM COSTS
ABOUT THIRTY SIX HUNDRED PER
EMPLOYEE PER YEAR FOR DISPATCH.
AND WHILE THAT MIGHT SEEM A
LOT. TO SOME SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE DOWN 30% IN REVENUE
THAT THIRTY SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
IT'S A FAIR TRIAL. FURTHER
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS
TO TAKE LEAVE TO CARE FOR
SOMEONE OUTSIDE THE FAMILY.
MANY OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS ARE
ALREADY COVERED UNDER EXISTING
LEAVE. POLICIES FOR AND THE
HEALTHY WORKPLACE HEALTHY
FAMILY ACT ALREADY ALLOWS
CARE FOR A CHILD. IN THERE
SOMEONE WHO STANDS IN THE SHOES
OF THE PARENTS OF THAT CHILD.
OR TO CARE FOR A PARENT LIKE
FIGURE WHO STOOD IN THE SHOES
OF THE PARENTS AND AS A CHILD.
A BIOLOGICAL OR LEGAL
RELATIONSHIP IS NOT NECESSARY
IN EITHER OF THOSE SITUATIONS
TO QUALIFY. FOR DIFFERENT
ARCADE SICKLY. WITH MORE THAN
ONE THIRD OF PROBLEMS. STILL
AND THE EXPANSION OF THE FRIDGE
THREE NINE AGO NOW NOT THE- TO
AGAIN IMPOSED. YOU MANDATE ON
HEALTH EMPLOYER. FOR THIS
REASON NOT THE PUBLIC AB FORTY
ONE AS A JOB KILLER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL NOT TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THOSE
OPPOSED YES YOU SEE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
BILL THE START OF THE ROOM ONE
OF THE ROOMS GOING TO REMOTE
CUSTOMIZATION. MISTER MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE TO AB TEN FORTY
ONE. YOU TO STATE OPPOSITION TO
AB TEN FORTY ONE ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD UNITS ONE AND. ZERO
APOLOGIZE IF YOU'RE LOGGED IN
AS A PRESENTER YOU'LL HAVE TO
CONNECT TO ANOTHER LINE TO DO
SO. WELL THE FIRST LINE ONE
FIVE SIX ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN TOM SHE HE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TEN FORTY ONE. THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE THIRTY THREE ONE THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS THROUGH THE USE OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIKE IF THE
PRODUCERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
EVERYTHING STATUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE THREE ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN TO DRIVE THE
REPRESENTING NFIB WE ALONG WITH
OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE ONE FOUR FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
BIRTH CHRISTOLOGICAL ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC CORRECT INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AT TEN
FORTY ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
TWO IN DYING TO HEAR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS HECTOR FERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING
CONTRACTORS IN CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY POSTED AT FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY ONE
FIVE ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELISSA HI BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE WESTERN CAR
WASH ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
NINE ONE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AFTER THIS IS MICHAEL
MILLER WITH THE CAPITALIZATION
OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
SEVENTEEN DID YOU WANT TO
STATURE. POLLUTION YES
WEDNESDAY NOVEMBER CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. AND OUR FINAL
LINING Q. WAS LINE ONE SIXTY
FOUR ONE SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN
LITTLE OF CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THEY WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS I DATE OF AS
OUR WORK THANK YOU AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
ON THIS BILL I THINK IS THAT
REALLY STATED IN YOUR OPEN AND
FROM A LOT OF FLIGHT TESTIMONY
FOR ME AND THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER SUCH A ROBUST-
GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES TO REALLY.
UNDERSCORE HOW OUR DEFINITION
OF FAMILY HAS REALLY CHANGED
OVER THE YEARS- AND WE'RE
FORTUNATE THAT IT HAS BECAUSE I
THINK IT USED TO BE A TIME
DECADES AGO WHEN MANY PEOPLE
WERE VERY CLOSETED ABOUT WHO
THEIR REAL FAMILY WHO THEIR
OTHER PLACES WE THINK THERE WAS
A- TERM ABOUT BEARDS RIGHT THAT
LIKE SOMEBODY HAD A FAKE
RELATIONSHIP TO BE ABLE TO MASK
THE TRUE RELATIONSHIPS- AND
THEY REALLY- THE MEANT THAT MET
THE WOMAN THAT WERE THE
EQUIVALENT. OF WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND A NUCLEAR FAMILY TO
BE AND I THINK- IN THIS GREAT
DIVERSE STATE THAT WE HAVE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THAT- I WOULD- ENCOURAGE I IAN-
AS YOUR CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE- DEFINITION- THE BUT BUT
BUT BUT BUT- THE EQUIVALENT OF
A FAMILY RELATIONSHIP. I'M JUST
THAT DOESN'T GET TRIPPED UP
THERE'S A WAY THAT MAYBE CAN
KIND OF TIGHTEN UP EXACTLY
MAYBE SOME STANDARDS THAT WOULD
DEFINE DOT EQUIVALENT I THINK
THAT WOULD HELP I THINK THAT'S
REALLY DESERVES PASSAGE TO
REFLECT THE- AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS WE HAVE ACROSS
OUR STATE OF THE PRODUCT- JOIN
AS CO AUTHORS NOT PERTAIN DO
SO. AND I'M HAPPY. TO MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU. SIR SECOND.
SECOND OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND ANY FURTHER CONVERSATION
I GUESS I REQUEST PLEASE SO IT
AND I TOTALLY RESPECT AND AGREE
WITH ARE MY COLLEAGUES FROM-
FROM SAN DIEGO- ON ON THE
DEFINITION AND THAT THAT'S ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT I'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH BECAUSE- IF
THAT DEFINITION IS A NARROW-
JUST CONCLUDE ANYBODY. THAT THE
EMPLOYER DOESN'T REALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY- NOR DO THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO ASK- THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEBODY IS
JUST USING THIS. AS A MEANS OF
YOU KNOW IT'S TAKING THREE
WEEKS OFF TO GO VISIT THEIR
SICK FRIEND IN MAUI- DURING
CHRISTMAS WHEN THEY CAN'T GET
OTHER TIME OFF. AND IN IN THOSE
KIND OF. LOOSE DEFINITIONS
ALLOW FOR HAT KIND OF ABUSE
AND THAT KIND OF ABUSE. IS WHAT
IS THE BUSINESS KILLER THAT
THEY TALK ABOUT- AND ALSO IN
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE WORLD-
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT COST.
AGAIN TOP COST TAXPAYERS.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN OVERTIME COSTS- IT
DOES I WORKED THERE FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS I DO UNDERSTAND HOW
MUCH IT COSTS. AND SO- SO IT
YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO SUPPORT
IT WITH WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT'S JUST TOO
BROAD. AND BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
THE CHANGING DYNAMICS OF
FAMILIAL RELATIONSHIPS. AND IN
THAT FAMILIES ARE NOW NOT
REALLY AS WELL DEFINED AS THEY
WERE BEFORE I HAVE A VERY
EXTENDED FAMILY ALSO. AND IN
UNDERSTAND THAT AS WELL AS
ANYBODY- SO- SO YOU KNOW IT. IS
THEIR LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT
HELPS. WITH THAT SO APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS- AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS A MEMBER WARD
WILL CERTAINLY ADD YOU AS A CO
AUTHOR- AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE BILL YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WHILE THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
NO FRAUD AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE IS WIDESPREAD FRAUD IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM- AND IT
DEFINITELY WITH IN THIS
SPECIFIC BILL- IT REQUIRES A
DOCTOR'S NOTE SO IT CANJUST BE
SORT OF LIKE RANDOM NEIGHBOR
WANTS TO GO TO HAWAII FOR THREE
WEEKS- THERE NEEDS TO BE SERVED
DOCUMENTATION TO ENSURE THAT
THE PERSON WHO'S- CARING FOR
THAT PERSON- IT IS LEGITIMATELY
ABLE TO DO SO AND IS DOING SO.
AUTHENTICALLY AND I WILL SAY
YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE SPOKEN
SERVICE OR ELSE FINISH UP WE
YOU KNOW WE SPOKE TO THE
CHAMBER CONTAINING TO MEET WITH
THE CHAMBER AND THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO. I THINK ARE MOST IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS YOU KNOW ONCE
THIS GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
IT HAS TO GOTO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AS WELL I'VE SPOKEN
TO THE CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE.
SO IT IS STILL VERY MUCH WORK
IN PROGRESS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE SITE
AND ALSO IF YOU CAN ENSURE
THAT- THE HIPPA REQUIREMENTS
DON'T GET THROWN IN THERE AS AN
OBSTACLE- WITH A DOCTOR'S
EXCUSE. SAYING SOMEBODY IS ILL.
AT THE AVERAGE OF THAT VIOLATE
THEIR HIP A REQUIRED MADERA
HIPAA PROTECTIONS SO- SO ANYWAY
I. APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THINK.
THANK YOU THIS AMERICAN. REGIS
WANNA MAKE THIS DOESN'T EXPAND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES BY RIGHT DOES THAT
NOW. OKAY SO. JUST TO BE CLEAR
AND I KNOW THERE'S SO MUCH
CONFUSION ON ON- FAMILY LEAVE
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY OF OUR
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. INCLUDING
TEACHERS AND COUNTY EMPLOYEES
COUNTY SAN DIEGO. DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
SO- THIS WOULDN'T BE A BURDEN
ON ON TAXPAYERS IN THAT WAY- I
ALSO WANT TO. MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THIS IS
PAID FOR BY THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES OUT OF PAYROLL TAX
CREDITS. THE SO WITH THAT THANK
YOU I ASSUME THIS WOULD BE A
VERY. SMALL PERCENTAGE AND WHAT
IT REALLY BURDEN THAT THE STI
AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE. FUND
CORRECT IT'S A VERY SAD WE
EXPECTED TO BE A VERY SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD
ACTUALLY TAKE IT TAKE IT UP BUT
FOR THOSE PEOPLE TO VERY
IMPORTANT. I DO I WANT TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DEFINITION- I THINK THAT THAT
DOES NEED TO BE TAKEN UP AND
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT- OUT OF.
AT APPROPRIATIONS SO THE SPEECH
RECOGNITION THANK. YOU GOT A
JUDICIARY SORRY WE GOT WE GOT A
INSURANCE THIS ON THOSE. OKAY
SO NOTHING'S WILL GET BY THE
TIME YOU GET THERE. I JUST WANT
TO KNOW THAT. I'D EXPECT A
LITTLE BIT TIGHTER GENERATION
THAT'S IT BUT- I'M- GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THIS WHAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR ALL THE COMMON AND
YOU SOME. WORK A YOU KNOW THE-
THANKS AGAIN THIS LAST YEAR I
THINK WE'VE SEEN A LOT. BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE BILITY OF A- I
GUESS IT'S CALLED A SILVER
LINING WHERE FOLKS BEEN A
VOLUNTARY CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONS
MAYBE. WHEN THEY WERE UNABLE TO
IN THE PAST- AND WE'VE ALSO
SEEN SOME HORRORS OF DOWN IS
NOT BE ABLE TO BE WITH THEIR
LOVED ONES. DURING THE WORST
TIMES OF THEIR LIFE- BUT WE
SHOULD BE REMOVING BARRIERS TO
ALLOWING LOVED ONES TO CARE FOR
ANOTHER THAT WAS MEANT TO CARE
FOR ANOTHER. INTERVIEW WITH ONE
ANOTHER. AND YOU KNOW AS FAR AS
CHOSEN FAMILIES. THERE IS FAR
AS THE CENTER THERE'S A
CHANGING DYNAMIC WHAT A FAMILY
IT FAMILIES ARE. I WOULD ARGUE
IS THE OPPOSITE THEY WERE
FINALLY. ALLOWING COMES BE WHAT
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN- AND SO
REALLY A- THIS BILL FOR THAT
REASON- AND SO. AMONG AMONG
MANY OTHERS AND SO WITH THAT. I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT
FAST FOR NEIGHBORHOOD THANK YOU-
EXECUTIVE ROLE ON A. B. TEN
FORTY ONE. SHIN IS DUE PASSED
TO INSURANCE KALRA HI KALRA HI
FLORA FLORA KNOWN GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER- JONES
SAWYER AYE RADIUS. RADIUS I SEE
ARE THROUGH NOW SIERRA DON'T
KNOW BOARD. WARD HI FILMS.
THANK YOU AT THE BILL IT'S A
PASS IT IS OUT AS BEEN GOING TO
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. AND UP
NEXT AB ELEVEN NINETEEN- THE
PERSON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
EMPLOYEES BASED ON THEIR FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL REQUIRES AN EMPLOYEE
TO PROVIDE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR KNOWN FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR SCHOOL AND
CHILD CARE CLOSURES. FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY DISCRIMINATION
OCCURS WHEN AN EMPLOYER TAKES A
NEGATIVE EMPLOYMENT ACTION
AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE TO CARE FOR
A FAMILY MEMBER THIS INCLUDES
MOTHER FOR MOTHERS AND FATHERS
OF YOUNG CHILDREN PREGNANT
BREAST FEEDING A PEOPLE. AND
EMPLOYEES WITH AGING PARENTS OR
SIX PALACES OR PARTNERS THAT
MAY ENCOUNTER FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES DISCRIMINATION
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR ROUGHLY 60% OF TWO
PARENT HOUSEHOLDS WITH AT
ROUGHLY 60% OF TWO PARENT
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN UNDER
AGE UNDER AGE EIGHTEEN. HAVE
BOTH PARENTS WORKING MORE THAN
ONE IN SIX AMERICANS AMERICANS
WORK FULL TIME OR PART TIME
REPORT ASSISTING WITH CARE OF
AN L. ELDERLY OR DISABLED
FAMILY MEMBER RELATIVE OR
FRIEND AND WANTED TWELVE
EMPLOYEE WHEN TWELVE- EMPLOYED
ADULTS CARE FOR BOTH CHILDREN
AND ELDERLY OR DISABLED ADULTS.
MOST EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE
CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES AT
SOME POINT IN THEIR
PROFESSIONAL LIVES EMPLOYMENT
ACTIONS LIKE TERMINATION
REFUSAL TO HIRE OR DEMOTION OR
BEING PASSED UP FOR PROMOTIONS
MAY BE BASED ON BIASES ABOUT
HOW WORKERS WITH FAMILY
CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES
WILL OR SHOULD ACT WITHOUT
REGARD TO THE WORKERS ACTUAL
PERFORMANCE. THIS TYPE OF
DISCRIMINATION AFFECTS
EMPLOYEES OF EVERY INCOME LEVEL
RACE GENDER IN INDUSTRY WORKING
MOTHERS LOW WAGE WORKERS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED ONE
STUDY BY THE AMERICAN JOURNAL
SOCIOLOGY FOUND THAT MOTHERS
WERE 79% LESS LIKELY TO BE
RECOMMENDED FOR HIRE. HALF IS
LIKELY TO BE PROMOTED AND
OFFERED AN AVERAGE OF ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS FOR THE
SAME POSITION AS NON MOTHERS.
MOST ALARMINGLY 80% OF THE
NEARLY ONE POINT ONE MILLION
WORKERS WHO DROPPED OUT OF THE
LABOR FORCE LAST SEPTEMBER
WOMEN. EMPLOYEES ARE STRUGGLING
TO BALANCE THEIR JOB AND CARING
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. DISPARATE
TREATMENT BECAUSE OF THEIR
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD
NOT BE REASON FOR TERMINATION
OR OTHER ADVERSE EMPLOYMENT
ACTIONS. AND I'LL JUST SAY YOU
KNOW YESTERDAY I WAS- IN THE
MIDDLE OF MY DAY AND ZOOMING A
LOT AND MY DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL
CALLED AND SHE AS SICK. AND I
WAS ABLE TO STOP WHAT I WAS
DOING AND GO PICK HER UP- BUT
I'M LUCKY AND WE ARE LUCKY
BECAUSE WE HAVE STAFF AND WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
BUT FOR SO MANY OF OUR WORKERS
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO WHAT
IF YOU'RE A GROCERY STORE
WORKER WHAT IF YOU'RE A NURSE
WHAT IF YOU WORK AT. YOU KNOW A
CAFE WHAT ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO
DO IN THAT SITUATION HAPPENS
AND SO THE POINT OF THIS BILL
IS TO ENSURE THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
WHO HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. HAVE SOME
FORM OF REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION SO THAT THEIR
JOBS ARE NOT JEOPARDIZED AND TO
ENSURE THAT OUR WORKERS ARE
MEASURED ON THE OUTPUT OF THEIR
WORK. I'M NOT THE PERCEPTION OF
WHAT IT IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
CARE GIVING RESPONSIBILITIES.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY. IS LISTEN
LIZ MORRIS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF HASTINGS CENTER FOR.
WORKLIFE LAW AND ALMA FERRIES.
THANK YOU OKAY SO EACH WITNESS
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH LIZ
MORRIS FOLLOWED BY ALMOST
VARIOUS LISTS. YEAH THANK YOU
CAN ALMOST GO FIRST SURE.
SHIPWRIGHT OKAY- GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY STORY
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS I'M
NOT READY YET AND I AM THE
MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN MY
YOUNGEST RUBIO TWO AND A HALF
YEARS OLD SHE WAS BORN
SEVENTEEN WEEKS PREMATURELY AND
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH THE
MOST SEVERE FORM OF THAT BOTH
OF THE DOCTORS GAVE HER 2%
CHANCE SURVIVAL AND SHE WAS
KEPT IN THE NEONATAL INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT FOR ALMOST EIGHT
MONTHS AFTER SHE WAS BORN.
RUBIO BASTAR QUADRIPLEGIC THREE
THREE TRACHEOSTOMY AND IS
DEPENDENT ON A VENTILATOR AND
REQUIRED TWENTY FOUR HOUR
SPECIALIZED CARE TO THEM WE
WILL BE WITH BORN I WAS WORKING
FULL TIME AS A BRANCH MANAGER
FOR HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL COMPANY
HELLO EMPLOYEE AND WAS GOOD AT
MY JOB I'VE BEEN RECEIVED A
COMPANY. OUT OF THE BY THE
BOARD. AT THE WHITE A WORK
HAVING HIGHEST. STAND OF THE
COME. I WORKED ALL DAY VISITED
WILL BE IN NICK YOU EVERY NIGHT
SHE WAS JUST TRYING. SO MY
PERFORM DIDN'T CHANGE MAKE THE
PROVIDED PROTECTION IF NEEDED.
I HAD TO USE MY HARD EARNED SIX
KIND OF PPL TO TAKE WOULD BE TO
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
SPECIALIZES IN. BOTH THE
FREIGHT OF ALWAYS ASKING FOR
THE ACCOMMODATION AND TIME OFF
BECAUSE MY BOSS IS A MENOMINEE.
I WOULD COMPLAIN ABOUT ME TO MY
COWORKERS BEHIND MY BACK. I
WOULD START AROUND CHRISTMAS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. I WAS
HUMILIATED SHAYMIN COMPANY
ANXIOUS ABOUT HOW I WOULD
PROVIDE FOR MY CHILDREN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET A GREAT
BUT SO POWERFUL THAT I ALMOST
BOUGHT THE WILL PREVENT. BUT I
LOVE MY CHILDREN I KNEW I
NEEDED TO PROVIDE FOR THEM. I
FINALLY FOUND ANOTHER JOB IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AS AN HR
MANAGER. I WAS SO GRATEFUL TO
BE EMPLOYED AND I COULD TELL
MICHAEL WORKERS AND MANAGERS
RESPECTED ME AND VALLEY MAKE.
AND THAN ONE ACTOR. THEN ONE
DAY ARE AFTERNOON DEREK WITH
THE CHARACTER OF THE SUDDENLY
STOPPED. WORKING FRIENDS
BECAUSE THE PULPIT. CHALLENGING
FOR ME TO FIND ADEQUATE
CHARACTER RUBIO I CAN ONLY VERY
WELL TRAINED PROFESSIONALS HAVE
TRICK EXPERIENCE AND CAN
MONITOR HER HEALTH CONDITION.
CALLED OFF OF THESE I COULD NOT
COMMENT I HAD NO OTHER CHOICE.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
END I'M A NEW JOB MY BOSS IS
OBVIOUSLY ANNOYED JOB TO
RETALIATE AGAINST ME BY DENYING
ME PERMISSION TO WORK REMOTELY
EVEN THOUGH EVERYBODY UP WITH
WORKING REMOTELY. IT'S LIKE
THEY WERE ASKING ME TO PROVE I
WOULD HAVE BEEN GOOD FOR MY
CHILD. I NEEDED A JOB I
CONTINUE TO GO TO THE OFFICE
EVEN THOUGH RUBIO DOCTORS THAT.
IT WAS WORTH IT BECAUSE I'M NOT
I'M CONDITION. THIS IS NOT
ENOUGH IN A LOOK BY AGAIN. I
WAS FIRED TWICE IN. THE FIRST
TWO YEARS OF MY DAUGHTER'S LIFE.
BUT CARE FOR. I EVERYTHING WAS
ASKED FOR ME AT BOTH JOBS AND I
WERE ABOVE AND BE. TO BE A TO
WORK AND ALSO PROPER NURSING
CARE BE MY NURSES THERE AS WELL
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY LESS
DEVOTED MY JOB BUT IT MAKES ME
THINK I'M MORE LIKELY TO FIRE I
HAVE LANDED LESSON THROUGH THE
WITH PARTY I WOULD TALK TO HEAR
ABOUT THE BILL BEING PROPOSED
BECAUSE THE JOB WOULD CHANGE MY
LIFE AND ANY OTHER SITUATIONS
LIKE MINE I WILL MISS OUR TO
HELP YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
NECESSARY. IT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. LIZ MARS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU.
MY NAME OF BUT MORRISON THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER
FOR WORK LIFE LAW UP WE JUST
HEARD FROM ALMOST THIRTY A FAR
TOO MANY WORKERS WITH FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES HAPPENING
CRISIS OVER THE LAST YEAR WHEN
THE PROFESSIONAL CARE PROVIDERS
THAT THEY RELY ON TO GET TO
WORK HAVE BEEN TEMPORARILY
UNAVAILABLE BECAUSE THE COMPANY.
MOTHERS IN PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED WHAT THE HARSHEST
IMPACT ON WOMEN OF COLOR SINGLE
MOTHERS AND WORKERS IN THE
PAINT JOB. NOT ONLY HAVE THEY
SUFFERED THAT THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE PROPER TOO. MANY WHAT
HOMELESSNESS FOOD INSECURITY IN
OTHER PLAGUE THE POVERTY.
DURING THE PANDEMIC WORKING
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO CARING FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN THE ELDERLY AND
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE FAITH. HARPER
ENGINE TWENTY. BETWEEN
PROVIDING ADEQUATE CARE FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES AND KEEPING
THE PAINT JOB THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE. BUT THESE CHOICES ARE
NOT NEW. DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
FAMILY CAREGIVERS EXISTED LONG
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND IT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY CONTINUE AND LIKELY
TAKE AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TO
ADDRESS THAT. AND CALIFORNIA IS
BEHIND IN ADDRESSING IT NEARLY
30% OF THE AMERICAN WORK FORCE
IS ALREADY PROTECTED BY A STATE
OR LOCAL LAW THAT PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
EMPLOYEES THAT CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES. CALIFORNIA
WORKERS ARE LEFT OUT. THE
EXPERIENCE OF THESE OTHER
STATES SHOWS THAT FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY DISCRIMINATION
LAWS WORK FOR EMPLOYEES AND
BUSINESSES ALIKE BY ENCOURAGING
EMPLOYERS TO TREAT FAMILY
CAREGIVERS BASED ON THEIR JOB
PERFORMANCE INSTEAD OF FIRE
WHICH HAS THE POWER TO BOTH
SAVE JOBS AND AVOID POSSIBLE.
AB ELEVEN NINETEEN IS
IMPERATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. IT WILL
ENSURE FAMILY CAREGIVERS
TYPICALLY WOMEN ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE WORK
FORCE. HOTELLING FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES AND NOT A
PRIVATE BALIK IF THE HARD AND
NECESSARY WORK OF CARING FOR
THE ELDERLY AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AND RAISING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WORKERS THAT
WILL KEEP OUR ECONOMY RUNNING
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M NOT A
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETEEN ANYONE IN THE
ROOM ALONE IN THE ROOM. THE
TESTIMONY STATION STE MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN TO STATE THEIR NAME
FILIATION POSITION THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND THEY JONES
TUITION WITH SUPPORT AB ONE ONE
ONE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. FIRST COMES FROM
MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY ONE THAT'S
ONE FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE FIFTY ONE LINE IS OPEN.
OUR NEXT COMMON DENTAL COMPLAIN
OF THIRTY FOUR THAT'S THREE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MATT BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT TO CONFIRM
MY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS- GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KARINA LEGO AND IF YOU NEED
TO CHECK YOUR LAW CENTER AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF. AB THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ECIGARETTE LINE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MISTER TURN
MEMBERS SERVINGAS THE LEAD TO
SHANTI HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT YOUR LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BERSERK MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT THANK
YOU. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MICHAEL FISHER I'M IN
A. L. P. VOLUNTEER ADVOCATE IN
THE CONSTITUENTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH ON BEHALF
OF OUR THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS SHOULD
CALIFORNIA A. R. P. SUPPORT
SHOULD BE BE ELEVEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. YOUR LINE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STEPPED BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. EXADATA
LINE NUMBER ONE OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS A
CHINESE- I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
WE ARE IN A PARK AT. EIGHTY ONE
ONE NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH WE HAVE
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CHART
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
AND PUBLIC COUNCIL AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT TIME WE GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KATIE WATER SMITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILIES
COALITION WHERE CROWDS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE
ONE NINE I'M AND I'MALSO
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER. THE
BUSINESSMAN CONFESSIONAL IN AT
THE BACK COUNTY ASSISTANCE FOR
CHOI WHO ARE ALSO INSTRUCTED
PART THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
EIGHT ZERO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THEY
ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIAN PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO CAUCUS BALKED
AT THE BILL ARMSTRONG THERE
JUST SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THE LINE NUMBER
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ORDER LINE NUMBER
ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS RACHEL FROM THE GREAT WORK
YOUR ACCOUNT. TRUMP NEED STRONG
SUPPORT AB ONE OR MORE NEGATIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BACK TO
THE LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOANNA RIGHT I AM
THE MOTHER OF THREE SMALL
CHILDREN AGES SIX FOUR AND- I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF ALLEY THAT
THEY DID NOT WORK OUT WITH MY
STRONG SUPPORT. AB ONE IN
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT OUR NEXT
FINAL BE NOT LINE NUMBER ONE
SIXTY NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IN SCOPE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANYONE CAN MAYES GENERATED
JEWISH JUST SHOW SUPPORT FOR
TODAY'S BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MOVEMENT
OPPOSITION AND- IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE ASHLEY HOFFMAN'S
ACTUALLY TO BE A NEVER REALLY.
THANK YOU I COULD AFTERNOON
AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WITH
ACTUALLY OPTED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB ONE ONE ONE NINE AS A JOB
KILLER I'M A LOT OF DISCUSSION
SURROUNDING THIS BILL HAS BEEN
ON THE PROVISION PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
EMPLOYEES OR PARENTS OR PROVIDE
CARE TO OTHERS. I WOULDN'T
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TODAY
IS THE BILL'S EXPANSION OF THE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION IN
THERE AFTER PRACTICE MANDATE
UNDER THE HOT AND WHAT THAT
PRACTICALLY WOULD BE FOR
EMPLOYERS PRESENTLY YOU SEE HOW
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
REQUIREMENT ONLY APPLIES TO
EMPLOYEES AT THE DISABILITY
ORGAN PLAY BUT CERTAIN
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. AB ONE ONE
ONE NINE EXPAND THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR THE AN EMPLOYER
MUST PROVIDE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION FOR ANY EMPLOYEE
WHO HAD FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES. FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES IS BROADLY
DEFINED UNDER THE BILL INCLUDES
PROVIDING DIRECTED ONGOING CARE
TO ANY MINOR CHILD THE CARE
RECIPIENT THE DIRECT CARE IS
NOT JUST LIMITED TO WOMEN WHO
ARE CHILD CARE CENTER IS CLOSED
AND IT APPLIES EQUALLY TO TRIAL
TO SEVENTEEN AT THE GOT TO GO
INTO ONE. CHARACTER VIA IS
ANYONE RESIDING IN THE
HOUSEHOLD FOR QUITE SOME THE
EMPLOYEE FOR MEDICAL CARE OR
MORE BROADLY RELIES ON THE
EMPLOYEES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
DAILY LIVING THERE FOR A LARGE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO ACCOMMODATIONS
UNDER THE SPELL THAT WOULD
INCLUDE ANY EMPLOYEE WHO IS A
PARENT OF A CHILD UNDER
EIGHTEEN AND ANY EMPLOYEE
LIVING WITH ANOTHER PERSON WHO
RELIES ON THEM IN SOME WAY. SO
UNDER THIS BILL AN EMPLOYER
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
ACCOMMODATE ANY EMPLOYEE WHO
FALLS INTO ONE OF THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES THAT MEANS THAT A
PARENT WHAT THE COMING LATE
EVERY DAY AFTER TAKING THEIR
CHILD TO SCHOOL OR LEAVE EARLY
TO PICK UP A CHILD FROM SCHOOL
CAN'T REQUEST ACCOMMODATION.
APPARENTLY WANT TO TAKE A DAY
OFF CARE FOR THEIR CHILD WITH
OUR SPOUSES ON VACATION CAN
REQUEST AN ACCOMMODATION AN
EMPLOYEE WHO NEED TO DRIVE THE
ROOMMATE TO AN APPOINTMENT CAN
REQUEST THAT ACCOMMODATION AND
AN EMPLOYEE WHO IMPACT THEIR C.
FOR EVERITT MAILLET LEAVE CAN
REQUEST MORE THAN THOSE TWELVE
WEEKS. UNLIKE OTHER LEAVE
SABRINA MORE COMBINATIONS UNDER
FEET HIGH ARE NOT CAST THE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
PROCESSES DESIGNED FOR INJURED
OR DISABLED WORKERS WHO NEEDED
MODIFICATIONS. TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WORKING THERE IS NO
SET HOURLY WE- OR- LET. EACH
ISSUE. AS HIGH FACT. WHAT IS
CONSIDERED. THAN COMMON. GET
FROM COURSE TO. IT IS DEPENDENT
ON THE INTO. AND EMPLOYEE AND
THE END OF THE EMPLOYERS IN
BATON. THERE ARE ALSO ARE.
FORTY HOUR. A PROTECTED. UNDER
LABOR CODE SECTION TWO THIRTY
POINT EIGHT. FOR FIGURATIONS
WERE CHILD NOT BE PICKED UP. OR
IF THE SCORE CHILD CARE CENTER
IS UNEXPECTEDLY CLOSED. FURTHER
THINK PRODUCT CAN BE USED IN
ONE TO TWO HOUR INCREMENTS
WHERE A CHILD HAS. MEDICAL
CONDITION AND THEREFORE NEED TO
BE CARED FOR BY THE PARENT AND
SMALL INCREMENTS OF TIME.
ALTHOUGH NO PLAYER CAN
TECHNICALLY TO NINE
ACCOMMODATION IS NOT REASONABLE
OUT OF FEAR OF LITIGATION MANY
EMPLOYERS ACTUALLY HAVE VERY
LITTLE ABILITY TO DO THAT. THIS
ASSEMBLY HERE'S AN IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION OF TRYING TO CONTINUE
BUSINESS OPERATIONS
UNDERSTAFFED OR DECIDE TO TAKE
IN A COMPANY IN WHO THEY
CANNOT. REMOTE COMBINATIONS
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION
ONE OF THE MOST COMMON SPECIES
FOR THE D. FH TARGETS FILED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN A WERE RELATED
TO ACCOMMODATION. BUT OCCASION
CAN FINANCIALLY DEVASTATED
SMALL BUSINESS. WHO IS
SUBJECTIVE HE HA. AND EVEN WHEN
AN EMPLOYER DOES GRAND
ACCOMMODATION THERE'S LIKELY TO
BE A LOT. ABOUT WHETHER THE
EMPLOYER SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE
AND THE DISABILITY CONTEXT
THERE'S BEEN EXTENSIVE
LITIGATION ABOUT WHETHER
SPECIFIC ACCOMMODATION
SUFFICIENT. WHETHER THE
EMPLOYEE IS ENTITLED TO MORE
ACCOMMODATION AFTER THE END OF
THE PERIOD OF LEAVE OR CULTURAL
CHANGE. EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY
SMALL PLAYERS HAVE FACED
MULTIPLE INCREASE LEADS TO
MANDATE THIS YEAR. WITH MORE
THAN 3637% OF SMALL BUSINESSES
STILL BEING CLOSED. SMALLER
PLAYERS SIMPLY CANNOT TAKE THIS
NEW MANDATE ESPECIALLY ONE WITH
NO LIMITATIONS ON TIME. AND
THAT IS HIGHLY PRONE TO
LITIGATION WE THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY. APPROACHED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SOME OF NAME
COM. IN OPPOSITION. TO A ELEVEN
NINE THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ROOM.
MOTEL MY STATION. SH MODERATOR
THERE ANYONE THE PHONE AND OP
TO A. ELEVEN NINETEEN. I WANT
TO GET A JOB WITH YOUR
OPPOSITION AB ONE ONE ONE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME OUR FIRST FINAL GO TO FIND
A BILL ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS TO USE THE CALIFORNIA LEGAL
PRODUCERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MEXICO I NUMBER ONE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BIRTH I
THOUGHT YOU KNOW ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE LINE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TOM
SHE HE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU. NEXAVAR
LINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK ARE
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS I
APOLOGIZE I THINK THAT I MIX
SOMETHING UP WITH MY- SILENT-
BUT THIS IS ONE OF MY BURKE
FROM NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA YEAH IN SUPPORT I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT NO PROBLEM
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS A LARGE GAIN
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WHERE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THINKING WHICH
REMEMBER THAT CAN YOU HELP ON
BEHALF OF THE DOUBLE CHECKED
THE TRADITION OF CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA
HI ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
WINEMAKERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE WESTERN CAR WASH
INSTITUTION BOTH IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE OF A
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD-
REFERENCES PRIME LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OF RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR LINE FOR NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THE
PROTECTOR PLANET ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSING CONTRACTORS THE
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFUL IN
OPPOSITION TO AB LAB IN. ELEVEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHER
PARTIES IN Q. THANK YOU. I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SUMMER GONZALEZ. FIRST I MET
WITH THE BILL BUT- I HAVE TO
ADMIT AS YOU KNOW AND I WORKED
IN THE SPACE FOR A LONG TIME.
FIRST OF ALL JUST SO PEOPLE
HOME NOW IF ANYONE IS CALLED AT
WORK BECAUSE THEIR CHILD IS
SICK YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TAKE PAID SICK TIME.
SO THAT WE DID THAT A FEW YEARS
AGO. IT'S REALLY PART WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PAID SICK TIME BUT
YOU CAN'T BE. STOPPED OR
RETALIATED AGAINST FOR DOING
SELF SO WE HAVE I HAVE THAT
PROTECTION. MY CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL IS THE ACCOMMODATION
PORTION. BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CASE LAW THERE'S NO RULE- IT'S
SO DIFFERENT THAN THE-
DISABILITY IT WHAT WE'RE USED
TO. ALREADY WITH- THE MEETING
AND- YOU KNOW YOU YOU LOOK AT
MEDICAL RECORDS YOU YOU DECIDE
WHAT CAN BE DONE THERE. THERE
IS A PROCESS THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH NOW WITH WITH. WITH
DISABILITIES THAT WE UNDERSTAND.
I DON'T KNOW EVEN AS BOTH AT
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN AN
EMPLOYEE WITH CHILDREN AND AN
EMPLOYER WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED BY A COURT
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION AND SO
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS BEEN DISCUSSED
I ALMOST FEEL BAD SAYING THIS
PUBLICLY WITHOUT. ADDRESS IT
PRIVATELY PURCHASED. IS THERE A
WAY TO GIVE EXAMPLES OR OR TO
SPECIFY WHAT A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION WHAT WHAT THE RAM
OF THAT IS I MEAN IS A
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
BRINGING MY CHILD WITH ME TO
WORK IS A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION- CHANGING MY
SCHEDULE IS A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION GIVE ME PAID TIME
OFF YOU KNOW. I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE COURTS WOULD ASSUME
WOULD BE THE REASON
ACCOMMODATION AND I THINK THAT
THAT CAUSES A LOT OF FEAR I
JUST. WOULD LIKE TO BE. TIGHTER
IN WHAT WERE WERE SUGGESTING IS
APPROPRIATE I JUST- I CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE ALL THE THINGS
THAT COULD COME UP RIGHT NOW SO
I THINK THAT THAT THAT MOST
EMPLOYERS PROBABLY CAN'T
EITHER. SO YES IN THIS IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
SHAREPOINT IT'S THERE'S A LOT
TO SORT OF FIGURE OUT THERE
RIGHT- TEMPORARY I THINK IS A
PIECE OF IT. YOU KNOW- THIS
ISN'T LIKE YOU KNOW I HAVE A
JOB THAT. GET YOU KNOW I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE TILL FIVE
BUT EVERY SINGLE DAY MY CHILD
GETS OUT OF SCHOOL THREE SO I'M
GONNA SAY HEY I NEED
ACCOMMODATION TO LEAVE AT THREE
EVERY SINGLE DAY BUT STILL TO
GET PAID FOR THAT TIME RIGHT.
IT'S MORE IF IT'S TEMPORARY-
SOMETHING HAPPENS WHERE THERE
IS AN EMERGENCY SITUATION THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT THAT MEANS IN ADDITION
TO THAT- EMPLOYERS DON'T HAVE
TO PROVIDE ACCOMMODATION IF IT
MEANS- IMPOSING UNDUE HARDSHIP
ON THEM SO YOU HAVE A- STORE
WITH ONE EMPLOYEE THAT'S- AT A
SEVEN ELEVEN OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. RIGHT LIKE THAT WOULD
IMPOSE A HARDSHIP ON. YOU KNOW
THAT STORE SO WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH. THESE
DEFINITIONS AND I AGREE THEY
NEED TO BE MORE FLESHED OUT-
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT. AND ALSO SUGGESTED TO
SCHOOL CLOSING BUT THAT'S NOT
CLEAR I I'M JUST THINKING
THROUGH ALL THE POSSIBILITIES
SO. GIVEN THE DONALD'S AND-
THERE'S A SCHOOL CLOSING IN ON
A FEDERAL HOLIDAY AND SO
EVERYBODY NEEDS AN
ACCOMMODATION TO STAY HOME WITH
THEIR CHILD. I'M RIGHT YOU KNOW
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
THAT OBVIOUSLY WOULDN'T WORK IN
THE REAL WORLD AGAIN SO- I
THINK THERE'S A TON OF WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THIS
SPACE AND I'M GLAD YOU'RE
TAKING US ON THIS IS. REAL I
JUST. THINK WE HAVE TO THINK
THROUGH. THE SPECIFICS. YEP AND
I'M COMMITTED TO DOING THAT YOU
KNOW ASSUMING WE GET THIS OUT
OF COMMITTEE. YEAH THANK YOU.
ARM WRESTLE THOSE EMOTIONS ARE
SECOND. OKAY THANK YOU THE
SERVER CERTAIN THANK YOU. SO N.
FOLLOWING A LITTLE BIT ON
MICHIGAN'S HOUSES CONCERNS- YOU
KNOW THE EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION IN THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT ALSO
COVERS THE HIRING PROCESS- WHAT
IS TO PREVENT SOMEBODY FROM
INTERVIEWING FOR A JOB WHO HAS
SO MANY RESTRICTIONS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CAN'T. BECAUSE OF
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES THEY
CAN'T ACTUALLY FUNCTION IN THAT
POSITION. HOW IS THE EMPLOYER
WHAT POSITION IS THAT PUT HIM
IN FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE-
EIGHT IF THEY SAY NO BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T DO THE POSITION
BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE
OBLIGATIONS ARE THEY NOW
SUBJECT TO. BEING SUIT. YOU
KNOW AGAIN I WOULD SAY I THINK
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
COMBINATION IT'S FOR TEMPORARY
RIGHT IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHERE
IT'S SORT OF AN ONGOING
SITUATION WHERE WE KNOW EVERY
DAY OUR KID GETS OUT OF SCHOOL
TO THIRTY RIGHT- AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT-
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE
WE'VE TALKED TO THE CHAMBER AND
THE OPPOSITION HAS RAISED SOME
OF THESE CONCERNS. I MEAN TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT I DON'T
WANT TO CREATE SOMETHING THAT
HAS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES-
BUT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS THE NEEDS WERE YOU
DO YOU SEE AS AS OUR OUR
WITNESS TESTIFIED
DISCRIMINATION THAT DOES HAPPEN
RIGHT WITHOUT HAVING SOME SORT
OF NEGATIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO FINISH OUT AND I
THINK AGAIN SOME. BUSINESS
CONCERNS ARE. THERE ONE LAWSUIT
AWAY FROM NOT BEING IN BUSINESS
SOMETIMES- AND IT IN OKAY. FROM
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIMENT
I HARKEN BACK TO THE DAYS WHEN
I WAS A KID MY SISTER GOT HURT
ON THE PLAYGROUND MY MOM WHO IS
A TEACHER BEFORE SHE PASSED
AWAY HAD TO COME AND GET HER
AND TAKE HER TO THE DOCTOR AND
THEN WHILE SHE WAS AT THE
DOCTOR I GOT HURT. AND SO MY
DAD WHO IS ALSO A TEACHER HAD
TO COME BACK AND GET ME- THEY
HAD NO PROBLEMS DOING THAT IN
THE PAST YEP AND I'M I'M HOPING
THINGS DIDN'T CHANGE A WHOLE
LOT. AN ENGINE ON THOSE DAYS
THAT THEY HAVE THAT. THAT IS
MISSED GONZALEZ HAD POINTED OUT
THAT THEY HAVE THAT CAPABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT ALREADY.
AND I JUST ON THE LAWSUIT- YOU
KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN FOUR
STATES HAVE PASSED THIS
ALREADY- ALASKA DELAWARE
MINNESOTA AND NEW YORK AND THEY
HAVE NOT SEEN A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN LAWSUITS- I THINK
IT'S THE SAME. ODDS OF BEING
STRUCK BY LIGHTNING SO IT'S
VERY SMALL- BUT- AND WE ARE
LOOKING TO THOSE STATES AS WELL
TO FIGURE OUT. LESSONS LEARNED
FROM HOW THEY HAVE DONE IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT- WE'RE
CRAFTING THIS THE RIGHT WAY. I
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
COMPETENT AS THE REAL WORLD
COMPLICATED IT'S REALLY TOUGH
TO SUMMER GONZALEZ IS POINT YOU
KNOW- IT'S CHALLENGING AND I
THINK THAT THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS FOR THAT
REASON TO WORK ON THESE THINGS
IS AN ALLEGED SHERRY HOPEFULLY
NEXT- AND THAT COMMITTEE UNDER.
SHAHRISTANI'S INTERCEPTORS
GREAT JOB A DRILLING DOWN ON
THESE ISSUES AS WELL SO- WITH
THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU A MADAM
SECRETARY OF CALDERON AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN PLEASE. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
KALRA HI KALRA HI FLORA. FLORA
NO GONZALEZ. I GONZALEZ I'D
JONES- JONES IRATE IS. SEATTLE
NO SEATTLE NOW AWARD. WARD HI.
THE WITH RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT
ITS WAY TO FISHING MANY THANK
THANK YOU. SO NOW WE ARE THE
REMAINING BILLS ALL CAMINO
BILLS WERE GOING TO THE RECORD.
AS LISTED IN THE FILE- AB TEN
TWENTY THREE OF BY SHARE FLORA.
RIGHT THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
AT AB TEN TWENTY THREE WOULD
ENACT THE PENALTY OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY AGAINST THE
PUBLIC WORKERS CONTRACTOR WHO
FAILED TO SUBMIT ELECTRONIC
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS A TRONIC SURVEY
PANELS A TOOL USED BY THE STATE
TO ENSURE THAT CONTRACTORS ON
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS ARE
PAYING THEIR WORKERS THE
PREVAILING WAGE IF THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO. I WANT TO STRESS
THAT THIS SOMETHING IS ALREADY
REQUIRED WITH CONTRACTS. AB TEN
TWENTY THREE WOULD SIMPLY
PROVIDE AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THE
CONTRACTORS ARE ABIDING BY THE
LAW. ALSO WANT TO SEE THEM
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL.
ACKNOWLEDGES THE NUANCES OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS INCLUDING A
GRACE PERIOD. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU HAVE A
MOTION IS OUR SECOND. AND THEN
THERE'S A WE HAVE BEEN
SUPPRESSED BY SUPPORT WE HAVE
MATT CLEMONS MEANINGLESS HOPE
YOU ON THE PHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN THE
TEMPERAMENT I I'M GOING TO
REDUCE MY TESTIMONY
DRAMATICALLY MATTHEW COULD DO A
BETTER SHE- UP BEGIN AT THIS
BILL THIS BILL IF YOU'RE HAVING
TO FIND IN. THE OF A
REQUIREMENT INSISTING LAW THE
FILE. SELECT TRYING TO
CERTIFIED PAYROLL- THE TARGET
PARKING LOT- IT AGAIN FINAL A
CHRONICALLY WILL- GREATLY-
EXPEDITE- PUBLIC WORKS I LIKE
HIM TO VERIFICATION THEN AGAIN
THE BILL IS NOT. REDUCING THE
TIME REQUIRED OF THE CONTRACTOR
PASSED THE FINAL. ELECTRONIC
PAYROLL THIRTY DAYS. AFTER THAT
WOULD YOU VIOLATE THE LAWS THAT
ARE TRYING WOULD BE INSTITUTED
TO ENCOURAGE A GREATER
REQUIREMENT ELECTREK TRYING TO
FIGHT WITH THE PAYROLL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN.
FOR THOSE SPEAKING. BUT IN
PUBLIC JUST YOUR NAME. POSITION
BILL THERE'S NO ONE THE ROOM
GOING TO REMOTE. STATION MISTER
MODERATOR TO BE HAVING IN SOME
ON THE PHONE FOR A TEN. THREE
THANK YOU TO STATE SUPPORT FOR
A BI TEN TWENTY THREE MIN PRESS
ONE BUTTONS ARE ON THE PHONE
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A LINE I'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
SORRY FOR THE
DELAY WHICH DEVELOPED THE
PERSON ON THE LINE NUMBER HERE.
NINE SIXTY NINE SIX NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS B.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COMPLIANCE ON THE HIGHWAY LABOR
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM AND I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THAT IS THE
ONLY MIND WE HAVEN'T. THANK YOU
FOR- LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION OF THE WE HAVE
RICHARD MARCUSSEN- BY PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. JAMARCUS THEM. I
POLITICIANS SHADOWED SHOW THAT
PHONE LINE CONNECTING. OKAY
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WITH THE PORK. WHAT WAS UP.
OKAY WELL LET'S- LET'S SEE
MOBILE LET'S MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT OF HIS MEDICINE GETS
ONLINE BILL WILL GO TO HIM- ANY
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IS ON IN
THE ROOM MOTETS MONEY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE.
YES WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
BETWEEN BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT
AS WE GET THAT LINE NUMBER.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT ONE SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR RICHARD MARX AND I
APOLOGIZE- FOR FOOD COMING IN
THROUGH THIS LINE. BRIDGING THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. WE CERTAINLY DON'T
SUPPORT. CONTRACTORS WHO FAIL
TO COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
TO SUBMIT CERTIFIED PAYROLL
RECORDS IN FACT WE FREQUENTLY
COMPLAIN ABOUT LEGISLATION THAT
GRANTS SOME CONTRACTORS
EXEMPTIONS FROM COMPLETING
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS
HOWEVER MISTER FLORES BILL. IN
OUR OPINION I PRESENTS
CHALLENGES PARTICULARLY THE
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES THAT
THE FINAL CERTIFIED PAYROLL
RECORDS BE COMPLETED AND
SUBMITTED ON THE FINAL DAY OF
CONSTRUCTION- WE DO UNDERSTAND
THE MOST FLOOR- IS WILLING TO
WORK WITH OUR CONCERNS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
DIALOGUE WITH HIM- TO. ADDRESS
THE BILL AND TO PRODUCE
SOMETHING THAT- WE ARE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR
MISSING THE CALL NO PROBLEM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FEEDBACK
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL LINES OF OPPOSITION
YOU MAY ALSO PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION. BY SEVERAL
WARS SECONDED BY SUMMER C. R.
TELL IS THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR OF A
SHARE. HI FRAZIER APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND ALLOW YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
AND PRETTY CLOSING COMMENTS THE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH INTO THE
OPPOSITION- WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON SOME
AMENDMENTS- INCLUDING A GRACE
PERIOD AND A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
CLAUSES WELL SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR OPPOSITION AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU IN A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IT
WITHOUT A FINANCES OR IF YOU
CAN HAVE- A ROLL CALL ON AB TEN
TWENTY THREE MOTION OF THE PAST
TWO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI
KALRA AYE FLORIDA AYE FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE RADIUS
SIERRA HI SEATTLE I WARD. HI
RIGHT. THE BILL IS UNDER
PREPARATIONS. SIMILAR JONES
SAWYER IS A BAFTA. NEW BILLS
MOVED AND SECONDED. WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY SIMER JONES
SAWYER GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
ALLOWS HEALTH CARE WORKERS
PROVIDING DIRECT PATIENT CARE
TO OVERRIDE A HOSPITAL
ALGORITHM IF IT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT AND
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
HOSPITALS REGULARLY USE
ALGORITHMS TO HELP DECIDE THE
BEST COURSE OF CARE FOR
MILLIONS OF PATIENTS A YEAR.
THESE ALGORITHMS AS HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO PUT TO INPUT
PATIENT INFORMATION WHICH
DIDN'T RETURNS WITH A
PRESCRIBED COURSE OF TREATMENT
HOWEVER ALGORITHMS ALGORITHMIC
BIAS AND SPECIFICALLY RACIAL
BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY
ARE WELL DOCUMENTED AND HAVE
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED IN RECENT
YEARS AND TO THE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO RESEARCH THE STUDY
THAT THE OUTPUTS OF A WIDELY
USED HOSPITAL ALGORITHM- AND
FOUND IT X. ZIP IT SIGNIFICANT
RACIAL BIAS WHEN IT REFERRED
BLACK PATIENTS TO EXTRA CARE
PROGRAM. SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER
TIMES THAN WHITE PATIENTS
ALTHOUGH TECHNOLOGY CAN BE A
HELPFUL TOOL. THAT THAT
COMPLEMENTS THE SKILLS AND
DECISION MAKING OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS IT IS NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE INCREASINGLY
PASSED LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS
THE IMPLICIT BIASES OF
INDIVIDUALS. SO I TECHNOLOGY
BECOMES MORE MORE INGRAINED
INTO OUR SOCIETY IS ONLY RIGHT
THAT WE TAKE THE SAME STEPS TO
ADDRESS ITS LIMITATIONS AS
WELL. MAJOR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE STATE ALREADY
RECOGNIZED AS NEAT AND HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SUCH PROTECTIONS IN
THEIR OWN POLICIES. ULTIMATELY
PROVIDING AS MANY TOOLS AS
POSSIBLE TO REDUCE THE IMPACT
OF BIASES AND ALL ASPECTS OF
HEALTH CARE WILL BE LIFESAVING.
AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT PROMOTE
PATIENT WELL BEING BY PUTTING
THE TRUST BACK INTO THE HANDS
OF THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
PROPERLY TRAINED TO DO THEIR
JOBS AS WELL AS CREATING B.
TALLY HAITIAN PROTECTION FROM
THEIR EMPLOYER. JUST FOR
QUESTIONING THE ALGORITHM WHEN
NECESSARY WITH ME TODAY THE
BRIDE TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IS TAYLOR JACKSON ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL'S SPONSOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
AND JANICE- MERRILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES IN OF TAYLOR
JACKSON IS READY SHE MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
PROUD SPONSORS OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT. AS A FAMILY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER SAID IMPLICIT BIAS
IS A HUGE ISSUE IN HEALTHCARE
AND STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
SIGNIFICANT BIASES INHERENT. IN
THE ALGORITHMS DEPLOYED ON A
LARGE SCALE CAN HELP FACILITIES
WHICH DO EVERYTHING FROM
SETTING PRESCRIPTION PLAN
DESIGNATING PATIENT ACUITY AND
DETERMINING HOSPITAL DISCHARGE
TIMELINE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SYSTEMS ARE CREATED AND
IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT PROGRAMMING
TO ADDRESS THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
OUR STATE'S DIVERSE PATIENT
POPULATION. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT
DOES NOT REMOVE TECHNOLOGY OR
CLINICAL ALGORITHMS FROM HEALTH
CARE BUT RATHER EMPOWERS NURSES
AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS TO
CONTINUE WORKING FOR THEIR
PATIENTS BEST INTERESTS. RATHER
THAN BLINDLY FOLLOWING A
COMPUTER SYSTEM. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT DOES NOT
MEAN HEALTHCARE WORKERS WOULD
BE FREE FROM OVERSIGHT
MONITORING OR DISCIPLINE
CALIFORNIA HAS STRONG HEALING
ARTS LICENSING BOARDS THAT
OVERSEE THEIR MEMBERS. AND
DISCIPLINE SUSPEND OR REVOKE
LICENSES WHEN APPROPRIATE AND
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
CHANGE THE CROP OF THE
HOSPITALS WILL ALSO RETAIN THE
ABILITY TO DISCIPLINE A WORKER
FOR ENGAGING IN UNSAFE
PRACTICES. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT SIMPLY INSURANCE AT A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER CAN
DISAGREE WITH THE CLINICAL
ALGORITHM TO MAKE THE BEST
TREATMENT DECISION FOR THEIR
UNIQUE PATIENT WHEN IT IS THAT
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
WITHOUT FEAR OF PUNISHMENT FROM
THEIR EMPLOYER SOLELY FOR THE
DECISION TO OVERRIDE AN
ALGORITHM. AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
ALSO CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GREATER WORKER ENGAGEMENT WITH
TECHNOLOGY THE HOSPITAL. ASKING
THAT WORKERS BE NOTIFIED WHEN
NEW TECHNOLOGY AFFECTING THEIR
JOB IS BEING BROUGHT IN. THAT
WORKERS GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE SOME INPUT ON WHAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY IS SELECTED. AND
THAT EMPLOYERS PROVIDE ADEQUATE
TRAINING FOR THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. HEALTHCARE
TREATMENT IS NEVER A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL FORMULA AND STRONG
LABOR CODE PROVISIONS UNDER
THIS BILL WILL MEAN THAT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS PRIORITY CAN
REMAIN THEIR PATIENTS. FOR THAT
REASON THEIN I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR AYE VOTE ON
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. THANK
YOU. UP NEXT GEN- MAY. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE'RE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT ECHO THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS PRESENTING A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
MINORITIES IN TERMS OF SECTION
REYES HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
MORTALITY SOME BELIEVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE A
SOLUTION TO GUIDE CLINICAL
DECISION MAKING FOR THE NOVEL
TO FEES. RESULTING IN THE RAPID
DISSEMINATION OF UNDERDEVELOPED
AND POTENTIALLY BIASED MODEL
WHICH MAY EXACERBATE IT
DISPARITIES GAP. THERE IS HOPE
THAT AI CAN HELP GUIDE
TREATMENT DECISIONS WITHIN THE
CRISIS IT GIVEN THE
PERVASIVENESS OF. A FAILURE TO
PRACTICALLY DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES GROWTH EXACERBATING
EXISTING HEALTH DISPARITIES. AS
ANYONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE WITH
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM NOTE
EVERY PATIENT IS DIFFERENT
NURSES AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS
SHOULD ALWAYS BE EMPOWERED TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. AND FREE FROM
FEAR OF RETALIATION FROM THEIR
EMPLOYER FOR GIVING OUT WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE IT DOES. EIGHTY EIGHT
FRIDAY TO SOUND POLICY FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS RIGHT BUT
ALSO FOR PATIENT SAFETY. AND
SETS US ON A PATH TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ETHNICITY. ECONOMIC
STATUS. RECEIVE THE BEST CARE
FOR THEM NOT THE BATH CARE AND
DETERMINED BY A FORMULA OR AN
ALGORITHM. THE LABOR FED IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
LEGISLATION OKAY. THANK YOU.
I'M DOING HAVE MOVE ON A PUBLIC
COMMENT AND AGAIN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE FOLKS WHO STATE
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE BILL. OTHERS NO ONE IN
THE ROOM- ANYONE REMOTE TEST MY
STATION. IF NOT A MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
ON THE PHONE. Q. THE STATE'S
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT ON THE PHONE LINES PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN THAT
COMMANDERS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO WE'LL GO TO OUR LOAN LINE
THIS LINE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS THAT
THIS JACQUI GRANT WHILE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH UPW
AFTER DATE COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS. THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LINES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OF ALL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. DR JAMES LEO ON THE
PHONE AS WELL AS ALEX HAWTHORN
AND SO WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
START. WITH DOCTOR LEO. FEES
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
KALRA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DR JAMES LEO AND CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER FOR MEMORIAL
CARE FOR HOSPITAL INTEGRATED
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M A PRACTICING
INTERNAL MEDICINE AND CRITICAL
CARE MEDICINE SPECIALIST AND
HAVE OVERSIGHT OF CLINICAL
QUALITY AND EVIDENCE BASED BEST
PRACTICES FOR MEMORIAL CARE I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE STATE. MAINTAINING
QUALITY OF CARE AND SAFETY FOR
PATIENTS AND STAFF OF GUIDING
PRINCIPLES FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS EVERY DAY. WELL THIS
BILL SEEKS TO PROMOTE PATIENT
SAFETY AND WORKER PROTECTIONS
WE COULD IN FACT DO THE
OPPOSITE. WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT IS ON WARRANTED AND
REPLICATES EXISTING REGULATIONS
IN BOTH THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE. AND HEART
COLLECTIVITIES WITH HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
DECISION SUPPORT- ALREADY IN
PLACE. THIS BILL IS PREDICATED
ON THE IMPLICIT BIAS FOUND IN
AN ALGORITHM USED BY OPTUM INTO
FINDING OUT PATIENTS TO HIGH
INTENSITY OUTPATIENT CARE. TO
AN ALGORITHM THAT DEALS WITH
CLINIC PATIENTS NOT WITH
HOSPITAL PATIENTS. IF THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL HAVE
PAINTED HOSPITAL CLINICAL
DECISION SUPPORT TOOLS WITH A
BROAD BRUSH OF IMPLICIT BIAS
WHICH IS UNWARRANTED. THE
ALGORITHMS ARE TEENS DEVELOP
ARE BASED ON THE HIGHEST
QUALITY MEDICAL EVIDENCE FROM
MEDICAL LITERATURE. IN OUR
DEVELOPED BY A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF DOCTORS
AND HOSPITAL STAFF INCLUDING
NURSES AND PHARMACISTS. SECOND
THE ALGORITHMS WE USE TO GUIDE
CARE IN HOSPITALS ARE RARELY
PRO SCRIPTED AND NEARLY ALWAYS
ALLOW FOR INDIVIDUALS TO OPT
OUT WITH GOOD CLINICAL
JUSTIFICATION. IN THE RARE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH SUCH
CHOICE IS NOT OFFERED IT IS
BECAUSE OF PATIENT SAFETY
DEMANDS THAT. BUT EVEN IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE THE HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ALGORITHM
UP THE CHAIN OF COMMAND. OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM LEADERSHIP HAVE A
DEEP AWARENESS OF IMPLICIT BIAS
IN HEALTH CARE AND AN EQUALLY
DEEP COMMITMENT TO DISCOVERING
AND REMEDYING THAT WHEREVER WE
FIND IT. ALL BEST PRACTICE
TEAMS THAT DEVELOP WORK WITH
CLINICAL DECISION SUPPORT
PROTOCOLS ARE CHARGED WITH
EVALUATING KEY CLINICAL
OUTCOMES FOR RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES. YOU CAN ALREADY
INCLUDE REPRESENTATION FROM
HOSPITAL STAFF IN THE FORMATION
OF THE ALGORITHMS. EDUCATION ON
NEW ALERTS AND SUPPORT TOOLS IS
PROVIDED TO STAFF BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION. WHAT CHRONIC
CLINICAL DECISION SUPPORT TOOLS
HAVE BECOME A KEY METHOD FOR
HOSPITALS TO USE TO HELP SPREAD
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EVIDENCE
BASED BEST PRACTICE. THIS BILL
WOULD TAKE A GIANT STEP
BACKWARD IN QUALITY OF CARE BY
ENCOURAGING WHOLESALE REJECTION
OF CLINICAL PRACTICE GUIDELINES
WITHOUT ANY REQUIREMENT FOR
SUPPORTING SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
THIS WOULD CREATE A DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT FOR PATIENTS BY
ENABLING AN EMPLOYEE TO IGNORE
WITH IMPUNITY CLINICAL DECISION
ALGORITHMS AIMED TOWARD
PROMOTING PATIENT SAFETY AND
IMPROVE CLINICAL OUTCOMES.
HOSPITALS ARE LIABLE FOR THE
ACTIONS OF THEIR EMPLOYEES NONE
OF THIS BILL WOULD FACE THE
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE. OF ONGOING
LIABILITY FOR VIOLATION OF
PATIENT SAFETY RULES.
RELIABILITY FOR DISCIPLINING AN
EMPLOYEE WHO IGNORES THEM WITH
A CLAIM OF CLINICAL JUDGMENT
FOR THE ALGORITHM IS BIASED. IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON AB
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND ALEX HAWTHORN
ONLINE. THANK YOU YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR OUTSIDE OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THE FULL DETAILS OF OUR OPPOSE
POSITION ARE IN THE LETTER TO
BE SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE-
I WILL SEE THAT TIME THOUGH- TO
ARTS THE EXPERT WITH WITNESS DR
JAMES LEO AND I CAN HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THOSE
OPPOSED. NAME AFFILIATION
POSITION ON THE BILL THE ONE IN
THE ROOM. MOTETS TWENTY STATION.
MOVEON MISS MODERATED THE
EVERYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT ON THE PHONE.
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
THAT'S ONE AND ZERO. OVER THE
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX ONE THREE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
RIGHT VENTURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA PUT THE ATTIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN IS JUST
NINE WELL WE DIDN'T SUBMIT A
FORM OPPOSE WHAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS PARTICULAR TO
RETAIN TO THE FINAL WORD OF THE
OVERSIGHT APPROVAL AND THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF. TO THE FORTY
TWO YEAR DISCUSSION THAT THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND WE DO HAVE A
COMMOTION. ON THE FLOOR ALREADY
IS THERE ANY FURTHER COMMENT OR
QUESTION. THE CIVIC CENTER PARK.
RIGHT NOW PLEASE. I'M TRYING TO
GET  GRASP ON THIS BECAUSE
THERE'S A REAL WORLD
APPLICATION OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT- IT'S HARD FOR.
MEDICAL STAFF WE CAN'T LET THEM
GO RENEGADE ON EVERY SITUATION
HOWEVER WHAT I'M SEEING IN THIS
BILL AND I'M TRYING TO SEE IF
THAT'S THE INTENT. IS ALLOWING.
MEDICAL STAFF TO INNOVATE IN
IRAN AND TO THIS AS IN THE
FIELD- TO SOMETIMES. RECOGNIZE
THAT THE ALGORITHM ISN'T GOING
TO WORK. AN OPERATING BASED ON
THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND HAVING A
GOOD OUTCOME FOR THAT PATIENT
IS THAT WHAT THIS IS AFTER. HE
ADDED IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
REAL LIFE JACOB STANCE- I'LL
USE MYSELF BECAUSE WE WANTED
THINGS THAT WERE WORKING OUT
WITH CMA IS KIND OF THE
OVERRIDE DECISION WHO DEAL IN
IT YOU KNOW- YOU'VE YOU'VE BEEN
IN THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE IT'S
GOT TO BE ONE PERSON RISKS AT
SOME POINT SOMEBODY'S GOT TO BE
THE ADULT TO MAKE THAT
DECISION. SO I'M WORKING WITH
CMA AND THE NURSES TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT IS AMOS
COMMITTED SOME LANGUAGE- THE
DAY DID QUITE LIGHT BUT WE'LL
KEEP WORKING ON THAT- I'M A
DIABETIC. MMHM AND WHEN I WAS
FIRST DIAGNOSED BY DOCTOR HE
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE OF THE
ALGORITHM WHEN YOU GIVE ME
INSULIN- MET FOREMAN AND ALL
THE OTHER MARRIED OF THINGS-
AND I JUST REFUSE TO TAKE. ANY
MEDICATION TRIED TO DO IT.
MYSELF AND IT WASN'T WORKING TO
ONE DAY A NURSE WITH THE LAST
NAME DONNELLY WHOSE. BROTHER
USED TO BE THE LEAD TO TEN A
GOVERNOR GRABBED ME IN A ROW WE
START ARGUING IT SHE TOLD ME
WHAT TO DO. I LOST FORTY POUNDS
I'M OFF OF. INSULIN AND I'VE
CUT MY MET FOREMAN IN HALF FOR
THAT TEAM THE ONE THE ALGORITHM
THAT THE DOCTOR USED. TO KIND
OF LOOK AT ME AS A BLACK MAN.
WE SIR PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS.
NEED TO GET THIS KIND OF CARE
AND THIS KIND OF MEDICATION AS
OPPOSED TO. REGINALD BYRON
JONES SAWYER SENIOR. COULD DO
THIS ALTERNATIVE TYPE OF A-
REMEDY WHICH A NURSE OFFERED TO
ME WHICH PROBABLY SAVED MY LIFE
AND SO THIS IS WHAT THIS KIND
OF DOES IS WE NEED TO WORK AS A
TEAM SOMETIMES THE ALGORITHM OR
SOME TYPE OF THE DOCTOR SAYS
WORK SOMETIMES. THE NURSE WORK-
IN SOME WAY YOU MIGHT EVEN BE
ABLE TO AVOID HAVING A SECOND A
THIRD OPINION BY USING ALL
THREE IN THE SAME PLACE SO THIS
IS WHAT THIS GETS TO MAKING
SURE THAT. EVERYBODY'S WORKING
TOGETHER AS A TEAM TO GET THE
BEST MEDICAL OUTCOME. YEAH GET
THE KIDS I'M AN INCLINE
ALTHOUGH THERE IS CONCERN WITH
I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT IT-
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT I'VE SEEN OUT THERE
IN THE IN THE FIELD. AND WHERE
ARE YOU IN I CAN NAME ONE
PERSON WHO IS ALIVE TODAY
BECAUSE OF IT. AND THEN BECAUSE
WE ACT WE ACTED OUTSIDE OF THE
ALGORITHM. AND AND SAVE THE
GUYS LIFE TOOK A LOT OF CRAP
FOR IT I'M SORRY WHAT. YEAH WE
HAVE BEEN ULTIMATELY IT CAME
DOWN TO AND THAT WAS THE THING
IS YOU KNOW YOU WANT TO TAKE A
LICENSE YOU CAN BUT THAT GUY'S
ALIVE BECAUSE- WE THOUGHT OUR
FEET. AND SAVE THEM. AND SO
YEAH YOU KNOW THE DATA THINK UP
TO. THAT THE BIG ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THERE IS A CONTROL FACTOR
THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY. IT
CAN'T BE THIS FREE FOR ALL BUT-
WHERE EVERYBODY JUST KIND OF
DOING THEIR OWN THING OUT THERE
SO. SO ANYWAY- STRUGGLED A
LITTLE BIT BUT YOU KNOW I'M
INCLINED TO SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISHMASH- CAPELLA JUST
FOLLOW UP ON THAT BECAUSE- LIKE
AS- LIKE MEDICS IN THE FIELD
RIGHT WE- OPERATE UNDER SO PEAS
RIGHT UNDER A DOCTOR'S LICENSE.
RIGHT AND IF SOMETHING IS GOING
DIFFERENT WHETHER IT'S PAIN
MEDS OR OR WHATEVER CARDIAC
MEDICATIONS AT THE THIRD
MINISTRY. YOU CAN GET
PERMISSION YOU CAN CALL THE ON
CALL B. R. DOC AND GET
PERMISSION FROM A DOCTOR TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS. TO WHAT YOUR
RECIPES ARE WHAT YOUR ALGORITHM
IS BRIGHT. SO I AM STRUGGLING A
LITTLE BIT LIKE. IF THAT
ALREADY EXIST OUT THERE. IF WE
CAN ALREADY DO THAT WHAT WHAT
IS THIS WHAT WE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL
BECAUSE- PURSES CAN ALREADY
LIKE IF THEY SEE SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T LOOK QUITE RIGHT. THEY
CAN ALL RIGHT TO GO TO THE
ATTENDING PHYSICIAN SAY HEY
THIS IS. GOING ON IT SEEMS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
THE S. O. P. SAYS. SO I GUESS I
AM CURIOUS- IT ALREADY SEEMS
LIKE THIS IS IN PLACE WE JUST
MAYBE NEED TO EDUCATE. PEOPLE
DIFFERENTLY. FONG AND I'M NOT
I'M JUST CONFUSED I GUESS THIS
IS ULTIMATELY WHAT I'M SAYING
AT THE C. MAKING JUMPING BUT
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. THAT IS
NOT AS UNIVERSAL AS YOU YOU
WOULD. FOR DEMOCRATS AS A
PERMANENT DAY MAY HAVE ACCEPTED
A LOT OF THESE- METHODOLOGY BUT
NOT EVERY HOSPITAL DOES AND
WHAT THIS BILL. ADDRESSES ITS
EXACT WHICH YOU'RE SAYING HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY'S KIND OF FOLLOWING
THE SAME PROCEDURE STATEWIDE.
CADETS UNDER OUR PURVIEW MAYBE
IN YOUR AREA. EVEN WHEN YOU DID
YOUR PRACTICE WHEN YOU ARE OUT
THERE IN THE FIELD IT WAS SO
WELL BUT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
IT'S NOT MISLEAD THAT WAY ALL
THE WAY. AND IN RETALIATION
PART IS REALLY IMPORTANT COULD
YOU. YOU DON'T WANT TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE YOU. MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION AND THE NEXT
THING YOU LOSE YOUR JOB YOU'RE
YOU'RE DISCIPLINED. AND YOU'VE
SAVE SOMEONE'S LIFE. FOR SURE.
M. AND I THINK YOU MAYBE THERE
IS SOME DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIKE.
ATTICS IN THE FIELD VERSUS
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE CLINICAL
SETTING AND PROBABLY SOME
DIFFERENT DECIDED NOT USE THEIR
AS WELL YEAH- I AM I'M GONNA-
STRUGGLING WITH IT BUT I. IT IS
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME SEVEN
PROJECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
YEAH THINGS ARE GOING ON FOR
THAT THING TO. YOU KNOW THE-
TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING HIS
FATHER THEM'S DONE ONDERS IN
THE MODERN MEDICINE ESPECIALLY
GIVEN. THE PACE OF WORK. THE A
LOT OF OUR- NURSES AND DOCTORS
ARE UNDER THAT THEY HAVE TO
RELY. ON ON SOME OF THE DATA
AND SOME OF THEM AS YOU STATED
DECEMBER. YOU KNOW AS THAT. DID
TO GIVE A SENSE OF SETTING THE
STAGE CAN WHAT IS. THE WHAT
WHAT WHAT ARE WE DEALING WITH
HERE THEY CAN USE A LOT OF DATA
POINTS AND THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY. IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT WE
ARE. ALSO HAS SOME FAITH IN HIM
AND THOSE THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK THEY'RE NOT GONNA. GO
ROGAN ABANDON THE TECHNOLOGY.
ABANDONED ALGORITHMS- YOU KNOW
JUST FOR THE SAKE OF IT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO IT WHEN THEY REALLY
SEE A NEED TO. AND WE ALSO NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ALGORITHMS.
WILL PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC
BIASES. AND THAT'S A REALITY
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. COST BEING A FACTOR.
INCORPORATED INTO THOSE
ALGORITHMS AND SO ALL OF US
INCLUDING THOSE IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD I THINK THOSE THAT. SPOKE
IN OPPOSITION ARE VERY
EARNESTLY WORKING. ON ROOTING
OUT THE SYSTEMIC BIASES BUT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
AND THE REALITIES UNTIL IT
DOES. ALGORITHMS ARE GOING TO
INCORPORATE THE EXISTING
SOCIETY THAT WERE IN INCLUDING
THE DATA POINTS THE DATA THAT'S
BEING IMPORTED. OVER MANY CASES
MANY MANY YEARS- AND SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING- I
DO THINK THAT YOU KOW THERE'S
A COUPLE SUGGESTIONS THAT ARE.
IN THE IN THE STAFF ANALYSIS TO
TIGHTEN UP SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK THAT- YOU'RE GOING
IN A GOD DIRECTION- AND- IT'S
ENCOURAGING TO HEAR EVEN SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION. THE GROUP-
SPENT OVER WORKING WITH YOUR
WINE TO WORK MORE WITH YOU IF
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
GOING FORWARD. SO WITH THAT WE
DO HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AT MADAME SECRETARY TO
GROW ON A. BE A FIFTY EIGHT.
LOS IS TO PASS TO HELL
COMMITTEE. KALRA HI KALRA HI
FLORA. FLORA NOW BEEN. GONZALEZ
I JUNE SAWYER HI SAWYER I REYES
ZERO NINE ZERO I WARD WORD I.
RIGHT THE BILL PROPONENTS TO
HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE BITTER NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ. THAT'S WHEN
THE POLICE. THE BILL OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY ABOUT THIRTEEN
NINETEEN I'LL CREATE A
VOLUNTARY MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION OF WORKER
COOPERATIVES CALLED THE
FEDERATION THE FEDERATION WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT OVERSEE
COMPLIANCE WITH DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNANCE STANDARDS FOR WORKER
COOPS A WORKER COOPERATIVE IS A
DEMOCRATICALLY MANAGED BUSINESS
OWNED AN GOVERNED BY THE
WORKERS THIS ALLOWS WORKERS TO
CHOOSE THEIR OWN PRIORITIES
LIKE STRONGER WORKER
PROTECTIONS AND BENEFITS
INSTEAD OF PROFITS. HOWEVER THE
LACK OF AWARENESS OF THIS
BUSINESS MODEL AND ITS BENEFITS
HAS BEEN A MAJOR BARRIER TO
REFORMING WORKER COOPS NEW
WORKER COOPS ALSO FACED
OBSTACLES DUE TO COMPLICATED
STATE AND FEDERAL TAXES AND
ACCESS TO CAPITAL AB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN WOULD INCENTIVIZE
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP BY CREATING
AN OVERSIGHT BODY THAT IS
ITSELF WORKER GOVERNED. TO
SERVE AS A RESOURCE. I SHARED
ADMINISTRATION MANAGERIAL AND
OTHER FUNCTIONS AND COST BY THE
FEDERATION WOULD HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR WORKER CO OPS
OF ANY SIZE. AB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP TO SCALE UP WORKER
COOPERATIVES- THE WORKER
COOPERATION MODELING CALIFORNIA
WHICH WILL HELP MOVE THE STATE
TOWARDS AN INCLUSIVE AND
RESILIENT ECONOMY BY CENTERING
ON WORKER OWNERSHIP INVESTING
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES. I WITNESS
WITH ME TODAY MATT WITH A CHAU.
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS MATT WOULD SAY ABOUT
THAT YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA HERE
TODAY AT THE SPONSORS OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN- EIGHT- ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOB DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND- MANY OF THEM HAVE
NOT FINANCIAL FOUND THAT JOB
AGAIN- THIS IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR PEOPLE
LOW INCOME JOBS I'VE BEEN
REALLY HIT HARD TO STRING THE
ENDEMIC- WORKER COOPS OUR
PROVEN MODEL AND IN A GROUP AN
ALTERNATIVE- TO ALLOW WORKERS
TO BAND TOGETHER- UNDER
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES TO SHARE
IN THE PROFITS OF THEIR LABOR-
ALTHOUGH THEY'VE GROUP AND-
VOLVO WITH A PROVEN MODEL- SO
FAR THEY'VE FAILED TO SCALE UP.
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEX
TECHNICAL ASPECTS RELATED TO
FARMING SUCH- WORKER COOPS SUCH
AS- GRADING BYLAWS REGISTERING
THE CORPORATION NAME
GOVERNMENT- AB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN IS IMPORTANT STEP TO
HELP HELP CLOSE AN EQUITY AND
SPUR ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND BY
ESTABLISHING A FEDERATION THAT
WOULD PROVIDE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
TO NEW AND EXISTING CO OPT OUT
FOR THE THREE THAT THAT YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
NINETEEN TEN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I THOUGHT. THANK
YOU. ANOTHER WITNESS INTO NOT
JUST ONE I SAW CAN KEEP HELLO.
HUSTLER OF A COMMENT STATE NAME
FELICIA POSITION BILL ON THE
ROOM. MOTETS MONEY. MOVE TO
THEM MISTER ED IN SOME ON THE
PHONE OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY. Q.
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO. YOU HAVE
ONE LINE OF ME JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE.
AND ARE COMMENT TODAY
IS FROM NINE ONE EIGHT FIVE
POINT EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS JUSTICE SANDRA HOW THE
COURT THAT THE KIDS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN Q. OKAY. THE
NUMB BUT THERE'S NO- GLOBAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ANYONE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS ON HERE SOME
OF THE SAME ON THE PHONE AND
OPPOSITION. AB. THIRTEEN
NINETEEN. FOR APOLOGIST MUST
SHARE IT WITH A PUBLIC COMMENT
YES. THANK YOU WISH TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE ZERO
PLEASE. AN ONLINE THANK YOU.
OKAY THE VERY MUCH A BRING
ABOUT TWENTY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I'M A BIG FAN OF A
PROPERTY ISN'T REALLY LIKE THIS
BILL AND SO GOOD LUCK. WE HAVE
A WE HAVE A MOTION DO PASSED
THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE THE SUMMER WARS
SECONDED BY SUMMER JONES SAWYER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I JUST
WHY I'VE GOTTEN SO MANY PHONE
CALLS IN THE LAST TWO DAYS ON
THIS BILL AND I'M SURE PEOPLE
WHO DON'T. WHO KNOW ME AND
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING
ON OUR LITTLE FREAKED OUT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE BILL- IT IS ABSOLUTELY
VOLUNTARY IT IS. WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO ESTABLISH A METHOD BY
WHICH WE CAN- ALLOWED PER
WORKER CO OPS WHICH ALREADY
EXISTS BUT TO ALLOW- FOR MORE
OF THEM INTO THEM TO EXIST IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE AND TO
REMOVE SOME OF THE BARRIERS- TO
THEIR EXISTENCE. SO IT'S
NOTHING SCARY- IT'S YES NEW IN
A FORM BUT IN A WAY IT'S KIND
OF- SIMILAR TO IT YOU KNOW
MAYBE GO VISIT SB HOW WE HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES THIS WOULD BE.
AT AN EFFORT TO EXPAND AND HELP
WORK WORKER COOPERATIVES AS
WELL WHICH ARE FUNDAMENTALLY A
GOOD THING IN MY BELIEF SYSTEM
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I ABOUT. IT THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY FOR ALL THE
ROLE IN THE THIRTEEN NINETEENTH
MOTION IS TO PASS THE BANKING
AND FINANCE KALRA. I KALRA HI
FLORA. FLORIDA VOTING CONCERT.
HI IN. I JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER AYE RADIUS SEATTLE
NUMBER. ZERO NOT VOTING BOARD.
WARD HI. WHAT THE DOES NOT
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR HAVING
THEM THIS PURPOSE
. FOR ALL
RIGHT MISTER CHAIR PRESENTING
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
SURE PROUD TO PRESENT AB FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH REQUIRE H. TWO A.
VISA EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE ALL
AGE TO A FARMWORKERS WITH
WRITTEN NOTICE OF KEY STATE AND
FEDERAL EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS
INCLUDING INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS DURING FEDERAL AND
STATE EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS.
LAST YEAR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOREIGN FARM WORKERS
WERE EMPLOYED BY ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA GROWERS AND
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS UNDER
THE H. TWO A. FEDERAL VISA
PROGRAM. THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN
INCREASING ANNUALLY. HISTORY
FARMWORKERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO ARE
TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER. OF WHO PROVIDES THEM
WITH HOUSING MEALS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK SITES.
MANY H. TWO A. WORKERS HAVE
NEVER BEEN TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE
AND EITHER SPEAK OR READ
ENGLISH. THAT THEY'RE FIRED FOR
ANY REASON THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
IMMEDIATE DEPORTATION WHICH IS
A POWERFUL DISINCENTIVE TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT ANY ABUSE OF
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS THEY ARE
SUBJECTED TO. AB EIGHTY SEVEN
SIMPLY REQUIRES AGE TO
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE AGE
TWENTY. OF FARMWORKERS ON THE
FIRST DAY OF WORK. A SHORT
COMPREHENSIVE WRITTEN SUMMARY
OF KEY LABOR HOUSING AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS IN SPANISH. AND
REQUESTED AN A IN ENGLISH- THE
BILL DIRECTS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER DEVELOP A TEMPLATE
CONTAINS A SUMMARY. OF THE POST
ON THE WEBSITE FOR H. TWO EIGHT
EMPLOYERS TO USED TO COMPLY.
WITH THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT. AB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN CREATES A
SAFER LEGALLY COMPLIANT
WORKPLACE FOR H. TWO A.
FARMWORKERS. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS MUGSHOT
THE- DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION OF
CYNTHIA RICE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION. ADVOCACY AND
TRAINING FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR IN OF
MARCUS IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE I
FEEL FREE TO TAKE IT AWAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MARK
TUCKER CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL- THE BILL
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM FACED BY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF FOREIGN
CONTRACT WORKERS ENTERING
CALIFORNIA UNDER FEDERALLY
APPROVED JOB ORDERS. THAT OFTEN
INCLUDE TERMS AND CONDITIONS
THAT ARE LEGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW WITH NO STATE OR FEDERAL
AGENCY CHARGED WITH PROVIDING
DISSOLVABLE GETS WORKERS. WITH
AN ACCURATE SUMMARY OF CURRENT
STATE LAW RIGHT THAT EXCEED
FEDERAL LAW PROTECTIONS.
PROTECTIONS. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN VERY SIMPLY IS AN H. TWO
A. FARMWORKER RIGHT TO KNOW
STATUTES. THAT PULLS TOGETHER
INTO A SINGLE WRITTEN NOTICE
CRITICAL STATE LAW INFORMATION
REQUIRED THAT THE CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED TO BE GIVEN TO EACH
FARM WORKER IN SPANISH. ON
THEIR FIRST DAY OF WORK HERE-
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CONTAINS A
LIST OF THESE NOTICE PROVISION
BUT SEVERAL ARE WORTH
MENTIONING HERE- IN ADDITION
COULD BE UP. WITH THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE
DECLARATION OF A NATIONAL OR
STATE EMERGENCY DECLARED IN THE
COUNTY THAT THEY WILL WORK AT.
FOR EXAMPLE NO LAW REQUIRES
THAT IF THEY ARE INJURED ON THE
JOB THEY MUST BE GIVEN A
WORKERS COMP CLAIM WITHIN ONE
DAY. ACCLAIM FORM. DIRECTOR
REASONABLY SUSPECTED TO HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED TO PESTICIDES THEY
MUST BE GIVEN PROPER
TRANSPORTATION TO A MEDICAL
FACILITY. SENATE EVERY WORKSITE
BEARDED BIRD BE PROVIDED WITH
TOILET FACILITIES HAND WASHING
FACILITIES AND COOL POTABLE
WATER. DURING HIGH HEAT WORK
CONDITIONS THE SHOPPING
PROVIDED WITH TRAINING AND
PREVENTING. OF RECOGNIZING.
THAT ALL WORKERS IN FEW
STRAIGHT WORKERS SHALL BE PAID
TEN REST PERIOD. EACH FOR OUR
WORK PERIOD FOR THE WORKERS MAY
NOT BE CHARGED THE OLD HAPPENED.
TAKEN LOOK WE AGREE WITH THE
CHAIRMAN DEBTS AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN WILL CREATE A SAFER
LEGALLY FIRED WHAT PLACE FOR
EACH TWENTY FARMWORKERS. AND
MOREOVER REDUCING INCENTIVES
UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYERS MAY HAVE
TO HIRE WORKERS WILL MAKE IT
UNDER PAYING INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THE WORKERS DON'T UNDERSTAND
THEIR RIGHTS ARE HOW TO HAVE
BEEN. FORCED OUT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE ARRIVED SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CYNTHIA
RICE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA RICE AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE WE PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES TO RURAL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON REPRESENTING
FARMWORKERS INCLUDING H. TWO A.
WORKERS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE MANY OF THE H. TWO A.
WORKERS COMING IN ARE DOING SO
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE EMPLOYERS
CONTROL WHERE WHEN DID THEY GET
INTO THE COUNTRY WHERE THEY
LIVE. WITH THEIR ROOMMATES ARE.
AND AFTER EMPLOYER PROVIDED
HOUSING THEY ARE ASSIGNED A BUS
OR VAN AND A TIME TO GET ON IT.
IN THE MORNING AND ARE IN THE
FIELDS AND OTHER EMPLOYER SENT
A BUS TO PICK THEM UP AT NIGHT.
IN OUR H. TWO A. CASES WHEN A
WORKER PRESENTS THE PROBLEM IT
IS ALMOST ALWAYS JUST ONE OF
SEVERAL VIOLATIONS MOST OF
WHICH THEY HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT. AND OUR UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA LAW. THESE INCLUDE
UNPAID TRANSPORTATION TIME
UNPAID OVERTIME DENIAL OF
MILLER REST PERIODS UNLAWFUL
DEDUCTIONS. THE LACK OF SHADE
WATER AND NON COMPLIANCE WITH
OTHER HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AND HOUSING
STANDARDS. INCLUDING THOSE
RELATED TO CONTROLLING EIGHT
COVERED NINETEEN EXPOSURE. WHEN
WE EXPLAIN THESE RIGHTS TO
WORKERS ARE FRANKLY SHOCKED
THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED
PROTECTIONS AND ROBBED OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF.
DOLLARS TO PAY THAT THEY HAD
NO. KNOWLEDGE THEY HAD THE
RIGHT TO. THIS BILL PROTECTS H.
TWO A. WORKERS BY ENSURING THAT
THEY KNOW THEIR RIGHTS.
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO PAYMENT
FOR EMPLOYER CONTROL
TRANSPORTATION. WHAT OTHER
CONTRACTS IN PLACARDS ON THE
BUS OF THE STATE THAT THEIR
TRANSPORTATION IS VOLUNTARY IT
IS ANYTHING BUT AND THE FAILURE
TO PAY FOR THAT TIME IS WAGE
THEFT. THIS IS TACITLY
ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE GROWERS AND
FARM LABOR CONTRACTOR WHICH
WOULD SETTLE THESE CASES WITH
US. FOR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PAYING THE WAGES OF THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
TRANSPORTED BUT NOT PAID. THE
OPPOSITION CLING TO THE UNIQUE
FACTS SITUATION IN THEIR
OPPOSITION LETTER- I'VE NEVER
REALLY IN CASE AND DISREGARDS
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE CASE I
SINCE THAT CASE. THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS TO THE MORE
RECENT CASES. INCLUDING A CASE
WHERE AGE TO A WORKER TRAVEL
TIME ON EMPLOYER BUSES LISTING
COMPENSABLE AS THEY QUOTE DID
NOT KNOW WHERE THEY WERE GOING
AHEAD OF TIME AND HAVE NO OTHER
MEANS OF TRANSPORTATION. ENTITY
ALL KANTAR CASE BY THE COURT
APPLIED MAMMALIAN AND HELD THAT
IF AN EMPLOYER DETERMINES WHEN
WHERE AND HOW WORKERS COMMUTE
TO WORK. THE WORKERS ARE NOT
CHOOSING HOW THEY GET TO WORK.
AND THE TIME IS DEEMED
COMPENSABLE. THIS BILL NOTICE
TO ENSURE A. WORKERS OF THE
RIGHTS YOU NEED TO CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA LAW. AND
PROVIDES A BRIGHT LINE
CODIFYING THE FACTS THAT
ALREADY MAKE. TRANSPORTATION
TIME COMPENSABLE UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES IF WE CAN READ
FROM COVER. YES THANK YOU- AND
WE ARE JURAI ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE ROOM ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE ROOM. C. NINE ANYONE FOR
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
IT SEEMS NINE MISTER RADHA
RAIDER ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIX THANK YOU
ARE EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN. IT
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOR THE
FIRST TIME THIRTY FOUR THREE
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MATT
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEACHERS IN THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEY CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEGATIVLAND ONE EIGHTY FIVE ONE
EIGHT FIVE RELATED OPEN.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE EIGHT
SEVEN ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT'S A GREAT WELL
LET'S GET THE W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL ON STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BLIND ONE EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DOCUMENTARIAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANOTHER BOUCHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT. SIXTY FOUR LINE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIRTY THREE IF YOU ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AT THE
COURT. OUR LAST MINUTE QUEUES
LINE ONE NINETY ONE NINE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE ON FARM WORKERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK ARE NOT FOR
THE LINE SECURE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE WE HAVE
MATTHEW ALLEN AND BRIAN LITTLE.
MATTHEW. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATTHEW WELL THE
PLASTER GROWERS ASSOCIATION- IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL IN
MY COMMENTS TO THE TRAVEL TIME
SECTIONS- THE BILL. BUT IN
REALITY IT- EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
ATTEMPTS TO CHANGE THE- THE LAW
BY EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT'S CONSIDERED VOLUNTARY AND
MANDATED TRAVEL FINE. AT HAS
BEEN DECIDED BY THE CALIFORNIA
THING FOR INVERLEITH PERSONAL
ATTACKING IT YOU THOUSAND- AND
BY DOING THIS IT EXPANDS- THE
SITUATIONS WERE BY TRAVEL TIME
WOULD BEGIN TO BE. REQUIRED H.
U. H. TWENTY EMPLOYEE-
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL GO WELL
BE THE CORE DECISION. BY THE
CLIENT GET TIME TIME DEEP AT
REGULAR OF PAY- THIS IS NOT A
NOTICE- EXISTING RIGHT STEPS
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A TOP
TWENTY COMPLICATED AT NO LESS
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE- FINALLY-
AND ALSO. IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL
SIGNIFICANTLY MAYORS SB ELEVEN
OUT TO BUY CENTER BOMBING LAST
YEAR WHICH WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM- GONNA GET A
MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR DIRECTED
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO
DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN. THE
EMPLOYEE NOTIFICATION TEMPLATE
THAT WAS CONTEMPLATED IN THIS
BILL ABOUT YOU- AND WE BELIEVE
THAT AT THAT PROCESS SHOULD
CONTINUE AND- WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT- EIGHTY SEVEN SHOULD
INTERFERE WITH THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BRIAN
LITTLE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
BRIAN LITTLE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
ORGANIZATION OF FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. ACTUALLY OPPOSE AB
FIFTY SEVEN FOR TWO REASONS
FIRST IT OPPOSES NATO AND
COLLECTIVE NOTICE REQUIREMENTS
ON CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
PARTICIPATING THE FEDERAL H.
TWO A. TEMPORARY AGRICULTURAL
WORKER PROGRAM PETER PROGRAM.
PLEASE WORKERS ALREADY
RECEIVING ATTENTIVE WRITTEN
NOTIFICATION THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE ON THE FIRST DAY OF
WORK OF THEIR PAY WORKING
CONDITIONS AND BENEFITS ARE.
ADDITIONAL MEDICAL TO DUPLICATE
ONE PLAYER YOU ALREADY RECEIVED
AN EMBASSY FOR YEARS. SECOND
THE TEMPLATE NOTICE SPECIFIED
BY AB FIFTY SEVEN THIS
CHARACTERIZES THE CURRENT STATE
OF THE LAW REQUIRING THAT THE
NOTICE INCLUDE A MISSTATEMENT
THE TRAVEL TIME FOR EACH TO
EMPLOYEES COMPENSABLE PEOPLE'S
REGULAR RATE OF PAY. WHAT'S UP
WITH THIS ONE REQUIRES TRAVEL
TIME TO BECOME. NO LESS THE
WAGE. WHICH BOYS TRAVEL
INVOLUNTARILY ON EMPLOYER
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION.
FINISHED AND VETOED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY TWENTY
BECAUSE DETAIL THE SPECIFIC
NOTICE LANGUAGE PROVIDED NO
MEANS PREVENTING THE NOTION THE
LAW CHANGE IN THE FUTURE. AND
RECORD THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO DEVELOP
AN ACCURATE AND WORKABLE
TEMPLATE NOTICE. FOR THE
WORKING THE LABOR AGENCY IN
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS TEMPLATE
AND WE OPPOSE AB. FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING ABOUT REPUBLICAN AND- A
NAME AN AFFILIATION ONLY.
STARTING ROOM ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE. I AM A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION SEEN
NONE MISTER MODERATING ONE
OPPOSITION BY PHONE. STATE
OPPOSITION BY PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO.
FOR THE FIRST TIME THE LINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR ONE EIGHT FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION. AND THE GROWER
SHIPPER ASSOCIATION OF CENTRAL
CALIFONE CORNIA ALL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WE'LL
GO NOW TO LINE ONE EIGHT NINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. TRIMS A
CHARACTER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL UP CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. AFTER THAT WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHT THREE ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ACTUALLY
HAPPEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BORDERLINE ONE EIGHT ONE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MELISSA HI ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. IN OUR FINAL LINE IN
QUEUES ONE NINETY THREE ONE
NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MIKE
ABOUT WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION WHY GROUP GROWERS
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO OTHER
CLIENTS IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR I BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. CNN MISTER CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH
YOU KNOW WHAT I JUST SAID ON
THE VIDEO MESSAGE WE ARE
WORKING TO MINISTRATION TO
pDISCRETION TO CHANGE UPDATE THE
MODEL NOTICE AND THOSE WITH
CONCERNS THAT TO. BELIEVE FEEL
WILL GET RESOLVED. BUT IS THIS
BILL MAKES WAY FORWARD- AND
FINALLY JUST ON THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER SOMEONE IS VOLUNTARILY-
TAKING TRANSPORTATION NOT THE
THERE'S A REALITY AND THERE'S
A- THERE'S- THE DELUSION AS TO
WHAT. VOLUNTARY JUST BECAUSE A
PLAYER SUCH AS VOLUNTARY
THROUGH THE REALITY IS THAT
FORMER TALK ABOUT THESE FARM
LABORS- THE EMPLOYER PICKS HIM
UP TELL THEM WHERE TO BE WHEN
TO BE THERE. TAKE SINGLE
WORKSITE THAT THE WORKERS NOT
SO EVEN KNOW WHERE IT'S GOING
TO BE- AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY
OUR EXPERT WITNESS- BY
TESTIMONY. OF THE BUS SHOWS UP
AT THE END OF THE DAY TAKE SOME
BACK IT COULD BE. TWENTY
MINUTES AN HOUR AWAY FROM WHERE
THEY LIVE WHAT HAVE YOU BUT THE
END OF THE DAY. THE RECORD
DOESN'T HAVE THE CONTROL
THERE'S NOT A TECH WORKER AND
SEPSIS CRITICIZED WHETHER TAKE
THEIR TESLA OR TAKE THE GOOGLE
DUST ON THE MOUNTAIN THE OF.
UNDER THE CONTROL. OF THE
EMPLOYER AND SO- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND- CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON SOME OF
THE DETAILS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CLL
ROLE. WE NEED A MOTION A SECOND
SIR. THANK YOU. PLEASE THE-
MOTION IS DO PASSED APPROVE
KALRA HI ALL RIGHT HI FLOOR NO
NO GONZALEZ WHERE HI JONES
SAWYER IRATE HI RES I SIERRA NO
SIERRA NO REPORT FORD HI THE
FILM'S OF APOLLO MISTER. THIS.
THE LAST AMONG THE- LAUGHABLE.
PLEASE YEAH AB. SB SIX FIFTY
FOUR A MAN MAJORITY LEADER EVEN
HERE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF TODAY PRESENT TO YOU AB SIX
FIFTY FOUR WHICH INCLUDES
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO MY
PREVIOUS MEASURE AB SIX EIGHTY
FIVE THE FOCUSED ON THE BASIC
STEPS EMPLOYERS MUST TAKE TO
INFORM WORKERS OF WORKSITE
SPECIFIC EXPOSURE TO COPE AT
NINETEEN AND REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CREATE A DATABASE TO TRACK
WORKSITE. OUTBREAKS TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP TO THIS MEASURES THE
CENTRAL AND URGENT. TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO BE
TRANSPARENT WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS ON WHEN AND WHERE
OUTBREAKS HAVE OCCURRED. IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND IT SURE
THERE'S NO BURDEN ON HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES OF DUAL REPORTING.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IN A MANNER THAT WILL
STILL GIVE THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
CRITICAL INFORMATION. SB SIX
THIRTY FIVE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
CREATE A PUBLIC DATABASE. THAT
ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO TRACK
OUTBREAKS BY WORKPLACE. AND
INDUSTRY WHILE THE- DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS PUBLICLY
POSTING OUTBREAKS BY INDUSTRY.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN OUTBREAK
INFORMATION REPORTED BY
WORKPLACE. AS WAS NEGOTIATED
UNINTENDED IN MY LEGISLATION.
AB SIX FIFTY FOUR CORRECTS THIS
THROUGH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
FURTHERMORE AS NOTED BY MY
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL ON AB
SIXTY FIVE. I AM COMMITTED TO
AMENDING THE MEASURE TO ADDRESS
THE DUAL REPORTING CONCERNS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE IS JESSE GRAY WALL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR UFC W.
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL AND
MITCH STEIGER. LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AFL-CIO. THANK YOU
AND SO PER VIDEO PER THIS GREAT
OFFER READY MADE AGAIN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. WONDERFUL GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACKIE GRAY WHILE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH YES
HE W. AFTER A COUNCIL IF YOU
HAVE THE REPRESENTS AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE STATE
PHARMACEUTICAL AND RETAIL
SECTORS ALL OF WHOM HAVE BEEN
BEING FROM OFFENSE WORKERS THAT.
FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO THEM AND
LEADER FOR ALL HER WORK IN
PASSING EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU TO
ENSURE WORKERS THE MOST BASIC
UP FOR TAX DURING THE SEVENTY.
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY FOUR IT'S
TECHNIQUE CLEAN UP TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC DATABASE HOUSE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WHICH TRACKS OUTBREAK BY
WORKPLACE INDUSTRY IS
IMPLEMENTED AS IT WAS INTENDED
AS IT WAS NEGOTIATED AND I THAT
WAS VOTED ON BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND ADMIT LEVINE BY
THE GOVERNOR EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
FOUR MAKES A TECHNICAL CHANGE
TO ENSURE BETTER
IMPLEMENTATION. OUR WORKERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THE EXTENT
TO WHICH WORKPLACE OUTBREAK
THAT AFFECTED THEMSELVES THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
HEALTH EVERYTHING EXPOSE ON BY
THE COUNTY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
MISTRUST MARKET TALK ABOUT
THROUGHOUT THE- STATE NEEDS TO
BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT WORKPLACE
OUTBREAKS IN ORDER TO GAIN
WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC TRUST.
LASTLY THERE WON'T BE THE LAST
TEN THAT MAKE A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THE STATE THEY SAID
AND WE NEED BENEFIT THEM IN
PLACE NOW SO ON THE NEXT
ACADEMIC OR PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OCCURRED WE HAVE THE
RIGHT DATA COLLECTION AND
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES IN PLACE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'VE MISSED EITHER READY MAYBE.
THANK YOU THE CHAIR MEMBERS
SUBMITS WITH THE LABOR ALSO PRO
TO SUPPORT THE BILL BOB THE
AUTHOR AND PRETTY WITNESS
REALLY CA THE IMP POINTS WE
JUST WHAT AT QUICK ONES THE
FIRST IS THAT REGARDING THE
CARE. WE CAN OUR START WE CAN
TO KEEP WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE VERY NARROWLY TARGET
THAT EXEMPTION SO THAT WE FOCUS
ON THE WITH ANYTHING
DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BUT WE DO STILL
BELIEVE IT'S VERY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE FILTER
WORKERS DO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION AND THEN ALSO
WANTED TO JUST SAY THAT THE
BILL IS ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR HELPING WORKERS WITH
WORKERS COMP CLAIMS. GIVEN SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE LAST YEAR AND
THE OPERATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THERE IS ANOTHER
CHECK ON THAT SYSTEM SO THAT
WORKERS WHO ARE COVERED BY THAT
PRESUMPTION FOR THERE IS AN
OUTBREAK AT THEIR WORKPLACE
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION. IN ADDITION ALL
THE OTHER REASONS WHY WE DO
NEED THAT WORKPLACE SPECIFIC
OUTBREAK INFORMATION REPORTED.
YOUR SUPPORT AT THE PROPER TIME.
THANK YOU- IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM NO ONE IN
THE ROOM. NO TESTIMONIES
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FIFTY FOUR. THE STATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIX FIVE FOR ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
AGAIN MAUNSEL ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
MOBILEFIRST ONLINE THIRTY FOUR
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIRTY FORTY OF A POSITION ON
THIS BILL. YEAH FIVE ONE VOTE.
WE'LL GO WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN COME BACK TO THIRTY FOUR
SORRY ABOUT THAT THIRTY FOUR.
LINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SEP BRAMBLE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NOT BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION UNITE HERE
MACHINE IT UTILITY WORKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE ONE NINETY
FIVE ONE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF
THE TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OUR LAST
LINE IN Q. OF MIND ONE EIGHTY
FIVE POINT EIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JESSICA FENDER ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FOR THE
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
NOW WILL TAKE- COOPER WITNESS
OPPOSITION OF THE WE HAVE ROB
MUTRIE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU AND I KNEW JUST
APOLOGIZE AND ADVANCE I WILL
TRY TO KEEP THIS SHORT I'M NOT
FEELING WELL THE BY DISAPPEAR
QUICKLY MY APOLOGIES TO THE
COMMITTEE. BOB ROBERT MITCHELL
OPERA CAL CHAMBER AND WE ALONG
WITH A BROAD COALITION OPPOSED
AB SIXTY FOUR- TO BE CLEAR THE
BILL IN ITS PRESENT DOES ONE
THING IT IT REQUIRES G. P. H.
CRITICIZED THE CIVIC LISTED
EVERY OUTBREAK. BOB I HEARD THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED- BOARDING
DUPLICATIVE REPORTING WE'RE
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THEY KNOW
THEY OFFERS INTEREST NOT FRONT
THOUGH I SHOULD NOTE THAT YOU
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S TECHNICALLY
IN THE BILL PRESENTLY- OUR
POSITION IS BASED ON. TWO KEY
ELEMENTS ONE THE LIST UP BREAK
THIS BILL THEN BE CREATING WILL
NOT HELP PUBLIC HEALTH AS WE
READ AND TO. CHANGE BUSINESS
INSTRUMENT THEY CANNOT CONTROL.
TO THE FIRST POINT- THE
REQUESTED NOT SEPARATE GOOD BAD
EMPLOYERS DISTRACTIONS- TO BE
CLEAR EMPLOYERS EVEN THOSE UP
PERFECT COMPLIANCE EVERY STATE
LOCAL AND COUNTY GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT CONCORD NINETEEN. CAN
EXPERIENCE OUTBREAK BASED ON
THE CONDUCT OF THEIR EMPLOYEES
OUTSIDE OF WORK A PERFECT
EXAMPLE IS A FEW EMPLOYEES OR
CLOSE FRIENDS GO TO A DINNER
PARTY IN A WEEKEND. AND THEY
BELIEVE THEY ARE SAFE BUT NAY
THERE ARE SUPPOSED TO COVER THE
NEIGHBORING THAT'S THE
WORKPLACE THAT NOW BECOMES AN
OUTBREAK REGARDLESS OF WHAT ON
IT SENATE THE WORKPLACE ANYWAY
AND THAT LEAD TO THE EMPLOYER
BEING LISTED HERE BUT THE
EMPLOYER HAS LITERALLY DONE
NOTHING. WRONG WITH THAT MERRY-
SO WE ARE THE HAVE CONCERN WITH
A LIST WHICH WE VIEW AS- IT.
AND FRIGHTENING OFF CUSTOMERS
FROM. BY THANK. THE REASON YOU
DON'T BELIEVE THIS LITTLE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH- V. PROVIDED
RATHER TO. OF THE- DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE LIVE PROVIDE BY GPA
B. K. OUT. DATE AS TOO BIG.
WHEN IT OUT START AT- IN FACT
GIVEN THE TIME LAG JIM LOOK.
WILL REPORTING FOR COUNTY
PUBLIC DEPARTMENT EPA AND THAT
PROP. TIME WITH JIM SUCH. WILL
BY DEFAULT BE THE- BUT
CERTAINLY THE BELL TOWER. YEAH
TO DATE. UNETHICAL BECAUSE IF
THE HERE IS THAT MA'AM OF THE-
SHOULD BE ABLE TO KNOW. OUT IS
A- AND- IT. THIS LIST WILL NOT
HELP THAT UNLESS IT IS.
PRECISELY TO DATE IS NOT IN THE
BILL TO FOR THAT REASON WE DO
NOT THE ASSISTANT. HEALTH AND-
WE DO NOT SEE IT SEPARATING
GOOD AND BAD EMPLOYEES. THIRTY
THREE WE ARE POST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE'S NO IN THE
ROOM. SO WE'LL SEE. MOST STATE.
AND THE MOVE MR. OR ANYONE
OPPOSITE ON THE- TO. SIX FIFTY.
THIS SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX FIFTY FOUR AM PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO THE FIRST
LINE WHICH IS NINE ONE NINETY
FOUR ONE NINE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN
LINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ABBOTT MET. IN THE
CALIFORNIA FUELS INCONVENIENT
ALLIANCE. ALTHOUGH OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE NINETY EIGHT
ONE NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR KARAT MEMBER STATES PORCHES
ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS THE SENSATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE ACTING CHAIR MEMBERS PRESS
THOUGHT IT OFF FROM BEHALF OF
PUBLICLY INNOVATION SOLUTIONS
IN MANAGEMENT IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BY NINETY TWO NINE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBER TECH THE FERNANDO ON
BEHALF THE HOUSING CONTRACTORS
THE CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINE SIX ONE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CALDERON
MEMBERS AMY BLOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. PLAN ONE
EIGHTY NINE ONE EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOUR ACCOUNT
NUMBERS PROJECT MANAGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS BACK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETY SEVEN ONE NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
NINETY SEVENTY ONE OF STATE
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL.
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY LITTLE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ABOUT A LINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX ONE EIGHT SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS RYAN THE LANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR FINAL LINE IN Q. WAS LINED
ONE NINETY NINE ONE NINE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
MOTIONS. I REQUEST YES SERVERS
ARE- THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND ALSO THAT I
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT CDPH HAVE
YOU COMMUNICATED WITH THEM
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO EVEN
HANDLE THIS BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE IT HAS A REALLY QUICK- AS
SOME OF THE SPEAKERS ARE
POINTING OUT- IT NEEDS A REALLY
QUICK TURNAROUND. AND I HAVEN'T
FOUND ANYTHING IN OUR STATE
THAT HAS A REALLY QUICK
TURNAROUND AT THIS POINT. SO
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THEM ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY EVEN. HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF MAKING THIS TYPE
OF THING EFFECTIVE. IT WE HAVE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND
ALSO WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED. IT IF SOMETHING
HAS TO BE ADDED- BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN COMMUNICATIONS WITH THEM
SO THEY'LL HAVE TO THE HOT DEAL
RAMP UP TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
THE INFORMATION IS BEING
PROVIDED TO THEM IT'S A MATTER
OF PRO OF INCLUDING IT IN THE
REPORTING. I THINK. FRAZIER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
BILL FOR A YEAR NOW AND- I KNOW
THIS IS A CLEAN UP BILL BUT-
CURRENTLY. AN OUTBREAK AS THREE
OR MORE CORRECT. IN THIS STATE
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK ABOUT
LIKE NOT DICTATING WHAT PEOPLE
CAN AND CAN'T DO RIGHT I MEAN
WE LIVE AND LET LIVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD. THE
BUSINESS ACCOUNTABLE FOUR THANK
THE PEOPLE WHO OUTSIDE OF THE
WORKPLACE. AND THREE PEOPLE AND
WE HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS I MEAN
IN MY DISTRICT HAVE LARGE
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES MULTIPLE
FAMILIES MULTIPLE FROM THE SAME
FAMILY. IF THEY'RE HANGING OUT
AT A DINNER. OR IN THE BARBECUE
IN THE BACKYARD AND THEY BRING
IT TO THE WORKPLACE. HOW IN
GOOD FAITH AND WE HOLD THE
BUSINESS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE- I
THINK IT'S A HUGE CONCERN WE
HAVE WITH THIS BECAUSE- WHEN IT
COMES TO ADD IN MANUFACTURING
IT IS VERY COMMUNAL. BUT A LOT
OF FAMILIES THAT WORK VERY
CLOSELY TOGETHER. IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THAT THE BUSINESS
IS EXPECTED. IF THEY CAN PROVE
THAT THEY FOLLOWED STATE LOCAL
AND FEDERAL GUIDELINES TO
PREVENT THIS SO I DO HAVE SOME
MAJOR CONCERNS I WOULD LOVE IF
YOU COULD RESPOND TO THAT. THE
CAPSULE I THINK THAT WHAT. SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WAS ABOUT REPORTING
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
EMPLOYEE KNEW WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED. TO COVERT THAT'S
WHAT'S EXCITING FIGHT WAS
ABOUT. AND THEN IT WAS
REQUIRING THE EMPLOYERS TO
REPORT THAT SO THAT WE COULD
KNOW WHERE THE OUTBREAKS WORK.
AND AT THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH- COULD THEN FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO AT THAT
PARTICULAR EMPLOYERS LOOK
LOCATION. THERE IS NOTHING
ABOUT RESPONSIBILITY THIS IS
NOT TO SAY THAT. THAT THAT THAT
THE EMPLOYERS RESPONSIBLE OR
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COVE IT
IS JUST TALKING ABOUT. MAKING
SURE THAT THE THAT THE EMPLOYEE
KNOWS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED THAT'S IT. WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT MAKES SURE THAT WE
SAY IT'S INDUSTRY AND WORKPLACE
BECAUSE THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS
PUT IS WHAT. INDUSTRY
WORKPLACE. AND IF THE ALTHOUGH
AND IN THE ANALYSIS IT DOES SAY
AB SIXTY FIVE PROVIDED A
MECHANISM FOR DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH TO COLLECT. AND PUBLISH
COBIT NINETEEN OUTBREAKS BY
WORKPLACE AND INDUSTRY. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IT HASN'T
BEEN DONE SO WE WANT TO CLEAR
IT UP AND SAY WE ARE EXPECTING
BOTH INDUSTRY AND WORKPLACE.
THE SECOND PART TO THIS AND ONE
OF THE- WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
CALLED AND SAID THAT THE
LANGUAGE DOESN'T INCLUDE YET-
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
THE DUPLICATION AND THAT IS
CORRECT IN THE LANGUAGES AND-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WE
DON'T WANT. ANY OF OUR
HOSPITALS FOR INSTANCE THAT
ALREADY HAVE THAT REQUIREMENT
TO REPORT WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
HAVE TO REPORT TWICE. SO THAT'S
THE OTHER PART OF THIS CLEAN UP
BUT IT'S THOSE TWO THINGS ONE
IS. INDUSTRY AND WORKPLACE SO
THAT IT ISN'T JUST INDUSTRY ON
THE REPORTING BUT IT DOESN'T
SAY WHO'S RESPONSIBLE WHO'S NOT
RESPONSIBLE IT'S ONLY THE
REPORTING IT'S ONLY BE
GATHERING INFORMATION. AND THE
SECOND PART IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT REQUIRING ANYBODY TO
REPORT TWICE BECAUSE GOING TO
TAKE THEM TOOK TWICE AS LONG IT
MAY SEEM TO BE THE SAME REPORT.
BUT IF THEY HAVE TO INPUT IT
AGAIN IT WE DON'T WE THAT'S
UNFAIR TO THOSE TWO THAT WAS
LIKE MEDICAL FACILITIES AND THE
LIKE TO HELP THEM. PREPARE TWO
DIFFERENT REPORTS SO ONCE
SOMETHING HAPPENS RIGHT THERE'S
A OUTBREAK. AND THEY GET PUT ON
THIS LIST RIGHT WHAT HAPPENS
THEN. NOTHING IT'S JUST TO LET
THE COMMUNITY KNOW THAT THERE
WAS AN OUTBREAK THERE. AS TO
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE OR NOT
RESPONSIBLE THIS BILL AND MY
PRIOR BILL HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH WHO'S RESPONSIBLE IT HAS
TO DO WITH MAKING SURE THAT A
WORKER KNOWS THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED. AND MAKING SURE THE
COMMUNITY KNOWS WHEN THERE'S AN
OUTBREAK AT ONE OF THE WORK
PLACES IN THEIR COMMUNITY RIGHT
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IF WE
ARE GOING TO PRINT. THE NAME OF
A BUSINESS ON A- PUBLICATION
THAT THE COMMUNITY KNOWS. THIS
IS THAT CAN THAT BUSINESS IS
BAD THEY'RE GOING TO. A QUOTE
UNQUOTE BLACKBALLED FOR ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER EVEN THOUGH. IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY THEIR FAULT.
JUST LIKE THE COMMUNITY I WOULD
NEVER WANT LIKE INDIVIDUALS
NAMES BEING PRINTED RIGHT THAT
WOULD BE TERRIBLE. AT THE HIPPA
VIOLATIONS A LOT OF ISSUES WITH
THAT. ON THE SAME SIDE THAT IF
A BUSINESS IS FOLLOWING ALL
THESE PROTOCOLS IN DOING THE
RIGHT THING. I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE SOME PROTECTIONS IN
THE FORM BECAUSE IT'S NOT FAIR
TO HAVE THEIR NAME GETTING
PUBLICLY SHAMED. ON SOMETHING
THAT THEY CANNOT CONTROL NOW
THEY'RE BAD ACTORS THAT ARE
DOING NONE OF THIS. FAIR GAME
BLOCK OF I'M GOOD. AND SO IT'S
REALLY THE FOLKS THAT ARE DOING
EVERYTHING PROPERLY IN ORDER
THAT I'VE GOT MY CONCERT WITH
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR. ANY OTHER
CUSTOMERS WITH EMOTION. THE
BILL. OKAY SOLUTION A SECOND.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN A LOT OF LAST YEAR
IN THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC
FOR YOU TO GET A BILL TO GET
THAT THROUGH I THINK CRITICAL-
AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT BEING
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYERS THIS IS
ABOUT A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
AND MAKING SURE THAT THOSE THAT
ARE. BUT IF THEY KNOW IT OR NOT
AND YOU WANT THEM TO KNOW IT.
DOESN'T RISK ANDDO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. AND IT'S REALLY
ESPECIALLY A WORKPLACE IS
OBVIOUSLY A COMMON- A PLACE
THAT I THINK FOLKS SHOULD KNOW.
OF IF THERE'S BEEN ANY KIND OF
BREAKS THEN THEY CAN TAKE A
PROOF OF PROACTIVE STEPS. AFTER
THEY AVE THE KNOWLEDGE BUT IF
WE'RE NOT GIVING THEM THE
KNOWLEDGE. THEY CAN'T TAKE A
STEPS WOULD NOT DISTRACT
THEMSELVES UP INTO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND SO THAT'S WHY I
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS AND-
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY. FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY FOR CAN HAVE A ROLL
CALL ON A BASIS OF THE FOUR.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA. BY KALRA
HI FLORA. FLOOR NOW GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HIGHRADIUS HI I. SEE ART
OPEN. SEE I DON'T KNOW LORD.%
FORD I DON'T BELIEVE. THE BILLS
UP IN THE- BILL HAS OUT ON
THANK YOU A SUMMARY IN SEE OUR
TO WELL TO COME. THE NEW THAT
EARLIER BUT THANK YOU TO HAVE
YOU BOTH. I THEN YEAH MEMSIC OF
THE US METALS YES. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY- LET'S SEE GAINES.
AGAINST ALL RIGHT. THREE EIGHT
SIX EIGHT JONES SAWYER- BY JOHN
SAWYER HI. SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER HI.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR JONES
SAWYER- JONES SAWYER IRANIANS
FIVE RADIUS HI. AB ONE ONE ONE
NINE RADIUS RADIUS HI. AB TEN
TWENTY THREE RAYOS FIVE RADIUS
HI. AB EIGHT TO FIFTY EIGHT.
PRESS FIVE RAAS I. AB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN RADIUS RADIUS I. WE'RE
GOOD SIR EVERYTHING CLICKED
REALLY GOOD OKAY THANK YOU
RICHARD THANK YOU.